Unmute!
Yippee!
Yay!
Hey guys!
We're all unmuted now!
I've been silenced.
Silenced.
We're all unmuted now.
Okay, we were actually discussing strats because we finally got the achievements and everything.
But I guess like...
So I guess like a small introduction of all of us so people would know who we are.
Because we have someone that's not a VTuber here in our ranks.
Like our little imposter right here.
Oh, that's that smell.
Who I also forced to make the server.
Beautiful.
Sherfer, why don't you introduce yourself, Sherfer?
I go last because I'm the special one.
You're the special one.
Okay.
Alright, so hello guys.
I'm Doki aka DokiBird.
I am the captain but I made Sherfer make the server as the captain.
That's me.
That's just pink strats.
Yeah, I'm just like outsourcing.
Alright, who's next?
How's it outsourcing when I'm part of the team?
And then I invited you to the team.
Who's next?
Well, you're the captain.
Okay, I'm the captain.
But I said I'm last.
Okay, Shy Lily.
Don't talk back to the captain.
Yeah.
How dare you.
It's three against one.
I know, right?
I got hands.
What?
You said three versus one.
I got hands.
Shy Lily has hands.
She has 3D.
I got loads of hands.
None of you are freaking real.
How do you know if you're real?
None of you are real.
You can't hurt me.
How do you know if you're real?
Yeah.
Because I can turn on my webcam.
Whoa.
AI.
My immersion.
Oh, yeah.
Nice immersion break saying you have a webcam.
Maybe I just put it on my feet, man.
Oh, that's...
That's some cryo stuff right there.
Whoa.
For free?
For free.
What the heck?
Alright, alright.
Shy Lily.
Your turn.
Introduce yourself.
Oh.
Hi.
I'm Lily.
Hey.
Hi, Lily.
What is this?
AA?
This is some AA shit.
Hi.
I'm Lily.
I'm addicted to Pal World.
Hello, Lily.
Understandable.
Have a nice day.
My condolences.
Do your parents know?
Oh, the f...
Then what this own me?
What the heck?
No, of course not.
Shh.
Don't tell them.
Alright, who's next?
Guys, don't be shy.
I'm last, though.
We still have to talk about our achievement stuff later.
We can't spend ten minutes on this.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
I'll go.
Uh...
My name's PP UFO, slime alien, VTuber in a human suit except for all the times when I'm not in a human suit.
I'm a gremlin with a heart of gold.
Just don't ask me where I got the heart or the gold.
Nice to meet ya.
PP.
Yeah, I got that small PP energy, though, because I'm like 153 centimeters tall.
Well, not very tall.
I have decided that this is your nickname.
I'm sorry, but you are PP now.
No, it's acceptable.
Understandable.
Have a nice day.
Just how it works.
I don't know, man.
You've now been dubbed PP to the rest of the world.
Hi, I'm PP.
Nice to meet you.
Alright, last but not least, the flesh tuber.
Okay, I have a name, you know.
Yeah, but you haven't introduced us, so how would we know?
Yeah, picked by your parents.
I'm just the flesh tuber.
Hi, I'm Surefour.
I used to be in Overwatch League Pro.
Now I just stream.
Also known as the RP guy, the BattleBit guy.
League of Legends guy.
Congratulations.
Now the Power World guy.
Do your parents have a name?
My legacy, the gritty guy.
Oh yeah, the gritty guy!
Oh!
Yeah, he can do a mad gritty.
Anyway, so while we were muted, we were discussing about the achievements.
We were discussing things before then.
Yeah.
Which was very relevant to our stream, right?
Guys?
Relevant to mine.
I like the achievement.
I don't know if my mods...
made a command for it.
But basically, Surefour is going to be our power leveler.
And then that's our strat, basically.
That's all we decided.
Wow.
That's the strat.
That was sick.
So we have a power leveler.
Yeah.
We got this far.
Anyway, so are we doing...
Were we doing the global achievements for day 2?
For the extra multiplier?
I think we just do whatever we can do.
Yeah, pretty much just do whatever you can do.
I think like...
keeping track of who's caught what is going to waste time.
So I guess just kind of...
Just do whatever and we'll kind of collect whatever we've done at the end.
The only time we need to do stuff together is for the group achievements.
Yeah.
We'll be there for that.
The group one was like take a team photo in the wildlife sanctuary.
And then with the reincarnated guy.
And then...
We had to compete in the ravine grotto dungeon.
As well as the mountain stream grotto dungeon.
Where the fuck is that?
I don't know where the fuck those are.
Yeah, I was going to say where the fuck are these places?
I have no idea.
You're the one that linked the interactive map.
I'm thinking about putting her...
The what interactive map?
Oh wait, I mean the...
The what map?
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm just like we already have a hype train.
Here's my contribution.
The what map?
If there was a map though, you should probably hide all the things.
And then...
And then just pick and choose what you'd want to show up on.
Sorry, I mean the...
The pal world map.
Sorry.
The official in-game pal world map.
The official in-game map.
Sorry guys.
How can you use that when it's hidden until you've explored it?
What?
Woah!
Explore everything.
Yeah, as long as we explore everything, it'll be fine.
Right?
Yeah.
It'll be okay.
We can figure this out.
Right.
We're not exploiting anything.
We barely know how to play this game, let alone exploit it.
Like...
So I think how it's going to work with the base is that if I'm gonna have you doing power leveling, that I'm probably just gonna work on resource management, and just checking in on where stuff is.
And in the meantime just trying to level myself.
Okay, and then Lily and I, we're just gonna exist.
We are just next to the island.
I'll do the level up the chicky P to level 30.
I'll work on that.
I'll only use a chicky P to fight.
Good freaking job.
I'm gonna put our face by the desolate church where they've got the ingot like vein.
Wait, who wants to catch five humans?
Who wants to do that?
No, you're in base duty.
You're the only one that knows what to do.
Raiders show up.
That's where all the buff men show up.
That's true.
You can cook the meat too because that's the base thing too.
How many steaks do I have to cook?
Just one?
Yeah, the mammoth steak.
Oh, mammoth steak.
I think surefour is the one that needs to fucking kill a mammoth.
You're the power level.
You're gonna be the closest to catching one.
It's true.
I'm being forced to do so many things.
What do you mean?
Power levelers!
When they say level up a chickpea to level 30, do they mean from one or do they just mean like have a chickpea and it be level 30?
No, it says level up a chickpea to level 30.
I mean, you can probably catch like a level 29 chickpea level up once.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
But I feel like by the time we find a level 29, I think we can just level it up by that time.
Fair enough.
I think.
There's like global one was like make a clip where all teammates are petting different pals of the same element.
Does that mean like all of us petting like water type or like one of us petting water type?
I didn't even fucking pay attention to the global ones.
Oh shit.
There's like breeding as well.
The Anubis and the...
Yeah.
Oh, Diremope with three.
I don't know how the breeding things work.
I didn't really get into breeding.
Oh, hey, if you...
Each person like the amount of pals we catch is points per person too.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
One of them is the Direwolf with three move speed passives.
I had that.
That's just fast as fuck.
So I guess for the first hour, I guess all we should really do is like catch, catch, catch.
Yeah.
And like try to move towards where the base is going to be, which is like...
If you have a mental map...
Yeah.
It's going to be like in the red.
Red area.
All right.
I don't know where...
The red area towards the tip of one of those arrows.
I'm pretty sure it's like towards the south end of the red and yellow area.
All right.
So basically, I don't know where the fuck that is.
So I'm just going to...
I'm not mentally...
So mentally...
It's by the Desolate Church.
It's too bad they don't have a search function on the map.
Yeah.
It's too bad.
We're going to just explore that together until we find it.
Right?
Yeah.
For sure.
Also to my chat, is everybody sounding okay or is anybody too quiet?
My sound guy is AFK.
I have no idea.
We're all okay.
All right.
Anyway.
So we got our plan, right?
We are...
Oh, fucking hell.
All right.
Hour one, just catch.
Just pump through.
Catch.
Yeah.
All right.
Nice.
As long as our goal...
Go.
...is not last.
Even if we're last place, we get $500.
So that doesn't really matter in the end.
Let's go.
Yippee.
In the end, even if we're last, $500.
Sheesh.
All right.
I boosted up Lily's volume just in case.
Oh, yeah.
I should boost...
Yeah.
It sounds great here, but I'm looking at the little thing on OBS and it doesn't look great.
Man, I'm trying.
Okay.
I'm trying.
Push it up.
Every single sub is coming right to me and it's being unbelievable.
All right.
I look decent.
Put up the gain.
Just put around 200% on Discord.
200%.
Yeah, I did.
That's what I did.
Yeah.
I wish I could turn up my shit more, but I have so much background noise if I do.
Like, I have no...
My set-up is super scuffed, and like, my set-up is super like beginner streamer.
Yeah.
How long are you been streaming?
A couple of years.
Wait.
What is your graphics card?
It's...
It's in there.
It's a graphics card.
All screamers are lazy.
Screamers only do things when they have to.
That's true.
The moment when her PC dies when she upgrades.
I wouldn't be surprised.
She's still using a 60Hz monitor.
Are you using a 60Hz monitor, Huli?
No, no, it's...
60Hz monitor, mouse acceleration on, what's a DPI?
It's surely more than that.
It's surely... when was the last time you bought a monitor upgrade?
It's been a couple years.
Have you ever... actively gone to your monitor settings and then changed your refresh rates yourself?
You're so bright, Nivs!
Okay, so you're on 60Hz.
She's on 60Hz.
I'm not bad at any FPS games, I just have a 60Hz monitor.
It's not my fault.
Oh, I'm actually... yeah, it's not my fault.
Well, so the thing with 60Hz is you're living in blissful ignorance until you realize...
Yeah, that is so true.
Until you realize...
Once you see the light, then you can never go back.
Once you see the light, you get blinded by God and you can't go back.
I'm not sure if I want God to flash me, to be honest.
Well, it's like a really good flash.
Yeah, it's like a flash that's in your memory forever and you can never...
Just one time and then you're gone forever.
Yeah, and then you can never go back.
You're like, if anybody else flashes me, it won't be the same.
It's true though, my friend is like a pro Valorant player and they came over to my house when they were visiting and they wanted to use my computer.
And I was like, what?
No, no, they turned on... they were like desperate.
Your friend is God?
No, they turned on my stupid monitor and they were like, wait, is this 60Hz?
And I was like, yeah.
And they had gone like two weeks without and they were like, what's another two weeks?
And then they just walked away.
I was like, are you kidding me?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Damn.
Well...
It's that bad, huh?
Check your Hertz right now.
I know.
How do I do that?
Go to your monitor... go to your monitor desktop.
Do display settings.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Desktop?
Right click on your desktop.
Yeah.
Right click and then do display settings.
And then... and then I forgot what to do next.
Okay.
Oh my God.
And then scroll down until you see advanced display settings.
Advanced display.
Yeah.
And then go to your monitor.
What is the refresh rate?
It says 60Hz.
Called it.
Now go to your refresh rate.
And see if you can change it.
Wait, what should I change?
Any number higher than 60 doesn't matter.
Also, I hit 120... 143.
You hit 144.
Wait, that's like a legit monitor then.
Yeah.
Yeah, so what happened is Shiloh probably bought the monitors like six.
144Hz.
And then it keeps getting to 60Hz the whole time.
Bro.
See, now you're like...
Now you have no excuse for your FPS playing.
Oh, everything turned dark.
Help.
Oh, no.
We're broken.
No.
Oh, wow.
Whoa.
I see no difference.
There's no way you see no difference.
Well, she's not even in any game yet.
Of course she says no difference.
You can see it with the mouse cursor.
What's different on my mouse cursor?
Wait.
It's smoother.
It's more smoother.
Yeah, because it's not 60 frames now.
It has more... it has more...
It has more...
it has more...
Whoa.
It's smoother.
That's why I hate 3D cartoons, man.
You're never gonna get me with that.
The human eye can only see 30 FPS.
I fucking... I fucking hate that comment so much.
It's like, why are you always complaining about frames?
We can only see 30 frames per second.
Dog logic.
All right.
They're apparently checking settings now.
Cheer for you.
I'll show that to people.
Oh.
Yeah, don't worry, Team Captain.
I'm...
I've already been on it.
Whoa.
You gotta...
Gotta remember to scroll slowly so we can verify all settings all the time.
And just scrolling up and down because they don't know if they're looking or not.
Alright, here we go.
I can't wait to start this... this PAL World adventure with all of you.
Yippee!
I can't wait to be dead, Wade.
Me too!
Dude, I've played so much but I've played so casually.
You know like when you play Animal Crossing and you're like, this is nice.
And you go visit your friend's island and it's just like fully terraformed and you're like, Wade, what the fuck?
Okay, what's easy to do that?
Is this a bad time to admit that the PAL World base building contest was mostly based on aesthetic?
Yes, because I saw you on the competition and I was like, you know what?
This person seems to know what they're doing.
Gotta...
It worked, it worked!
Someone lied on their resume when I was looking.
Looking for players.
When you show up to your job and you don't know what you're doing.
Oh my god.
I came in with the confidence of a guy.
Like a 30 year old white guy at an interview.
And then she had all these vouchers underneath her and I was like, you know what?
People are vouching for... surely she knows what the fuck she's doing.
People are vouching for her.
Like, she knows, surely.
No, I do, I do, I do, I do.
But I also make it look nice.
Okay.
We don't care.
There's no points in whether or not it looks nice.
Okay.
Alright, I'll abuse the pals.
That's what my caption wishes.
I'll abuse the pals and I'll make it ugly as well.
Which face has the most aesthetic...
There's no... which face has the most aesthetic face.
They should have that.
They should have it.
We should ask them to make a rule just for us.
Put that in there.
Just for us.
I like how some of my chat, when people attack the base they'll be in awe of how nice it looks.
Exactly.
They're like, whoa, this looks nice, what the fuck?
They're like, oh my god, we can't attack that base.
Oh my god, look at how much work they put into it.
Wow.
See?
Yeah.
You get it, see?
We understand.
We just get it.
Alright, let's see.
I think they haven't even checked us yet, please.
Please.
We just want to join the survey.
Do they come in here?
Do they just randomly come in my stream?
I think they just look at your stream because it says just scroll up and down until it happens.
Until it happens.
Just get in and out until it happens.
I'm all tabbed right now until they tell me something.
We're voice number six.
How long does it take to get to six?
Yeah, you said this would be fast, huh?
First time.
Oh my god.
Please, we just want to play PAL World.
Let us in.
Oh my.
They should give us names for creative pet names too.
By the way, some PALs at the beginning that will be really, really useful.
If somebody can get that like Tom Bat cat thing, that would be really, really helpful.
If you can bring that to our base, that would be really great.
Okay, why am I being pointed out again?
Because you're power leveling.
It spawns at night in like the starter area.
But like mostly like towards like the bottom of this one hill.
You see, this is exactly why I got you.
You already know where people spawn.
I already played like three days of PAL World when it first launched and then I was done.
I have a hundred and twenty hours in the game, but I also let my chat backseat a lot.
I mean, that's the point.
That's the point of streaming.
Why the fuck would you do it for yourself when you can just have them backseat?
Why won't they verify me?
Dang, you sound so desperate.
Stop trying to get verified so hard.
It's kind of cringe.
I'm so fucking lonely.
I just want the touch of an admin.
All host verified so hard.
Dang, he's desperate.
Dang, this Discord kitten really be out here purring.
I'm not a kitten.
Silence kitten.
No.
Admin master hasn't approved your presence yet.
Oh my god.
All host verified.
Start the world and share the code with your...
We're not even verified yet.
We're not verified yet.
Well, it's not against me to verify it.
Please let us in.
Verified by the way.
It's okay.
Please.
We've been looking at the same achievement list for so long.
I just like the mental image of like, okay, once you start the world, you better stay in the cave area though.
Don't walk away from there until we start the timer, okay?
How would they know?
Okay.
Oh, that's sure.
God damn sure where you baited me.
I thought they talked in their chat.
Vegeta and Piccolo not big fan of the...
What the fuck is this?
Can this be our team song?
Can this be your team song?
Yeah, link it in the team chat.
All right.
Oh god, I need to make sure that people don't hear this.
What?
Let them hear.
Vegeta needs to speak.
It was parent-child.
Mental advisory.
Explosive content.
Look up Vegeta and Piccolo not a big fan of the government rap.
There you go.
This is our team song.
This is the song.
My chat was like, let him speak.
What the fuck?
Let him speak.
I am not...
I am not supposed to be letting my chat hear.
It's saying we're starting in five minutes.
How do I know if I'm verified or not?
We don't even have characters yet.
How do I ping an admin?
I need at least ten minutes to make a campaign.
Come on.
I gotta get that aesthetic.
Admin.
Help.
Am I verified?
I gotta hide the screen for a second.
The world name is Among Us Island.
Nice.
Join multiplayer game.
Alright, give us the code, surefour.
I'm closing the thing.
And then I'm...
Look at that.
Finalized.
Where the fuck do I get the code?
What do I click?
We're...
Okay, this is bad that we're all so very confused right now.
Wait, did you send the code in the voice chat?
I don't know where the code is.
Oh shit.
Okay.
I don't remember.
It's been so long.
It's been so long since I played this.
I'm customizing my character real quick.
What the fuck?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
My Discord crashed.
No!
Goodbye Discord.
Okay, I need to make a new browser apparently.
Since my Discord crashed.
It's not one of your achievements, bro.
Don't worry.
It should be fine, right?
No, it's not fine.
Okay.
Don't worry.
It'll be fine.
I think we need...
Oh my god.
Why are you not showing up?
I'm not showing up on Discord.
What?
I think we need the IP address and then a password or something.
I don't leak my RP.
Well...
No.
Three minutes.
Three minutes until timer starts!
I guess that's the end of this team.
Team Doki Bird is over.
Where do I get the code?
I don't fucking...
Google it.
I don't fucking know.
Check the invite code for this world on the options screen after starting the game.
Okay.
Google it.
We only got three minutes!
One, two, three.
Calm down.
Counts down from 180.
Nah, it's chill.
I think a minute isn't gonna make much of a difference anyway.
We're gonna get okay.
A minute is a pretty long time, okay?
Yeah.
What the fuck are you talking about?
It makes all the difference!
This is a serious update!
I'm posting the invite code in the team chat.
It is available for everyone now.
Yay!
Oh, okay.
But also the timer starts in three minutes, but we don't start starting.
Okay.
That's not a problem then.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, so I can't fix my Discord, Fugi, so nobody will know who's talking now.
I'm so professional.
It is I, Fugi's mom.
Hello.
Alright.
Do we have our code yet?
Okay.
I posted it.
What the frick?
Okay.
How do I join?
Wait, what's the IP?
We don't need the IP.
You go to the code one.
Oh, there's a code one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It wasn't working for us.
It was in the first week, so I hadn't used it before.
Oh, join multi...
Oh my God, there's a code.
That's what we've been saying, team captain.
Wow.
Team captain?
You didn't even know Jack shit.
Team captains are known for their leadership.
You didn't even know what was going on.
Alright, character build, speed run.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
Okay, cuz I have changed the hat color.
Alright, I'm gonna show people the game now.
Alright.
That looks like me.
30 on 30.
Okay.
We're not allowed to leave the starting area.
No.
We're stuck in our cages.
We'll be fine.
So many constraints.
When will I finally be free?
There you go.
In like two minutes apparently.
Oh, then I can talk about drugs?
Yeah.
Complete.
I'm getting my hair color.
I'm alive.
I'm good to go.
Okay, I might need to look a little bit more healthy.
Roger, Dodger.
Alright, there we go.
Make sure it's thick.
The towers are the key to the treeholds.
Wait, this game has lore?
I did not know that.
You have 150 hours on this game.
What do you mean?
I just thought it was like pew pew pokemon.
Wait, the timer started.
Wait, the timer started?
Wait, I'm not even in.
You guys have to get in the guild first.
Oh my god.
They started the timer.
Wait, how do I skip this?
Everyone hold F on me.
I'm holding F.
F on the tower.
Oh my god.
What the heck is going on here?
Accepted.
We're so thick.
I'm missing one.
Accepted.
I think we can all just go now.
Where's our base?
Figure it out, motherfucker.
What do you mean?
We're a team.
Timer starts.
I'm power leveling.
Okay, goodbye.
I'll give you 10 wood.
Alright, guys.
Let's punch this Mammorant out.
We all punch it together.
It'll be fine.
We can just punch him and keep respawning, right?
That's an exploit.
That's true.
We all just keep punching it.
Eventually.
We don't even have balls to catch it.
Like, what's the point?
Alright.
We just need his mead.
Where are we building our base, PP?
Well, first off, go ahead and start making yourself some balls.
I'm making a workbench right here.
Alright.
I'm just gonna punch you.
I'm gonna punch this lamb.
Oh, I need a chicken so I can level it to level 30.
Yeah, you can fight one Mon first so you get to level 2.
Level 2!
Level 2 time.
Nice.
I'm level 3!
And then you can start catching people.
The fuck?
How are you level 3?
What do you mean?
Is our power leveler not leveling up?
Wait, what should our stats be?
Oh my god, level 4!
Hell yeah!
Go to technology, unlock pal spheres.
I know, but what stats should we bank on then?
For right now?
Yeah.
For right now, if you die, just go to this one.
But our stats, though...
Oh, stats?
Depends on what you're maxing.
I'm gonna do work speed and weight.
I think I'm gonna do stompie nomie nomie.
I'm gonna do a weight for now.
Oh shit!
This rock isn't real.
What do you mean it's not real?
I can't punch it.
It'd be faster if I actually just got it.
I'm just gonna fucking fuck you.
Alright.
Alright, how do I need...
Wood and stone.
Ah fuck.
Alright, punch some rocks.
Look at us go, we're so efficient.
Shepard, what level are you now?
Our power level.
Uh, 32.
Damn, wow.
By the way, if you need to build a bench, you can deconstruct it and get the materials back.
I hit level 2!
What do you mean?
I hit level 2, we're level 3 and 4!
Wait, what do I need?
I need, uh...
I need more stone.
Alright, let's see.
Take that back.
Wait.
Wait, I needed that.
This is our power level.
Give me my rocks!
Hey, can you build that workbench again?
Wait, what happened to our workbench?
Wait, what's our team name?
What the heck?
Vegeta and Piccolo.
Right now it's our name too.
What's that as an acronym?
VPHTG.
Basically what we're gonna do is, we're gonna work our way towards where we're gonna set up the base and just catch shit along the way.
Sounds good.
Just head towards Desolate Church.
If you get lost, just, uh, you know, ask the gods where it is.
Ask the gods?
Alright, no problem.
Ask the gods.
Yes, the gods.
Let me tab out real quick and ask the gods.
That's crazy.
Guys, I can't ask the gods if I'm in-game.
I'm just saying.
The gods can't know I'm sitting playing Power World.
Yeah, the gods can't know I'm playing it.
It's blasphemous when you're playing Power World.
What the heck?
No, gods, don't look.
Gods, don't look.
I'm sorry, it's not Pokmon.
Don't look.
Legally distinct Pokmon.
Let's see.
Work speed.
Am I close to- Oh yes, nice, I can build an axe too.
Oh yes, nice, I can build an axe too.
Don't say the P word, the lawyers are coming.
Power has been in development for like two plus years.
If Nintendo couldn't stop it before then, Nintendo can't stop it now.
True.
Valid based drill.
Preach.
I need more stone.
Crap.
Nice, I can catch a chicken now.
Alright, where's my chicken?
The chicken's gonna be my only pal.
I don't even know if the game volume is like okay.
Just a team of chickens.
I'm sure it's fine.
I need to make my pickaxe.
Alright, there we go.
Why the fuck is there another fucking- Oh shit, I'm- Also, don't forget to get wool.
Otherwise you're gonna freeze to death at night.
So kill some of the little sheep.
Nice.
I'm trying to remember how to throw a pal spear.
Murder is wrong.
Murder is wrong from our pal leveler?
That's a problem.
That's a problem right there.
I don't kill, I capture.
You capture humanely?
Yeah, ethically.
Is it an ethical capture?
How do you know it's ethical?
Is it free range?
Yes, it's free range.
One of the global events is we have to get 20 humans and put them in the viewing cage.
Oh yeah.
Oh wow, that's neat.
I love that.
I mean we had to catch like five of them earlier too.
Oh my god, my chicken is level five!
I'm killing all the chickens!
Alright, let me- Some free points are just flying around and getting max lift monk energy or whatever the fuck it is.
Oh shit, I mean, I could do that.
I'm surprised lift monk is not a goal.
There's like 400 of them on the map.
It's a global goal.
It's a global.
So do we have to catch all of them?
If you get level 10, you get like 150 points.
Oh, okay.
Oh, so all of us have to do it technically.
I mean, the gods would be able to help with it, but I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, the gods.
The gods.
But I can tell you, I got to level 10 doing that and it was a lot of fun.
It took me like 10 hours, so I don't know how worth it is.
Yeah, yeah, we could totally do that in like 8 hours.
You just get a flying pet and then fly around.
You have to max it up.
My little chicken, go do your job.
Oh my god, there's a chicken rolling down.
No, don't get distracted by treasure.
Why do I always do this?
Treasure!
Are we doing okay?
I can't even tell.
We're doing great, right?
Are we doing okay, guys?
The first hour is going to be a little rough.
It's okay, I still have my chicken here having a great time.
We're good, we're good.
Yeah, I can tell it's having a good time.
I can see its health dwindling.
Yeah, yeah.
Minus 20.
He's doing great, he's doing great.
I'm going to get the gumara so we can have seeds.
So we can plant.
There's so many dead animals on the ground as I'm walking.
They all spawn next to us.
Which is great.
Alright, get over here.
Wait, where is our base going to be again?
Our base is going to be...
Keep walking.
Do you see the tower in the distance?
You're going to walk towards that.
And then you're going to turn left.
Okay, I see it.
Get over here.
Oh my god, get the fuck over here.
There you go.
Everything will be fine.
Yay!
Alright.
Where's the...
Do you guys have another bench down there?
Or no?
You can just build and disassemble.
Oh, okay.
Look at that.
This is why you're on my team.
This is why you matter.
You matter.
That's a way to put it, I guess.
Finally!
You are an asset to this company.
See, parents, you were wrong.
Look, mom, I'm madder.
I'm doing it!
See?
I'm not a disgrace being a 2D anime girl.
We have literally been slaughtering everything.
I just saw one of the little wooly guys and I was like, Oh, I'm going to fight him.
Dead.
Literally dead.
That's the fourth one.
Nice.
Should have killed them faster.
Alright, chicken.
Go fight, chicken!
Riot?
Great asset.
Go fight.
Nice.
Go, chicken, go.
I should have had the lift monk right at the start.
That's fine.
Nice.
My chicken's level 7 now.
That's right, I only have worthless pals right now.
Where are the penguin pals?
Don't we need that for like...
Kind of near base, actually.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, is this the base?
Uh, are you already up there?
No.
Oh, wait, this isn't the base.
Sorry, I got a little lost already.
Alright, grab stuff.
Nice, free items.
Yeah, I'll try to get to the base ahead of everybody else.
My little chicken.
I'm sure I don't end up over encumbered.
I like being cucumber.
I don't know what... I'm gonna name this chicken.
Wait, how do you name your pals?
Uh, in the menu.
In the menu?
Can you press F on them or something?
If you go to your party, you can name them.
Oh!
Okay.
I'll name you...
How do I name it?
Where the fuck is it?
Can I just go this way?
Where the fuck do you name it?
Maybe I can just go this way.
Also, there's an egg.
Oh, yeah!
Pick up eggs!
I just picked up... Yeah, I picked one up.
Oh, there it is!
That's the best way to get good pals without being in a high level area.
Okay.
If you don't have space, just get rid of the small ones before you get rid of the big ones.
Don't worry.
I have so much space right now.
Oh my god, there's so many of them.
There's so many dead pals here.
I wonder who did that.
Who did that?
That's crazy.
Holy shit!
I wonder who did that.
Everywhere I go, I see dead pals.
You know the official Pal World YouTube channel posted that short about cooking lamb bells?
Yes!
I saw it!
I was like, ah!
The creator does Pokemon versions too.
Oh my god, watch the Pokemon versions.
The versions are like more fucked up.
I love how like, Pal World people are like, yeah, we want them to make something for us.
Do me next!
Yeah, me, me, me!
Nintendo, this is what we've been asking for all these years.
Nintendo would never.
I wanna make normal sandwiches.
I wanna make Pokemon sandwiches.
Oh, me too.
What would be the tastiest Pokemon sandwich though?
Wait, what's the wagyu of Pokemon?
Isn't there like a cow Pokemon?
Milk tank?
I don't think...
Yeah, Taurus, Taurus!
No, Taurus would be...
Yeah, but he would be chewy.
He's got too much muscle.
Taurus?
I bet it'll taste like jam.
I feel like legendary...
Wait a minute, I'm a slime, I can't agree to that.
I feel like legendary Pokemon would be like the most juicy.
Cause they're like aged really well too.
No, no, cause like you know how like the older they are, the more aged they are.
It's not about the juice, it's about the mouth.
It's about the marbling.
Yeah, but wouldn't like legendary Pokemon have like really good marbling?
If you think about it.
Since they're legendary.
You gotta think about the one with the most like fat on it.
Wouldn't that mean Chansey would be the most delicious one?
No, cause then there's also Slowpoke.
Maybe it's just Fluffy.
Snorlax!
No, Snorlax!
Wait, Snorlax's tail is good, right?
Oh, Snorlax!
He doesn't move!
But then it's mostly fat though.
But wouldn't it mostly be fat?
It's gonna be hard to get lean meat from Snorlax.
Maybe he can combine Pokemon.
You can use his fat to like fry another Pokemon.
Oh, true!
Like use his fat to make bacon.
If you think about it.
What is the bacon of Pokemon?
The little pig.
The little fried pig.
He can fry himself too.
Cause he's fire type.
Tee pig?
But they're hard to breed.
You don't need to...
I mean...
They're like too rare to be the bacon of Pokemon.
Depends on whether you have Nintendo online.
Cause if you have Nintendo online, then...
Every time you go to the mystery trade, all you're gonna get is...
Nintendo online.
Someone says Lechon.
You're free to play or pay to play.
That's the question.
Alright, I'm placing our Pell Box.
Give me one second.
Okay, I wanna move over just a little bit.
So I can get the trees as well.
I need to get more...
Balls.
This is maybe the best I'm gonna get.
My chickpea's level 9 now!
Look at him go!
No, I think it should be further over.
Where am I?
Is this me?
This is me.
Alright, I'm heading over to our base.
Okay, building it now.
You should be able to fast travel once I finish it in 5 seconds.
Oh, oh yeah!
Fast travel!
Almost forgot.
Head to the...
Alright, set.
Alright, build a wooden chest.
And deploy a Pell.
Lucky as I have a human.
Wait, you caught one already?
Nice!
Oh my god!
We just need 19 more.
We need to build our little...
Four more.
No, but four of them has to be level 10.
Oh, but I guess we could power level them.
To be level 10.
Do we have to catch them?
Do we have to catch them at level 10?
Or do we have to power...
Do they just have to be level 10?
I don't remember.
How are they gonna know?
Watching our streams?
No, what the fuck?
Seriously, we have to sit through this bullshit?
What?
Our mods...
I did not consent to be tracked.
I didn't accept the cookies.
Yeah, we didn't consent to be like...
Moderated in a tournament.
What the fuck?
Are you trying to tell me?
It's an invasion of my privacy.
Watching us right now?
That's fucking illegal.
Oh, I should grab some iron.
Alright.
We're base level 2.
Shoddy bed, primitive workbench.
Alright.
Oh no, my weapon!
I have a damaged weapon.
Do we have a repair shop in the base?
I'm about to build it.
Not yet though.
What do you mean by shop?
Someone just asked me how I get rid of being wanted without dying.
I don't know.
Just don't even witness, man.
Just don't look.
It's that easy.
Close your eyes.
Tell me about how much you're wanted.
That's kinda cringe, bro.
Uh, stone and wood.
I need supplies.
If you can put supplies in the chest, I can search for more stuff.
Alright, here's some meat.
Here's some wood.
Some rope.
I'll put the eggs here too.
I need to build a shoddy bed.
Which means that I need infrastructure.
Oh!
A raider!
Oh, we're already raiding?
Damn!
That's fast.
Okay.
Alright, I'll put some wooden foundation here.
Oh, we can catch them!
Let's catch these guys!
Let's do it!
Okay, I don't have any...
Okay, here we go.
Let me make some balls right now.
Balls.
I need more wood.
If anybody has an abundance of wood, if you can bring them back to the base, that'd be great.
I can bring some back.
In the meantime, let me assign some pals.
Oh, here they come!
Here they come!
Oh, shit!
They're really fucking cute!
They're not even the good ones!
Yeah, but they're cute though.
They got the gamer hoodie.
They probably bring gamer subs.
Probably their entire blood.
Alright, alright.
Let's get ready to chill.
Alright, there you go.
Aw, they're not even the humans!
What's the point?
They'll cut these trees for us.
I already forgot what the achievements are.
I just...
Well, most of the day one achievements are just killing the field bosses.
Oh, they are?
Okay.
A couple of pictures and...
So we just all power level one level one and then just...
We are gonna be base level three.
I think you have to only get to base level seven.
That's what the screenshot said.
Really?
Okay.
Oh, it's twelve.
It's twelve.
The screenshot showed seven.
I got to seven in about an hour yesterday when I tested it.
Oh, that's... I think it's twelve because I think the screenshot is just to show you guys.
And be like, this is how you take a screenshot.
What are you doing here?
This is how you take a screenshot.
If you guys didn't know what it looks like, this is how the screenshot thing looks like.
I'm gonna...
I need the...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I can get piggies.
They farm ore really well, the piggies.
Let's see...
Repair bench... are you making repair bench or am I making the repair bench?
I can make it just one second.
Okay, JK, I made it.
That works too.
Here we go.
Nice.
Let me repair my fucking pickaxe.
I'm gonna make clothes.
Because I'm still naked.
Oh yeah, it isn't even night time and we're already at this point.
This is actually really good.
Making pretty good time.
I should not put this so close.
I forgot how finicky everything is.
Nah, burn it down.
It's all good.
Put it down.
Alright, I need...
Oh, I still need two cloths?
Do I make...
You should fast travel probably back to the start area.
That's the fastest way to get wool is to kill the lambs.
Yeah, I just need to make into cloth.
No, it's cool.
I forgot you can make cloth with wool.
Nice.
Now I'm not naked anymore.
Yay.
It's almost night time.
I got my clothes on.
Once it hits night time, if you guys can try to catch the flying bat thing.
We can use him for mining.
The tombat.
I have one mining pile.
I have the rush boar.
Oh, the rush boar is good.
Yeah, rush boar is nice.
Yeah, you can just put it in for now to mine the iron.
Puts the fire right next to the wood structure.
It's fine.
What's gonna happen to us?
What's the worst thing that can happen?
Let's see.
Oh yeah, I need to go fight Chilit so I can get ancient points.
So I can get us a Gankubator.
Oh.
Alright.
I need to be like level 15 for that.
So I'll have to go level at some point.
Yeah, go power level.
Or somebody with a high level who unlocks it can just build it as well.
Surefour, what's your level?
I'm level level.
You're level level?
Are you in range to fight Chilit yet?
I need fucking like arrows and shit for that, motherfucker.
You don't need arrows.
You can one man it.
Yeah, I bet you.
You're a gamer.
Yeah.
Well, yeah, I'm gonna one man it, of course.
Yeah, but are you trying to say you're not good enough to do a vote?
No, I'm saying I'm working on things.
I said I'm working on things.
What are you working on right now?
I'm working on building a tower.
I'm making nails so I can send them to a merchant so I can get millions of dollars so then I can buy arrows so I don't have to craft them.
Why don't you just craft it?
Because it takes two fucking years!
But we have the ingot ore.
You don't have to make...
The ore is gonna be easy.
Getting ingot is gonna be easy because of our base location.
Exactly.
Just skip arrows.
Just go straight to gun.
Yeah, just go straight to gun.
Okay, wanna give me a freaking gun then?
Ah shit, I forgot to make clothes.
You're gonna need a gun for it.
From where?
We're not in America.
If we're not in America, how do all these other people get guns?
Alright, tell me where the closest fucking Walmart is.
I'll get a fucking pump.
You live in Central?
You know where the closest Walmart is.
How do I transfer that into Palworld?
Turn your webcam on.
While you go to Walmart.
There you go.
Easy.
I forgot we all have to catch some to get the...
What is it?
The...
Extra points.
The registered points.
I think you can just drop...
Like give pals to other people.
Oh my god!
Yeah, that's so smart!
You can!
Just put them in the base.
Yeah, and then we just pick it up and grab it.
It's registered.
That's actually so smart.
Yeah.
I don't have a tombad yet.
But I have boar.
In box.
I'm gonna put...
I have duck.
If you take one from the base, it'll register in your thing.
But it doesn't register as a first catch.
So you can still get the bonus EXP.
I'm only leveling stamina and carry weight.
Alright, I put a...
Do you need a penguin?
I have penguin and a duck.
You got a fuck?
Yeah, I got a fuck.
Oh, he finished the cloth.
I got unused stats.
He finishes but cannot acquire.
Alright, I'll put it in.
Oh.
Alright.
I need to make myself an outfit.
My motherfucker's tombad.
I can't see.
It's so dark.
Yeah, I got the...
If you have the fire pal, it's really useful.
Oh shit, you're right.
You're so smart.
Sometimes my brain cell hits the corner.
And it's really far.
You just have your one big breakthrough.
I do shit myself in the process, but it's okay.
Awkward silence.
Ruminating.
It's okay.
You matter.
Don't worry, Lily.
Yeah.
Silence can be a beautiful thing.
Maybe I should just go back to the game.
Maybe I should just shut the fuck up sometime.
Who knows?
Oh, wait.
The presser can also mine.
I can't find tombads yet, but...
Okay, that's fine.
We'll find it eventually.
Oh, also, if somebody can get an elk, like that blue and purple, like, shiny elk looking thing.
That thing helps with wood.
Alright.
We're not at that point yet, though, so no rush.
Just gonna... let's see.
Why do I want to go back to base?
I don't even remember why I'm here.
Where are you?
I'm at the base.
I am bringing the presser.
He's dead, though, so I have to put him in the box.
Oh, yeah, I wanted to build more balls.
Okay.
Balls time.
I mean, we're making good progress.
Yeah, we're doing good.
I think.
We're only, like, less than 30 minutes in, so we're doing good.
Oh my god, look at us go!
Like, we gotta be doing, like, alright.
Yeah, right?
We can't be last, right?
Right?
I think we're base five now.
Is there achievements for the towers?
Yeah, there is.
Wait, let me look at the achievement list.
Base five.
Achievement report.
Where the fuck is the achievement link?
Where?
Okay.
I'm gonna go to the chat for you so they can respond to chat while you're doing things in the game.
Yeah, and that's PP's mod!
It's not my mod!
Do you know anything about multitasking?
Okay, faction tower.
Yeah, 20 points per team.
And then, like, one is 20, two is 60, three is 150, four is 250, and five is 350.
I need one palladium fragment if anybody's got one.
I got one.
Okay, let's see.
I'm in base.
Okay, just drop it in a box.
You must defeat a boss where all team members use a fox spark with a weapon.
Last hit with a fox spark using a unique skill.
Oh, we have to do a thing where we all have fox sparks.
Alright, I'm gonna build the...
Is that a global event or a day one event?
It's a global.
Yeah, so we can do that, like, whenever.
On day two, yeah.
We had to catch five lamb bell at the same time using traps.
How the fuck?
I guess we all just...
I don't know.
Someone that knows how traps works can do that.
When do we unlock traps?
What level is that?
We already unlocked it.
Then I guess we have to build that at the starting area.
How
the fuck?
Everything is so dark.
You pathetic fox.
Work harder.
Yeah, tell him.
Build that dictatorship to podium.
Grab some more palladium fragments.
More balls later.
I need 20 palladium fragments.
To do the next two things I gotta build.
Oh, okay.
I can grab some now.
Just put 40 in the box.
We need 11.
Oh, okay.
Cool.
Then we're good.
We're good then.
Oh, wait.
Let me repair my shit.
Nice.
I don't see a tombat anywhere.
I saw a daydream.
It spawns near the second waypoint.
Near the Mammoth Forest.
Oh, okay.
Alright, I guess I'll go back then.
Oh, no.
No.
It's daytime now.
Oh, yeah.
Right.
Let's see time.
We have a repair bench?
Yeah, it's at base.
Yep.
Am I blind?
Maybe.
I guess so.
What the fuck?
It's okay.
We all have one blind spot.
I don't.
I am the blind spot.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
You're perfect.
I'm perfect.
I can't fucking see.
I'm pretty sure your chat can figure out something that you're not perfect in.
Oh, yeah.
For sure.
They're gonna say everything.
You think your chat's lying?
Yes.
Why would you say your chat's lying?
They know everything about you.
They only want to see me in pain.
And you're not cultivating a good chat.
Listen, it's not like a YouTuber chat where everyone's super nice and will die for you, okay?
Is that true, chat?
Is that true?
What?
What kind of chat did you cultivate?
I cultivated a base chat who's not afraid to say their opinion.
Oh.
No.
Wait, then their opinion is true then.
Unless you're trying to say...
Are you gonna take that, chat?
That's what they are.
Their opinions.
They're opinions.
Not all...
But are you trying to say every opinion your chat has is wrong then?
No, I'm saying every opinion is an opinion, Doki Bird.
Yeah, yeah.
So are you trying...
Do you know what an opinion is, Doki Bird?
Yeah, but then...
It could be right or wrong.
So you're trying to say...
that their opinion is wrong.
If it doesn't agree with me, then I permabanned them.
So you're censoring them?
Yeah.
Whoa!
That sounds like...
I run a dictatorship out here.
That is a PAL World gamer right there.
The truth will eventually come out.
What truth?
Surefour chatters.
You come here to say your truth.
Speak your truth.
Say your truth here.
This is a safe space from Surefour.
My place is a safe space.
You literally said you censored people.
Rarely.
It's just the option is there.
That's the auto mod.
I didn't do that.
You have to establish dominance every now and then.
Someone in my chat was like, he was mean to me.
Good.
Run.
Hey, there's the city.
There's the town.
Get over here, Life Monk.
Oh my god.
He's a monster.
He's running so fast.
Okay.
Get over here.
Stone pit logging site.
Yes!
We're finally at the stone pit logging site!
Alright, cool.
Am I high enough level?
That's a question.
Foxpark, please.
Shoot him.
I don't want to chase this lift monk for like 20 years!
Please!
Do you think I can put the logging site on top of a tree?
Or is that an exploit?
Cool.
You can try it out.
Ask for forgiveness, not permission.
That usually goes.
I never told that Natsu.
Oh, sick rocks.
That's true.
Please.
I've been trying to kill this lift monk for like five minutes now.
He's always running.
Look at this.
I'm too lazy.
Yay!
Okay, we need to be level 24.
Somebody needs to be level 24 for us to get base level 12.
That's the last recipe is at level 24.
I'm working on it.
24, okay.
What level are you at right now?
Once we get to that point, all we need to do is do material management to get it to level 12.
Alright.
But we probably need to catch more stuff.
I'm working on it.
What level are you right now?
We're almost there.
I'm 10, I think.
Close, close.
I'm 13.
I'm 11, sorry.
Yeah, let's go Lily!
We're here!
Let's go!
We're doing our part!
It took me like five minutes to catch one lift monk, but I'm doing my part.
We're getting it.
Okay, let me build a ranch.
Because then we don't have to make pow balls anymore.
Yay!
But how much do those actually make the balls?
When it's split between four, not great.
But I can make two ranches.
If I get enough wood and stone.
Ram ranch.
What do we need the most right now?
Right now, we need both wood and stone.
Oh, okay.
I'll just do wood right now.
Rock and stone.
Might as well just cut some wood.
Pitch tree.
Punch tree.
Do any of my boards do...
Okay, we're okay.
What do you do?
You do mining.
Mining away.
Okay.
I don't know what's left to mine, I mine in anyways.
Oh my god, I can do Minecraft plot covers now.
We only need level 20.
Oh nice.
Fuck these trees.
Alright, I'm gonna go level 20.
I'm gonna level up a little bit.
Oh shit, I'm two.
I'm slowly walking over.
Mining diamonds.
Don't worry.
I'm worrying.
I'll be the lumberjack of the team.
I just really enjoy walking around punching pallets.
Wait, did you not make a weapon?
I do have a weapon.
Oh, your fist.
My fist is made out of steel.
I got two.
Arkas are surprisingly very strong.
What the heck?
Why are my fists too slow?
I just wanna beat up this green squirrel.
Yeah, that was me too.
I gave up halfway.
That's alright, the back bonus is surprisingly effective.
You're gonna bane him?
What?
You're gonna bane the squirrel?
Yeah, I bained him.
Damn, that's fucked up.
I had to do it to him.
Why were they running?
So they... die?
What the fuck?
They just die in snow and that's kinda judgmental.
That's kinda judgmental.
They don't know anything about me.
I can be really nice.
You're trying to beat up a squirrel.
Does that sound like a nice person?
I'm the nicest person here.
You are not the nicest person here.
There's some dudes down here.
Maybe my hands just wanna talk, man.
I'm gonna catch these guys.
I'm mining.
Alright.
How many people do we already have?
What do you mean?
We have one people.
One people?
Hopefully we're about to have more people.
Yeah.
I will catch people too.
Alright, we got another person.
We got another one?
Yeah, let's catch another one right now.
Nice.
We're doing our part, Lily.
I don't get a gun.
People catching!
Woo!
This is what we wanted, Nintendo!
This is what we wanted!
I wanna catch Professor Oak.
Yeah, but Nintendo will never do anything because they're too big.
I feel like Nintendo's main revenue is just merchandising at this point.
It's not even Game Dev.
I got the police after me!
It's okay, let me just get this person.
I just want this person.
I punched him into a rock and now I can't get him anymore.
And I can't.
No!
Kill him!
What do I do?
What the fuck?
Well, there goes my only Powerball.
Anyway, there's a guy down here in the rock.
If anybody has a Powerball and wanna catch him, I'm right here.
Wait, where is he?
Right down this hill.
I'm out of balls.
I got him out of the rock though.
And he's ready to catch.
Okay, I'm trying to find...
Oh, I see you.
I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
Help me!
I'm coming over.
Five nails.
My knight in shining armor, where are you?
Coming over.
Don't worry.
I went the wrong way.
I'm coming over for real now.
Is he still there?
Yeah, he's still shooting at me.
Oh boy.
Just live.
Help!
Don't worry.
Wait, where in the world are you?
Did I go the wrong way?
I don't even see your name on the map anymore.
Don't worry.
I'm going the right way.
For real this time.
Oh, okay.
I see.
I think.
I'm here.
Don't worry!
Yeah, you're coming.
You're coming.
Help me!
I'm right here!
Hello!
I feel like Boar is gonna fucking kill him before I catch him.
Okay.
Alright, you have to hit him in the head because he doesn't technically have a hitbox.
There you go.
Okay.
Oh my god, look at this one pistol.
You should be able to get him though.
Yeah, I got him.
No!
Oh fuck.
I got him out.
I got him out though.
Come on.
Get over here.
I have five more.
Oh wait, that's your boar.
That's my boar, yeah.
I have five more.
I was trying to kill it.
You six?
Oh!
Oh, I got it!
We got syndicate thugs.
I'm gonna put some dudes in here.
Alright.
We're doing it.
I'm gonna put my human in the pal box.
Oh wait, he's already in here.
I'm being assaulted by three officers for assaulting a person.
Oh shit.
That's a...
It's like assaulting people is a bad thing, Lily.
I hope you...
I just wanted to catch them.
Wow.
Give them a nice little home.
No big deal.
But they already have a home.
What do you mean?
But I can make a homey a home.
But their family is in their original home.
I'm the family now.
Are you trying to say your buddy now?
Oh, whoa!
Whoa.
This hole was made for me.
We're sorry.
Wow.
Don't talk too... never mind.
I'm not gonna make that joke.
Go on.
No, say it with your chest.
It's okay.
Don't go for European, Lily!
Don't go for European!
It's on European!
Well, you were gonna go that route, huh?
Wait, what happened on the rock?
Never mind.
This is ending Twitch Rivals!
We can't get away with this!
Alright, do we now... do we have enough for the stone pit?
Alright, I'm putting out the stone pit.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
I should've built the ranch first.
Wait, what do I need for the ranch?
Don't worry.
Alright, don't worry.
I have a lot of stone.
I'm coming over.
Maybe dying is like...
Yeah, I'm going to put it in the box.
You got any fire Pokmon in the Paldex?
We've got one.
I got only the Fox Sparks.
What the...
I put the stone in.
Rock and stone.
Okay, do we need more stones?
No, I think we're good.
I'm going to build the first ranch.
Nice.
I noticed in making Nubis, it's like that...
green...
panda and...
female bee.
Oh!
Nice.
That's how you breed them.
The...
Vespa Queen, but like...
Palworld.
But the Palworld...
version of it.
Oh no.
No fucking pickaxe.
I like seeing the little syndicate guy also swinging...
a hammer here.
It's actually kind of endearing.
He's doing his part.
Our little teammate.
He's a great asset.
Great asset?
Great, great asset?
Great asset.
What the hell name is that?
It says, are you guys making a...
Oh, you're making a crossbow.
Nice.
I'm making a crossbow.
Oh, nice!
Where's the repair bench?
I'm gonna go murder things.
Oh, I think I put...
Did I... Did I just assemble the repair...
Why is there like four benches?
We have like four benches.
We can be instructors.
So we can work on multiple projects.
We have five.
Okay, I should know...
We should make... We should replace them with the high quality benches...
when we can though, cause they make stuff faster.
We got a high quality right here.
I'm gonna put a repair bench right here.
Now we have...
I don't know if we do have a repair bench, but here is one too.
Nice.
Why is she so tanky?
I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go catch some pals.
Alright, let me put...
Ow!
Where's Vixie?
That's our first mounted pal.
Uh...
Direwolf is pretty good.
You can also... You have to find Chillit anyway.
So you can just do Chillit if you want.
I'm gonna try to find it.
I think it's Rushboard.
Yeah, Rushboard is the first one.
I'm trying to remember where the Direwolf was.
How do I get the Direwolf?
It's near the bridge.
There's like a bridge near a waypoint.
Where is Direwolf?
God help me.
Google is not an exploit.
That's all I'm gonna say.
Alright, so...
So let's find which...
What?
Whoa!
Who the fuck is that?
I don't know.
That's the word I've been saying for a long time.
It's like a forgotten memory.
Alright, let's see it.
Wait, why can't I use this red... Oh, there we go.
Don't wanna find... Okay, it is in the abandoned mineshaft.
Don't wanna find...
Okay, it is in the abandoned mineshaft.
Okay...
Where am I?
First off, where am I though?
Okay, this way.
No, I shouldn't make the max.
Oh shit.
I think this is the way.
I only made three arrows.
Okay.
Wait, how many balls do I have?
I did not double check that.
Yeah, you always gotta check your balls before you go out.
No comment.
I want you to live with that.
Wouldn't you agree?
I want you to think about what you just said.
But I agree.
I think he's not really my strong suit.
It's all good.
I don't agree.
Dang.
You gotta check your boss and make sure you don't have cancer.
No, that's for breasts, right?
No, I think you can get...
...testicular cancer.
Yeah, you have to do that for...
...testicular cancer too.
Yeah.
So you would say you have fondles.
Yeah, chat, you should fondle...
Chat, make sure you don't have lumps.
...testicular cancer right now.
Real quick, real quick.
Stop telling your VTuber chats to fondle their balls.
You know half of them have lived for a statement like that.
I'm not sure if you're a VTuber.
TRIPPER, did you check your balls today?
Yeah, did you?
I'm being harassed right now.
We're not the ones checking.
We're asking if you've checked yourself.
Yeah.
It's one of the global achievements, I think.
I'm not gonna talk about my balls.
We're just concerned about your health.
Cap.
Wow.
We're just here trying to be a good friend.
We don't have the sticular cancer.
Listen, reverse the rules.
Alright, all the women in chat, have you guys checked your breasts to make sure you don't have breast cancer?
Just make sure.
We want you to be safe.
Give a little swipe of the mammaries.
Alright, pressure's built.
I think that means we're going to the next base level.
Alright, nice.
Seven.
Alright, hot spring.
Oh shit, I know my balls!
My balls!
Don't worry, my chickpea's here.
I'm not worried anymore.
No, my little chicken!
I need a wooden stone, but we need to assign people to the actual mine.
Right now we have this shitty little green chipmunk doing all of the...
All of the woodwork.
What do we need for it?
We need that blue and purple elk guy.
Elk whatever his name is.
And we need a tombat.
But if we can't get a tombat, that's fine, but...
We just need to wait until nighttime right now.
Yeah.
It's not nighttime so we can't do anything.
But the elk would be good.
Elk should be out right now.
If you see one.
Still trying to figure out where the direwolf is.
They're on me.
They're on you?
Where are you?
Oh my god, you're so far away.
I'm heading over.
I think I need to go...
Level.
Whoa!
Not the poor sheep!
It's taking so long!
I wanna build a second ranch.
Wait, maybe I can catch this person.
I should get a glider.
Oh!
We got another human!
Nice!
We have three humans now!
More human.
More work.
Something you doing?
What are you sure for?
Zog's done.
Zog Zog.
Oh!
I know where the...
There's a shiny lamb bell!
Let's get it!
Don't we get points for shiny?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we do!
Tiebreaker is shinies I think.
We get extra points as well.
So much more damage.
Please chickpea do not kill him!
Make it so they're not aggressive.
Hold four.
Hold four?
It's fine, we're fine.
It's okay.
I'm beating him up right now.
I'm beating him up now.
Make sure I don't accidentally kill him myself.
I think it's faster to die and just try again.
What the fuck?
Oh I got it!
I got it!
Nice!
Clip it!
Do I have VOD history on?
Clip it chat!
Clip it bro!
Guys, I haven't been on this Twitch in a long time.
Do I even have VOD history on?
I actually didn't chat!
Oh no!
That's against the rules.
I have an excuse!
I have an excuse though!
You have no excuse.
I have this note from my doctor.
I do!
It's okay!
I might die though.
I do though.
I do.
It's fine.
Save!
Has anybody gone to the chili yet?
No, clips are not on.
Guys, remember to go back to my VOD and clip it when I turn it back on!
Wait, no!
If you don't have it on, you won't have a VOD!
Oh wait, clips are on!
Don't worry, people were fucking around.
It's okay, clips are on.
Alright.
You're trying to sabotage us.
Oh, oh, oh!
Do you guys see?
There's an outpost over here with the thugs.
They've got those Elks over there.
Oh, okay, nice.
There's so many direwolves here.
Yeah, we should probably go get those Elks.
I have no health because I have no food.
But...
Maybe I'll find some food.
If I die, that's probably better.
So it's fine.
If I die, I die.
If you die, just respawn for a head.
Oh wait, did I just die?
Uh, hmm...
Maybe.
Woo!
Nice.
I got direwolf!
Wait, am I dead?
What level is direwolf?
Oh, I think I died.
Alright, I'm gonna give up.
Oh wait, I like, I fell into the water and for some reason...
Oh, I must have taken fall damage!
Oh, okay.
What level is the direwolf mount?
I don't remember.
15?
Oh, okay, I haven't enough minerals.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Oh, there it is!
Okay, nine.
Yeah, I can afford it now.
Oh no, please don't kill me.
Elks spotted.
Getting help.
Nice, thank you.
There's like a couple at that outpost as well.
There's a direwolf that wanna fucking kill me.
God, he's so fast!
Hit him enough so he'll hit back.
Come here, boy!
As long as you don't hit first, you didn't start the fight.
You can finish it though.
Yes!
Okay, there's a...
Oh, nice, there's my stuff.
Oh, I see you, surefour.
Hey.
Oh.
Ow.
You catching it?
That'd be spam-catching shit.
I'm trying.
I'm trying, Beth.
Where the fuck is the...
Oh my god, I'm fucking...
dying.
Holy shit.
How the hell do I get over there?
We got the elk.
Oh wait, I'm gonna go.
I don't know.
Okay.
I need to get home.
I'm so fucked right now.
I have 99 HP.
I need to get home.
I'm so fucked right now.
I have 99 HP.
Alright.
Back to the base I go.
Deploying Elkin base.
I'll be there soon.
Alright.
Putting all my resources.
Oh, I'm gonna drown again.
Why am I like this?
Our pals are... our pals...
They're stressed out!
Oh no, they're so depressed.
Oh no, join the club, bro.
Someone do something!
I'm gonna drown again!
Okay, I need... leather, wood, fiber...
I think I should have enough.
Where the fuck is the...
Why have I tried this twice?
This is...
Yay!
I have a level 14 chicken!
Nice-o!
Help me, handyman.
It's about nighttime too, so we can try to get...
Okay, it's Tomabat again.
Yeah, Tomabat again.
Fuck!
Yay!
Nice.
Acquired.
Oh yeah, I'm...
Let's see...
I wanted more balls.
Nice!
Nice.
There's arrows being...
crafted somewhere.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Do a little leveling.
Need more balls.
What do I need?
Let's see...
Where am I missing?
Wood.
Okay.
When do I get it?
I can't see.
Fox!
Give me the light!
I'm like AD-ing out of habit.
Like FPS-ing.
AD-ing?
AD.
AD, AD, AD, AD, AD.
I can't stand still when I'm...
Can you sidestep, bro?
Yeah.
I can't stand still while I'm fucking chopping a tree.
What does AD stand for?
A-N-D?
Like you're A-N-D on your keyboard?
Really?
A-N-D?
What do the letters A-D stand for?
Oh yeah, cause it's...
That's why.
Cause like in Fortnite, I...
Fortnite.
Yeah, yeah, give me credit.
No, don't.
Let's see... It's night time!
You're a Fortnite-er?
Bro, I spend...
I spend like at least $500 on Fortnite skins and I'm not proud of it.
Man, Fortnite's really fun though.
It's near the...
Combat should be near the Mamoswine, right?
Yes.
Okay.
I'll see if I can find them.
Yeah, Mamoswine Forest.
Oh, I see!
I found the combat!
I need mana rest.
Let's go!
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Get over here, I'm gonna fucking catch you.
Whoa.
It's self-defense cause he shot first.
Yeah, tell your lawyer.
You saw it chat!
He shot first, guys!
Oh my god, I actually might die.
I'm fucking around way too much.
Do you have anything for these diaries?
Oh no, oh no.
I don't think so.
Okay.
Ummm...
Is the Limb Mug achievement, is that a global one or is that just a day one?
It's a global, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, yeah, it's a global.
Cool, cool.
All the day one achievements are like very...
Just mostly catching the bosses.
Okay.
Except for the bases and the...
Woo!
I have two tombats.
Nice!
Who do we replace then for the tombats?
Ummm...
Well, we actually...
We should be able to build the next thing.
Sorry, I'm not at base right now, but we should be able to build the next thing now.
Which I think is another berry thing.
We were out of resources last time.
But we should be able to do a base upgrade and then you can just throw them in.
Alright, what's the...
What do we need for the berry?
Give me one second, I'm almost back at base.
I got the tombat.
I'm heading over to base.
Alright, sounds good.
I'm getting some Wok.
Shrek.
Metal.
Seeds and wood.
We have a lot of seeds.
So I think that should be fine.
Alright, I'm back in.
Seed, fiber and wood.
Give me the light.
Let me just double check and see what we need.
Ummm...
Next base upgrade we need one more berry plantation and hot springs.
Okay.
I got you a lot of wood.
I can build the hot springs right now.
I can put some wood for you.
Thank you!
And then...
Alright.
Yeah, we have like 268 wood.
Oh, I have like ancient civilization parts.
I have six.
How do I get six?
I think we're gonna need that for the next upgrade.
What the fuck did I grab?
We don't need scopefrogs, do we?
What did I do?
We need five stone.
Oh, five stone?
Easy.
No.
Don't need it.
Oh!
When I caught the shiny lamb bell, I got ancient civilization parts.
Oh no!
That makes sense.
I didn't notice that.
Alright, I put the five stone in.
We can do a dungeon run too.
There's a dungeon right by the entrance of our base.
Do the dungeon bosses count towards anything?
Uh uh, no.
Well, doing the dungeon counts.
There's only alphas in there.
We need to do the ravine grotto dungeon and then the mountain stream grotto dungeon.
As a team, by the way.
So if you find the ravine grotto dungeon, that's what we have to do.
Okay.
I'm not sure where that one is, but...
Alright.
Hey, Google.
Where's the ravine grotto dungeon?
It's not an X1 if it's on the internet!
Base level 8.
It is... wait, it's near us.
Base 8.
Uh, we need a medieval workbench and then we'll be base 9.
Uh, good question.
Okay, I'll put the tombats in.
Wait, alright.
Who do we replace for the tombats?
Uh, anybody really.
Anybody?
Okay, I'm replacing...
Except for the elk.
Pretty much anybody else is...
The fuck's the elk?
There's no elk in here.
Okay, is someone level 12 on base?
I'm not level 12 yet.
Uh, can you build the medieval workbench?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Alright, I got rid of the vixie and the creamy.
Do we need those?
Okay.
Um, vixie is probably...
Is good to have, uh, creamy is not.
Alright, I'll... What do you wanna replace for the...
The vixie then?
Why'd they call it creamy?
Uh, let me take a look.
I guess the chicken, right?
Do we need... We don't need the chicken.
Chicken can give us food.
We can get rid of the syndicate thug.
We don't really need him.
We don't need him?
He is a person.
You can't just throw people away.
They are...
They all matter.
Don't worry, I'll go to the black marketeer.
I'll sell them off.
Dude, I wish that we could capture him, but that's an exploit.
It's fun having him on base.
No, you can capture him.
What?
You just can't capture him with a campfire.
Yeah, we can't like...
As long as you're doing the damage and stuff.
Yeah, I guess so.
Alright, I have the tombad in.
Our pals are stressed though, cause there's not enough beds.
Okay, I'll build some more beds.
We're gonna find him...
Someone's like, we're gonna find him a new family.
We're gonna find him a new family.
We'll take care of him much better than any other family ever could.
True.
Yeah, exactly.
So true.
Alright, I'm gonna see if we can find that fucking...
We have like three stars on Yelp as a family.
Oh, the ravine dungeon is like...
It's not bad.
We're trying our best here.
Could it be better?
Sure.
But like, we're not asking for perfection.
Nobody's perfect, you know.
I am.
Cause he's perfect.
He's the only perfect person out here.
Well then.
Cause he silenced all the other opinions.
No, I'm not a silencer.
Oh, we got two victims.
Didn't you say you fucking...
Didn't you literally say...
You ban anyone whose opinions don't match yours?
I think you're putting words into my mouth.
You can't silence...
You can't ban me.
You're too smart to be gaslit.
Alright, we got two Vixies in the ranch.
They're gonna make powballs for us.
Nice.
Wait, before I go...
How many powballs do we have?
I have 12.
I might wanna grab some more before I go.
Did someone feed this to me?
Alright, we're base level 9.
Nice.
There's nobody in here.
I'm gonna have to start leveling up myself.
I can't build any of the new things anymore.
What did I free?
I can.
What do you need built?
We need the sphere workbench, which is level 14.
And we need the cooler box, which is level 13.
For those.
Sphere bench.
Alright, let me see what materials we need.
And the cooling box?
The cooler?
We actually have enough stuff for it already.
We just need...
Oh, we need ice organs.
If anybody has ice organs.
We know where to get them if we don't already have them.
Wait, who do we kill for that?
The penguins.
Oh, okay.
But they're nearby.
I'm gonna go murder them.
There should be lots of penguins here.
If you can put any ice organs you have in the chest, we can make the cooler.
Alright.
I have 15 ice organs.
Hold up.
Ayooo!
Let's go!
There's 3 here.
There's like 5 of them here.
Ice organs?
Organ.
It's so weird.
It's like, what are the achievements?
And I'm like, well, I can't share.
I don't know why.
You can't share it.
I don't know man.
I'm pretty sure there's viewer Google Docs.
Yeah, there is.
There is a viewer one.
They just didn't want to link the main one so it doesn't crash and people edit it.
And we're just like, what's going on?
I'm freaking out!
Well, if my mods have access to that and want to share it, please do.
I linked it once, but I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know if my mods did anything.
You know what?
Just enjoy.
Just enjoy the moment.
It's like you see us catching humans and you're like, why are we wasting time catching a human?
What the fuck?
That was a really nice way of saying, I don't want to do it.
Just enjoy the moment.
Don't get absorbed with this.
You're taking this too seriously.
Come on.
Just look at us.
Doesn't it look like we're taking this so seriously?
I'm just going to go drown myself.
Enjoy the moment!
And he's enjoying the moment drowning himself.
Alright, I'm going to grab a couple things.
I'm going to go level myself for a little bit and come back.
But yeah, cooler box and the other one.
I'm going to make another chest.
Put my ancient civilization thing.
And then our first sphere worm expunge.
I can probably...
catch the penguin dude.
Lucky.
Well you said you already had 15 of those ice organs.
We have like 30 in there now.
The boss penguin, like the one for the achievement.
Ah yeah yeah yeah.
He's pretty low level.
He's only like 15 or so.
We have 30 already in there.
The only problem is the other little guys that come with him.
Wait, is the boss dungeon solo or can you do it in pairs?
You have to do it as a team.
Wait actually, boss dungeons?
Let me double check.
I don't know.
I can wait.
I'm sure you can just solo catch them.
Yeah the boss dungeons, it's solo.
Okay okay.
There's other stuff that's like...
different.
That's like global for fun.
But we can easily do other dungeons again.
Also, sure, do you already have the incubator unlocked?
Did you fight a boss yet?
Not yet.
I can make a breeding farm.
Okay.
I mean...
Yeah?
I don't know what to do right now.
Right now we need to build the...
I just need someone who's a higher level to build the thing.
What level?
Cooler box and sphere workbench.
14.
Oh I'm 14 already.
I'm only 12 so I gotta go on all.
The small penguins are an issue.
We need 20 ingots and 10 nails.
I'm doing it.
Oh you're doing it?
You're building?
Okay.
We should have nails and ingots already in the box.
I swear I'm doing it.
Okay I'm gonna help us get more ingots set.
Okay.
I'm on code level.
I have another dog with me.
Super mining.
How about?
Alright.
What the dog doing?
Grab more ingots.
Oh she respawned.
The NPC.
I can catch her now.
Oh nice!
Nice.
We're almost there.
We're almost at 20.
She keeps alerting the authorities.
How dare her call the cops.
Right?
We're trying to get her home.
Get her home.
I'm shooting her and I had a couple times so she's catchable.
What the heck man.
Yeah.
She should enjoy the moment.
She's being too hot on herself.
Yeah just enjoy the moment.
We should let it happen.
Just get caught.
Come on.
VTubers are murderers.
What?
No.
Us?
I'm trying to not murder her but the police shows up and they murder her.
Yeah.
It's self defense.
What the?
Alright.
Let's see.
I have a lot of ingots.
Do we need more ingots?
Do we have enough?
We need hella ingots.
On god.
Alright.
I'm gonna try to be trifling.
I put a lot of ores in the box.
Damn it.
Stay in the box ball thing.
It's comfy.
Trust.
This box is so comfy.
Yes.
I did it.
I'm gonna...
I kinda want it but what if I just walk off?
Oh.
Come on.
Stay in the box.
The police follows me after capturing a human.
That is unfortunate.
Can't believe this is where our tax dollars go to.
Can't believe you're funding this.
Yeah.
Can't believe this is why you shouldn't pay taxes.
Whose fox pirate is this?
It's mine.
I put it there.
Oh my god.
Just hit me in the face already.
Please.
I beg you.
Alright.
I got you.
We have dwarves.
Nice.
Now it's a lot faster.
There we go.
Faster burning.
Where in the world...
Where did that lift monk go?
He's just staring at me.
Oh my goodness.
Anthony.
Please.
Lily you matter.
Don't do it.
Oh my god.
Please.
I beg.
One punch in the face.
And surely I'm dead.
There we go.
I...
I have more ore for you.
Mining away.
I can do a minecraft cover now.
You can play giraffe town now.
I can play giraffe town.
Oh yeah.
Giraffe town is a...
Legendary adventure.
About a giraffe in a town.
Whoa.
That little lag spike there.
Holy shit.
Please stop lagging my game guys.
I'm level 15 now.
Oh my god.
You're level 23.
That is our power leveler.
Right there.
Have you caught any of the...
Boss Pokemons yet?
I mean Powmons.
Yeah I think we should probably work on getting like the chill out so we can get the egg incubator.
Yeah.
Go Sheriff 4.
We're egging.
Oh shit we still have 3 hours?
Yeah but the eggs take so long though so we might as well get it now.
No no no the server has it so it's like 2 minutes.
Oh.
For large eggs it's an hour.
Yeah that's what I'm saying.
Yeah so I feel like we should grab some eggs now.
Like get the egg incubator now in case we find a large egg.
Let's see.
I'll grab some more ore for this.
No my weapon.
Tom is taking a break?
I don't think so.
Is this a competition?
There's no other eggs in tournaments.
I dare you.
But you matter don't worry.
But you do matter.
But please don't take a break ever.
Peace and love.
Where the fuck is it?
Oh it's so far away.
I'll grab the chillit.
Where is it?
Chillit.
Chillit is...
like...
It's okay I googled.
Okay.
I do not know how to describe where it is.
It's near us though.
It's not far.
Alright.
It's like here.
Report my achievements?
What achievement did I get?
It's okay.
PP's mod.
You got a shiny?
Did that count for something?
Yeah we got a shiny.
But which one?
What do we report?
I don't know what's going on.
PP's mod.
Report my shiny lamp.
Go PP.
Go.
Alright nice.
Wait do I have balls?
I do right?
I don't fuck.
Surely.
I was there and I was like wait a minute I don't even have my pal balls.
They were there in the next second.
That's what I said.
Before you leave you gotta check your balls.
Always check your balls guys.
Always check your balls before you leave.
Why is it always about balls?
It's okay I got one ball.
That should be enough for chillit.
Mod says it's done.
Nice.
Surely balls matter.
Mod make sure all our...
Okay the cooler box and the pal sphere is made.
Mod make sure all our achievements getting reported.
Mods.
Unpaid interns do your jobs.
Yeah.
We're not gonna write your references if you don't.
Nope.
That's right.
You'll never be able to leave me for a better streamer.
Exactly.
You'll never know.
Where the hell is this thing going?
You can't leave me if you don't have a resume.
Resume.
Oh King Paka?
Wait what level is King Paka?
Oh no he's level 23.
Nah fuck that.
He's enough level for sure.
He's level 23 right now.
Yo fuck him up.
Yeah fuck him up.
Do your power level thing.
I'm doing it.
Oh hey there's a teeth in here.
I'm gonna kill him.
Alright.
I'm just gonna level.
Where is chillit?
Perfect.
Oh.
Alright.
Do your thing dire wolf.
Don't worry I have my pickaxe.
Ow.
Don't worry I'm doing like 2 damage per second with my pickaxe.
Ah.
Ow.
What?
Wait the bonus AXP for the...
for like getting...
I got chillit.
51?
What the fuck?
That's so little.
I got the chillit guys.
We got the chillit.
Record it PeepeeMoz.
We can get the incubator.
Go to my stream right now.
Go Peepees.
Go Peepees go.
We got noodle.
I need better piles I can't kill shit anymore.
My pile is just like...
Oh I got an egg too.
Mining a rock while I'm fighting stuff off.
Stop killing everything.
We're trying to catch them.
I'm heading over now to give us the...
the incubator.
Oh wait what am I doing?
What the f...
What the fuuuu...
King Paka just ran off in the other direction.
Can he leave the boss area?
I think they all can technically.
If you aggro it.
If you aggro it yeah.
I didn't aggro him but dude he uh...
He's got shit to do I guess.
I guess he forgot to pay his taxes or something.
He was in a hurry.
Alright let's see.
Uhhhh...
Got the chillit right here.
I'm gonna put that chillit in my team now.
Alright.
Let me level up that incubator.
We have...
We need palladium fragments.
Does anyone have extra palladium fragments?
Uh I can mine some.
Yeah I need some fragments.
To make the incubator.
I'm pretty sure I just put some in a chest.
No cause I can't make it.
Oh yeah I did I did.
Yeah I see it.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright incubator.
I'm gonna put it right here.
Alright.
Here you go.
Right right.
I should finally make a crossbow.
I've been trying to beat everything up with a pickaxe.
It wasn't really the smartest thing to do.
Let's see.
It's so annoying.
I can't climb anything cause of like the pingy shield.
I guess so I have to look everywhere.
Every time I climb I have to like slow climb cause the second I press space I just like snap back.
Snap back to reality.
Oh there goes gravity.
He won't give up that easy.
Let's see.
Get more weight in here.
Oh no my pals are stressed.
Get used to it.
This is your life now.
Woah.
We have a healthy work environment.
Don't worry guys.
Nobody is getting abused.
I swear.
Everybody wants to work for our company.
Our company.
Yeah.
Money isn't real.
Tell them.
Let's see.
I'm gonna grab more penguins.
Whoops.
No my balls.
Alright I should be 15 in a second.
I can't climb.
Wait what's our PAL base?
Why do I have all those ingots?
What's our PAL base level right now?
It should be level 9 or 10.
Oh shit we're almost at 12.
Yeah we're doing really good.
I got the penguin.
It's only about materials now because we already have somebody the right level.
What materials do we need?
Good question.
I'm about to come back to base.
Yeah.
I can mine some materials right now for us.
I know that we're gonna need ingot.
But I have like 26.
Did we already build the cooler?
Yeah we have a cooler.
Yeah I already leveled this thing.
Okay okay.
Alright I'm heading back.
My new tactic didn't work.
I figured I can just spam.
The dodge button.
Don't try to kill something.
It doesn't fucking work.
Would I have to stick to killing easy stuff?
So when I get hit it doesn't matter.
Wait where the fuck is the...
Oh no.
Is it up there?
No it was up there.
I'm like trying to figure out where the fast travel is down here.
I believe in you.
I'm so lost.
Alright grabbing this thing.
Oh it's over here.
Did we make the incubator?
Yeah we did it's up on the cliff.
Cool cool cool.
I put it on the cliff.
I'm heading back.
Nice I did it.
I found this thing.
I did it.
Did you catch the sweepy yet?
Or get a sweepy?
Surefour?
I'm gonna go catch stuff in a bit.
But I just asked my chat if they're gonna clip it when I kill a boss.
And they're all spamming no.
Guys!
Don't you want us to win?
They're gonna say no.
That's not the question you wanna ask.
Okay don't you want Shy Lily to win?
Yeah!
Actually they might say yes.
They might say yes.
They might say yes for Lily.
Guys think of it.
Lily wants to win.
Please just feel sorry for me.
It's like 50-50.
We got no ifs and yeses for that.
Let's see.
What do I need to do?
Someone said if Lily wins, Surefour wins guys.
So no.
Guys don't worry.
We'll kick Surefour out at the last second.
So then only Lily...
Only I will win.
Don't worry.
We'll sue you for discrimination.
I guess disqualified last second.
Yeah yeah don't worry.
Disqualified for what?
We'll plan an exploit.
We'll plot something.
Don't worry.
How am I being called a cheater again?
Oh it's a reentering theme.
Yeah you don't know.
You don't know.
What the?
Coincidence?
Mmmmm.
I don't know.
Doesn't seem much of a coincidence anymore.
It's a little coinkydink.
Surely there's some truth to it.
Mmmmm.
Got it.
I'm getting more iron.
Do we just need ore?
I've got a bunch but I took it with me for some reason.
Yeah but like what materials do we need?
For all the other stuff?
Hold on one second.
Bye.
I'm gonna mark my map.
So one of Pia's mods said they would clip and don't worry and now my chat is gunning them down.
What is happening?
Run!
They're like hide the evidence!
Hide the evidence!
Run!
The moat is Helper's massacre if you don't know.
You weren't built for a flesh tuber's chat!
You weren't built for it!
Don't touch my soft V-tube.
You leave them alone.
Oh no.
You showed weakness.
You're fucked now.
You should never show weakness.
They bite around here.
Alright I'm putting the ingot in the chest.
I'm gonna look at sweep up where.
We don't count deaths here.
We don't count deaths.
Sweep up boss.
Me too.
I'm counting too.
Alright.
Wheat plantation, mill, cooking pot.
Where the fuck is the sweep up boss?
If you have the resources I can build it.
I think we have right?
I can build the wheat plantation.
We need wheat seeds though.
You buy them from Ventar.
Oh we can just buy it?
Yeah.
I'll buy the seeds now.
We need wheat seeds and uh let's see.
What do we need for the cooking pot?
Where's the house?
Otherwise I think we have everything for that.
Did you kill Pang King?
No I didn't.
I need someone who is level 17 to make the cooking pot.
I can make.
Wait what level am I?
We have all the stuff already.
I'm level 17 I can make it yeah.
I'll buy the wheat seeds right now.
Thank you.
So I'll make the cooking pot.
Wait what was the person?
There you are.
Mr. Merchant do you have the seeds?
I don't.
No that's the pal Merchant.
Alright.
I'm just trying to retrieve my stuff.
Um.
Mr. Merchant do you have the seeds?
These ones are fine actually.
Oh I got wheat seeds.
Nice!
I'm dead.
What can I build right now?
Oh my god what happened?
Uh my Pokemon weren't on aggressive.
And then I they didn't attack.
And then I got swift in one shot.
Damn.
You fell off.
Oh my god there you are.
Alright I put the seeds in one of the boxes.
Alright.
So you can just make it.
And then I'll make the cooking pot.
I'll make the wheat plantation and then someone can make the cooking pot.
Yeah I can make it now.
Alright cool.
Nice.
I'll put it right.
I'll put it next to the incubator.
Oh can you put the wheat seeds in the box?
Yeah I did I just did.
Oh shit.
Should be in one.
We need two more.
Oh we need two wheat seeds?
We need three of them.
Sorry my bad.
Do I have enough money?
We need two more right?
Yeah two more.
I'm gonna get out of here.
Goodbye.
Don't worry here I am.
God we have so much ingot.
I love this space.
I have just enough for two more wheat seeds.
I'm gonna go grab the...
I'm gonna go grab the leather I left behind.
Nice.
Alright now I'm broke.
For the wheat.
It's for the wheat.
It's a good purchase.
Do it for the wheat.
I'm heading over.
Someone's slacking off we have to eat him now.
Oh yeah.
Well we can make a machete.
We can make a machete.
It's to send a message.
No slacking off.
Slack off and get eaten.
We can replace you with another life monk.
But you matter.
Don't worry.
Setting a large egg.
We got the cooking pot.
And...
Nice.
I have two seeds now.
I put it in.
Okay thank you.
I'll build up.
I'll build up the beds for guys.
They're stressed out.
Got it.
Have we got any extra arrows around here?
Uh...
I'll put some in the box.
Thank you.
I'm gonna go catch the sweepa.
Oh sorry.
I only had seven.
My bad.
Good enough.
Where the fuck is the sweepa?
Sweepa boss where?
Sweepa.
Where are you?
You're so far.
Holy shit.
I can get there.
Get ready to report this.
I'm ready to travel so fucking far for this one sweepa boss.
Wait actually...
Can I...
We need more wood.
No?
Okay.
Guys balls check.
Balls check.
Balls still there?
I can't see but I think I'm going the right way.
I almost died cause I always...
Turn on my glider...
Before I hit the ground.
Oh no.
Oh no I think I'm dead.
I accidentally ran into water.
Accidentally in water.
No!
He'll be fine.
I think he'll be fine.
We'll just keep swimming.
Alright.
Once the wheat farm is finished then we're going to be level 10.
We'll be okay.
I don't know where...
Oh hey.
Oh I found reincarnated guy!
Come to me.
We got to take a picture.
Let's go.
Come to me we got to take a picture.
Wait do I have to catch the boss or kill it?
Cause technically I killed it.
You have to capture field.
You have to capture it.
Oh no.
Guys get to me!
I found the reincarnated guy!
We can do that.
Okay we need level 20.
We need someone to make the work bench.
I'm sorry the weapons work bench.
At level 20.
I'll make nails right now.
I don't know if I can find him again.
Oh you got nails?
Okay.
Oh I see I see.
You can't mark on the map.
Wait we can mark him?
Yeah yeah yeah.
All we need is the weapons work bench.
We'll be level 11.
Okay.
I marked him.
I did it.
I found...
Nearly drowning saved my life.
Do we need for day 2 Do we need a different level of base?
Or is it like just 12?
Day 2 we need 20.
Oh okay.
Easy.
And then we have to capture 2 black marketeer.
Level up any pal to level 50.
Oh shit you can't catch them then.
Okay cool.
Yeah we have to capture you later.
Just normal.
No I know but I didn't know that I didn't...
I still feel like it's a little bit exploity to catch them but like...
Yeah okay.
They even said it's fine you can do the pal recycling with them.
Nice.
How do I get out of here?
It's so dark.
I can't see.
I might just have to get the fox spark.
My.
We don't need a second tombaad do we?
No we're good.
Yeah I already have 2 tombaads here.
Might as well catch stuff to just level up.
Yeah.
True true.
And you get to...
If you find a level 29 chickpea go for it.
Go for it.
Cause we still need a level 30 chickpea.
Whenever you come back to base if you can build the weapon...
I think you have to level it yourself.
I don't think there's ever just gonna be a random one.
Unless it's like a shiny.
Yeah that's what I was thinking.
We find a shiny.
Oh my god where am I?
I can't see.
That was responsive.
Cool.
I'm trying to get to the sweeper.
But I can't even see.
Uh oh.
Where am I?
Oh there you are.
Okay we're still low on wood.
I should try to capture a flying pal.
Yep.
That would be very helpful.
I think the...
The easiest and best one you can get at this level is like...
I guess it's still the...
bird one.
I wanna get that...
What was it?
The dragon one.
Yeah that one's way sicker though.
If you can make it out to the desert.
That one is good.
I need to figure out how to get there.
I'm gonna kill that sweeper and then I'm gonna get it.
Yeah quiver.
Yeah I think that's the one.
Oh I can't dodge.
Oops.
Alright.
Acquired!
Am I close?
Am I close to the sweeper?
Oh god we're one off on wood.
Where is he?
I already forgot where he is.
Where's who?
The sweeper.
He's so far.
Did you get all the nails made?
Yep everything's made.
All we need is just somebody to make it.
What do I need to make?
It's level 20.
The weapons workbench.
I'm always last.
Where the fuck do I put it?
And then we'll be level 12 and we'll have completed base for today.
And I guess it's just like...
I guess we can keep leveling the base.
Oh yeah we can keep leveling it.
Yeah.
We level it to level 19.
So we can get it for level...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
True, true, true.
Base, base, base.
As long as you just don't hit the level up button it doesn't count.
Yeah.
We just get to level 19 and we're fine.
Shit don't worry Deidre I'm gonna save you.
Oh he's dead.
Okay that's...sucks.
Okay I got 21 pile balls.
I need to bury the...
Bob.
Catch some stuff.
What is this?
Oh hey there's...
Hey there's another tombat!
Ayo!
But we don't need it anyway so I'm just gonna release him.
Yeah but I mean if you get the 10.
That's true.
Nice.
I put my pile spurs in the base.
Get over here.
Get over here dire wolf.
No please I don't wanna die because I'm still using my pickaxe as a weapon.
No!
Okay I'm just gonna leave.
Get over here dire wolf.
We're gonna leave.
Where am I?
Out.
I should really start crafting a bow.
Ow.
I want to get a crossbow.
Yeah I need a crossbow too.
I have not been crafting.
I need quite some ingots for those.
I was scared to craft one I was like oh shit that's what an ingot costs?
I was like ahhh.
What the hell is happening to this spark?
Alright.
Let's see where am I?
Yay it's almost day time!
Hold up I need to steal butterpots.
Oh hey there's a toko toko!
We needed those right?
Oh nice we need that!
Yeah we need 10 of them.
Yeah okay.
Ummm...
Yeah now that we've almost got our base up to 12 we might as well like go towards the desert I think.
Yeah there's one here on me.
Should we start doing the bosses that we have to do together?
Uhhh...
I don't think there's any bosses we have to do together.
Oh.
Just dungeons we have to do together.
I don't know where they are though.
Don't worry.
Google where are they?
They're like level 19 dungeons.
God's got my back.
Alright.
How many tokos do we need?
I forgot the thing.
10 I think.
10?
Okay.
I got one.
Nice.
Alright nice.
We just need...
Get over here.
Don't blow up.
Don't blow up though.
Oh shit.
No.
Please.
Nooooooo!
Did you explode?
I died!
No!
I wanted to catch him!
Guys I'm right... No!
Not like this man.
Not like this.
My first death!
And then my wolf killed him.
First time huh?
Don't worry young one.
You'll get there.
Okay.
Alright nice.
Alright let's see.
Where did I die?
Oh there it died.
I can't believe it.
The bird on bird violence.
Like here?
Where the fuck did I die?
Oh really close to the dungeon.
Did anybody take down Pen King yet?
Nope.
Yeah so about that.
He sort of killed him.
Yeah it's like the...
It's not that he's hard.
It's the other ones.
My dire wolf kind of killed him while I was waiting to respawn.
Oh.
Yeah.
Just a little oopsie.
I mean doesn't that count though?
No it has to be capture.
We have to catch them.
Oh okay okay.
Should we start making...
Once you have the...
Well we've already got the palisphere wrench.
We can already start making gigasphere.
Or whatever the green ones are called.
Alright.
We can make hyperspheres.
I can at least.
I think you're at the point where you can make hyperspheres.
Alright I gotta go back and...
See.
Oh there's a...
I see more iron.
Let's see.
Where?
When do we unlock the secondary...
Location?
Uhhh.
We might have already actually.
I don't know what level that unlocks at.
The secondary base?
We check right now.
I'll go check.
Wait where do we put our secondary base then?
I think you unlock it at level 10.
Yeah we have it.
Where do we want to put our second base though?
I don't know you're the base expert.
I think it's probably near the desert or something.
Yeah desert sounds nice.
Uhhh.
Where the fuck did I put my own repair bench?
There it is.
We can also make like a...
Gun stuff.
Ooooo.
Where are the...
Oh.
That's not it.
Oh my god there's so many benches.
Which is the bench I need.
There's too many.
Too much benches.
I need...
I need this and your repair my armor.
Ah.
Okay.
Let's see.
Grab a little bit of that.
Let's see what do I need.
What was I doing?
Sweeper.
Sweep attack.
I need to get that sweeper.
Sweep sweep sweep.
Is this sweeper like the most powerful?
Fifteen seconds detention for you.
Okay why do you actually sound like that guy though?
This is kind of bothering me.
Oh Baldi?
No no you sound like the principal.
I am the principal.
He is the principal.
He is the law.
Dang.
D'oh.
Alright.
I'm heading over.
Sorry about all the stuff I did.
Please don't call my mom.
Sorry I said balls like fourteen.
Now fifteen times.
I had fun.
Come back again.
Sometimes.
Level 23 bushy.
I'm bushy.
Where the fuck?
How do I get across?
Legally.
There it is.
I'm almost there.
God they're so fast.
Stop running.
Perish.
No.
Let me climb.
Please don't let me drown.
Okay.
We're almost up top.
Balls check?
Don't worry I checked my balls.
Balls have been checked.
No lumps.
We're checking balls yes.
Bushy and bio yes.
Why is there a lot of balls?
I got a full grown man in my balls.
Woah.
He's just cross checking.
Thank god you checked those balls.
I mean it's part of the global achievement though.
You gotta catch like five guys so.
Oh wait.
That's a level 31.
Getting that killed.
How many hours do we have left?
I haven't been paying attention.
Me either.
Two and a half.
Oh no.
Tom Bat's falling ill.
Take him out the back.
That's cool.
Let's go.
I have no more arrows.
Oh no.
Wait do I have enough stuff to make arrows right now?
I'll make arrows.
I just need one arrow to get him out of the sky.
That's it.
I need one wood.
Grab that waypoint.
Oh hey there's an effigy here.
I know we get points for effigies too.
For the global right?
Yes.
Once you get a flying pal it's really easy to do.
Especially at night.
Yeah.
Get over here.
Get over your waypoint.
What the heck?
What's going on Lily?
What are you doing?
I'm trying to deal with the pig.
The what?
I'm battling the pig always.
At all times.
Is it even a boss?
No it's not.
It's just the right wing.
The ping.
The ping?
I thought you said pig.
I was like what?
Every time I dodge I'm like...
Oh I'm out.
I'm like no way.
Legendary difficulty ping boss.
Alright go kill this sweeper.
Go down.
I only have a pickaxe.
So I'm not helpful.
No not the babies!
We don't care about the babies!
No!
Oh god I might actually die.
It's okay my direwolf is okay.
I leveled up.
It's okay.
It's like dark souls dodging.
Two more balls.
Then I have to farm some ball materials.
It's always balls.
Always balls.
What am I gonna do with all these balls?
No way.
That's not worth it.
I'm not running after him.
Come on direwolf.
Nice.
Oh no he's hungry.
I just have to dodge earlier.
Yeah.
You have to think into the future.
Yeah exactly.
Yeah yeah.
Everything a little early.
Just think 200 ping in advance.
I'm gonna be more convinced.
Oh no my pal team is hungry.
Okay I'm almost level 18.
Yeah the fastest way to level up in this game is just to catch pals.
Like literally just spam catch pals.
Don't worry.
I'm out of balls.
I have one ball left.
Give me that sweeper!
I shall harvest balls.
So proud of you.
Nice.
I missed.
Nice!
Clip clip I got them!
Okay but don't clip the dick part.
Clip it!
Clip this guy!
The sweeper though!
I grabbed the sweeper.
Win!
Nice.
We did it.
I'm gonna feed my fucking wolf.
Alright nice.
Where is this?
Oh my god.
Alright guys.
I got the sweeper.
Another boss down.
Let's go!
I'm so freaking proud of you.
Oh my god.
You're so great.
Do you have a...
Do you...
Surefour how many bosses have you caught yet now?
I've killed one.
Why is this cat attacking?
Jesus.
Nice.
Who's next after sweeper?
What do I have to catch next?
The Goombas.
Okay where is Goombas?
Goombas where?
Where is this?
Come on get in the boat!
Nice!
Nice guys.
Nice we're doing it.
Where the fuck is the Goombas boss?
Where is it?
This is not helpful.
I know you should get that checked though.
I don't know.
Goombas pow world boss location.
What?
What the fuck is it?
I don't know.
I'm gonna steal some of that.
Boom 17.
I need some more balls.
What the heck?
We all need balls don't we?
Yeah.
I'm gonna steal all the balls.
Let's see.
Uh...
Oh I need to put away this.
Oh yeah.
I put some ancient civilization parts away.
Is there anything we need to make in ancient civilization?
No right?
Uh...
There will be.
But not right now.
Not right now.
Okay.
We can also make more incubators for the leftover eggs.
And then just tear them down after.
Yeah if we can make a second incubator that would be pretty good.
Yeah we can make it.
Don't worry I'll make it now.
We need cloth and stone.
Can someone get that for us?
Yep.
I can get more.
I'm in the first area so I can get more lamb.
What is happening?
We're on our way to get $500.
Guys we already have $500.
We're in last place right now.
We already have $500.
Shit man.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Let me grab this.
I can't click this stupid word bench.
Oh my goodness.
Let me craft.
I can't click this stupid word bench.
Yeah you'll be fine.
Guys we're sort of 15th place right now.
No.
We're 16 teams right?
Guys.
We're not last.
Guys these things we can do it so fucking fast.
I'm just saying.
Let's see.
Put stone away.
Okay.
Oh we just got last place apparently.
Oh.
Shit.
No way.
Guys don't worry.
I can speed run all these bosses and then we're gonna get out of it.
It's tortoise and the hare baby.
Tortoise and the hare.
We'll be fine.
Because all we need is to catch up a bit.
Yeah.
We're just trying to kill Mamo right now.
Alright I'm level 19 now.
I'm coming back to base.
Wait team must capture?
Does that mean all of us must have 10?
We all have to catch up.
Oh we can just drop pals.
It says dropping pals.
Oh my god what happened to the base?
Wait does it mean like the...
Alright we're level 12 base now.
Nice.
Clip it!
Clip that!
What a really boring...
Oh we're level 12 base now.
Clip it!
That's cool.
Okay what do I need to do?
Wait I need to build an incubator.
Guys I still need stone.
Wait who the fuck used up all the stone that I just put away?
Large Pelved.
Who used all the stone that I literally just got for us?
Wait what?
I literally put in like 18 stone now there's zero.
Where the fuck are you going mother fucker?
Oh fluffy Pelved.
Last players game.
No we're playing the long game.
We're playing the long game.
We have a plan.
If we want to upgrade to level 13.
How do I get him to work?
If you can make us the fluffy Pelved.
Two of them.
Then we can get the...
Then we can be level 13.
I'm making the egg incubator.
That's literally all we need.
Alright it's a level 24 recipe.
It's the plan to be last place.
What am I making?
Make two fluffy Pelveds.
Alright.
We got a Nox right now.
I'm making the other egg incubator.
We need more cloth and then I can make it.
I'm gonna try and find a...
moss.
Oh.
We can make like 139 cloth.
So.
Do it now.
What do I want to do?
I already forgot what I was...
Oh yeah.
Gumas.
Where the fuck is Gumas?
Still trying to figure out where he is.
Boss map.
Pal world boss map.
All alpha boss locations.
Oh wait.
Just the alpha boss?
Finally bro.
Alright Anubis.
Gumas.
Where are you?
Warsec.
Elizabete.
No I need Gumas.
I'll go get a lock.
Okay Gumas is right here.
Okay I figured it out.
Alright I'm gonna head over.
He's like right here somewhere.
Achievement list.
Uh.
Doomit?
What's Doomit?
I don't even know what these bosses are.
Dummit?
Oh it's like.
I love him.
He's like this cool dumb looking fish dude.
Oh my god.
He's so stupid looking.
I think I know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
It's like the Quagsire guy right?
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
The Quagsire.
The moment you said the dumb looking fish guy I'm like quite excited.
Yeah oh my god.
He looks like he has no brain cells.
You're not wrong though.
Where is Dummit?
Let's see.
He's the dented fish.
Derp fish.
I'm gonna crash these guys right now.
Yeah I can probably take down the Dummit.
I just need to figure out where he is.
He's on the eastern islands I feel like.
No?
No.
Why are they fighting?
Oh my god.
Ooh this little Joltik.
I wanna join into this fight.
No!
Oh wait he's still alive.
Oh he's on the Icewind Islands?
Really?
That's really far.
Oh boy.
Uh okay.
Alright well.
Alright.
Alright we've done Chillit.
We've done Pen King.
Well we haven't done Pen King.
Oh we haven't done Pen King.
Wait what are you doing right now?
I didn't know.
What are you doing right now?
Power leveling.
Oh okay.
We have to stop eventually right?
I mean how many hours we got left?
Two?
Two hours?
Yeah.
Alright.
When are you gonna start capturing?
True.
Yeah but when are you gonna start capturing?
You're doing great.
I got two only!
What do you mean?
You're doing fantastic.
I'm gonna make some balls.
I'm trying to find Umas.
He's like right here somewhere.
Oh there he is.
Alright here I go.
Capturing Gumas.
Yeah we're just leveling enough to just kill the bosses back to back.
Yeah exactly.
I forgot to...
See that's what I'm saying.
It's tortoise and the hare.
Exactly.
We've been taking our time getting everything ready.
Yes!
Alright he's over here.
Like this is organized.
Just gonna use him.
Oh.
We have base management.
I get the materials.
Yeah.
We have boss killing.
Exactly.
There you go.
I found my purpose.
I have been defeated by the like.
I'm just...
I'm downgraded to material fetcher.
You know your purpose.
You know it.
I have found my purpose.
There were organized chaos right here.
Guys clip it!
I got Gumas!
Clip clip!
Gumas!
And I caught this random fish.
Yeah I'm doing my part.
What can I say?
We're doing our part.
We're doing it.
We got Gumas!
Another 10 points!
We can't be last!
I have become one of the pals!
No way!
We got another 10!
10 on the board!
We got a...
Victory Royale!
Fortnite about to get down.
Get down!
Wait are you doing Dumont right now?
PP are you doing Dumont?
PP!
I'm not.
Okay okay I'll get Dumont then.
Alright.
I was gonna get a...
What's his name?
I do the higher level bosses.
You do the mediums then.
The mediums are like Beacon and...
Aqua, Patalia...
Okay where the fuck is...
I need to make a shield.
Dumont, Power, Alpha boss.
I'm like too reckless.
I just fell through the map.
And I'm in the water.
And I'm dead.
Oh jeez!
Oh what came out of that egg?
Oh a Nox.
Oh nice.
Yeah.
Do we need to use it?
Uhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh What the heck?
Nah.
Where the fuck is...
Where the fuck is Dumont?
Where is he?
Don't know.
Dumont.
Power.
I'm gonna make a shield.
Pull up your map YouTube video.
Where is he?
Okay.
Ow.
I'm gonna make a shield.
Boss.
Yeah I have no balls.
I couldn't catch it.
Don't say that about yourself.
You value outside of your balls.
Balls are all I had Matt.
I just need you to know.
No.
You're so much more than that.
You're so much more.
You're so much more than just balls.
Guys.
Tell me where the fuck is Dumont.
You're so much more than just balls.
I can't fight him.
He's kind of far.
Where are you right now?
I don't fucking know where I am.
He's like past the bamboo groves.
Oh he's past the bamboo.
I'm not fucking catching that.
Alright I'm just gonna go for Pen King then.
There's another guy on this lake in the middle of the ocean though.
Pen King is on a respawn timer right now.
Oh still?
Probably.
Grintel.
Grintel location.
He's a lagger.
I'm just material boy.
It's better this way.
I can't even fly a freaking pile man.
Bruh.
I figured out where he is.
Oh god that Lunaris is level 32.
Maybe not.
Don't worry we won't forget.
We can take the photo anytime.
We can take it anytime guys.
Do not worry.
I'm not worrying.
See everybody is worrying that we're not doing the baby things right now.
Like we're doing the hard work.
Yeah we're playing the long game.
No one is believing us.
The base level was like...
I don't know how many points but seems like a lot of points.
Oh my god.
I got the chillit already right?
I got the chillit.
Oh my god that was way too many.
I'm just gonna make a storage right here.
I don't feel like walking all the way back.
You made too many wood.
No there's like so much wood that I immediately became over encumbered.
It's like a thousand.
Woof.
Okay I'll put this back here.
It's alright.
Guys you're supposed to believe in us.
Like you said not aesthetics.
I'm just gonna catch these random pals for levels.
Like I can literally...
I'm almost close to a level 30 chicken guys.
Believe in us.
Let's go.
Well I mean you have to be...
I'm so close.
Holy shit do we have no pals that are picking stuff up?
Oh my god.
I'm not in charge of bases.
That stuff really works.
Yeah it's terrible.
We also have like two of them.
We have the Lizmonk and Vixie just stuck downstairs the whole time.
Yeah.
I think it's this way.
I'm looking at the map to make sure where the fuck this place is.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
I need...
Fox tell me where I am.
Help me.
How much high quality pal oil you got?
Uh...
Only regular pal fluids.
Dammit drops it I think.
Selene might have some...
Fuck me.
I need some pal fluids.
Okay what do you need me for?
High quality pal oil.
I have pal fluids.
Is that what you need?
I need high quality pal oil.
High quality pal oil.
Yeah.
No I don't have any.
Okay.
Don't worry.
You'll get there.
Yeah we'll get there.
It's like when I had to keep calling Cassidy McCree.
McCree Cassie.
I believe in you.
Okay.
Uh...
Where is this guy?
Which bosses are you guys going after right now?
I'm going for...
Where is this guy?
Grintail.
Okay.
Oh he drops high quality pal oil too.
Does he?
Grintail?
Yeah yeah yeah.
I think I might be able to just buy some.
Am I going the right way?
I can't tell.
I'm just swimming in it.
Okay cool.
Guys am I going the right way?
I'm just riding in the ocean.
Oh shit.
Oh shit my dire wolf is dying!
Oh fuck!
No!
Oh shit.
Okay.
Hey can you stop not being caught?
My dire wolf is dead.
My ass.
Yeah you have to farm it.
You can't buy it.
No I'm pretty sure you can buy it from one area.
Oh.
Um.
Okay.
Nobody's done...
I'm gonna buy some armor.
Azurobe right?
I'll do Azurobe.
Guys I might die in the water.
That's not good.
That's called drowning.
I might drown.
It's got a special name.
Just one big slurry.
There's an island.
There's an island right there.
Keep swimming!
If you die in the water does that make the price go up?
For like the gamer girl?
Well it's the ocean.
It's the looted.
Please!
I should be able to.
I should have enough HP to live through this.
Oh I do not have enough HP to live through this.
Oh no.
There was hope.
Briefly.
There was brief hope.
No I'm almost at the island too!
Oh wait wait I can crawl.
I can crawl to land.
Pain.
Misery.
Absolution.
Can I crawl to- I can.
Oh I'm just dead.
Wait unless- wait I can!
I can crawl to land!
It'll be fine.
And then she slowly dies on land.
No!
My island!
So I was like don't give up!
Guys I think I might give up right here.
I didn't know how to get to- I was lost!
I got so lost.
Oh no.
It's okay I can find my items.
I just need to crawl to land right now.
Bro I swear I just brought so much to the base and now it's all gone.
What did it go?
Did someone make the- pick up the Nightwing saddle?
Nope.
Guys I found the island.
Stone I mean.
I can get my items back.
Cause I'm on land now.
I was like how do you get lost when you have a map?
I just wanted to get there faster!
Well the stone is gone.
Oh shit!
I can respawn here!
Yeah I'd be using this stone to make balls.
Oh my god.
My whole life I've been working for these stones.
Oh my god okay.
I figured it out.
That's fucking capitalism.
Stone cold.
Cause I'm a little cold right now.
My shirt.
I lost my shirt.
Okay I need to replace my wolf.
I don't need you anymore.
Alright I'm gonna use the bathrobe right back.
Good luck.
Don't fall in.
Don't forget to check your balls.
Check before you get wrecked.
Oh shit dire wolf's okay.
I only got my first dire wolf.
Oh we got a stone here.
Nice.
Wait you know what?
I'm gonna go back to the Oh my god did you just one shot him?
What's wrong with you?
My pals are too aggressive.
That's like the worst part is like you get to a certain like That's one thing that Nintendo did right with Pokemon is that you get to a certain level and it just makes it so you can catch stuff easily without like the lift monks.
Because all my pals just one shot everything and then it's like impossible.
Back!
Oh shit.
Can anyone like... does anyone have a quill burn on them right now and can you give it to me?
Uh oh.
Oh no.
I just want a quill burn.
What is a quill burn?
The fire... not the fire burn.
One of the dragons for flight.
Mmm mmm mmm.
Did you just cancel my saddle?
Yeah.
Well I didn't cancel anyone's saddle.
There was nothing in here.
There's a cowardly victim right here.
Oh yeah there was nothing.
Alright you're right.
I'm making a saddle.
I didn't cancel no saddle.
Wow you're gonna blame a Vtuber?
Your chat will not like that.
I can't believe your chat's not gonna like that.
No they will like that.
They'll spam evilge.
Alright let's see.
I'm gonna grab get my shit back.
Dying was a strat.
It made me close enough to the end.
I'm gonna go suit to the boss.
Use the hound.
I am not using this boar to ride him fast.
I'm using this boar to mine.
I'm almost at the boss out here.
Wait Shufar what level are you right now?
29.
Oh you can catch the Mamos.
You can like kill the Mamos thing soon.
But I wanna make a gun first.
And I also need to make high...
I need ingots to make high resistant...
...
armor and then I can go and buy high quality metal.
So I can make a gun and then I can buy ammo.
And then I can kill everything.
There's so much to this.
Yeah but we're not supposed to kill everything.
We're supposed to catch things.
But I can kill them and then catch them cause I'm killing them.
Ah wait.
Where's the logic?
Wait.
There's my stuff though.
Boom.
So I was like I wanna make a gun first.
A true American.
He's Canadian!
In no time.
Alright nice I got my stuff.
Okay.
You're free Abu.
That's all it is.
Where the fuck is the Grintail?
It's right here.
Efficiency.
I wanna get a flying pal so bad.
I wanna get that...
...Quilvern.
I wonder where the closest one is.
The closest one is like near the bridge area.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Like one of the bridges from what I remember.
Canada is simply North United States.
It's America's hat.
Okay.
Should be near here.
Where's that live monk statue?
Oh god I'm gonna fucking drown again.
Why?
No not the fuck.
Not this again.
Yeah I should probably spec into way quite a bit.
I don't know.
I have found my purpose.
Well.
I drowned here.
I've had more eggs.
Why did I drown here?
Why is there an energy here?
Grab that.
Why did I have to fall?
Have we pet anything yet?
No.
And we're petting stuff.
We can just grab all our pals and start petting them.
At the end.
Like at the last 30 minutes just start petting.
Nah they removed that feature for North America.
We couldn't be trusted with it.
What petting pals?
Petting pals?
What do you guys do?
What do we do?
What do you do with them?
Yeah.
Dude you don't know about that there's like so many games out of Japan where they have like a petting feature.
Whether it's like for animals or for people question mark.
But like they just remove that feature.
It's not manly enough.
Wait what are you guys doing with the petting feature?
Are we?
Yeah I'm concerned now.
What are we doing with the petting feature?
We're removing that.
I've said too much.
Oh no.
Are we bad people?
Are we the bad guys?
Yeah.
Alright.
I died but at least I died where I wanted to be.
Out of the fucking water.
Over here.
Stack dog.
Get over here.
Giving them the cake.
Guys we might be 12 now.
But like the moment we hit our fucking breaking point.
It's gonna go so fast.
Once we start petting the pals we're gonna be in first.
Like you guys might be like wow you guys are only 12.
But because this is a long game.
Trust the process.
We built the foundation.
We built this dirty house.
I was like trust the process.
And I'm like where am I?
Now enough about that.
Now you trust the process.
I figured out where I am.
Yeah.
Yeah get him.
I found the tail.
I found Grimtail.
What the?
Oh shit that's a...
Oh he's level 17.
Wait he's level 17?
Oh you don't have to...
Oh my god you're level 10.
I didn't even realize.
Did you kill him?
No no I meant like my fucking wolf is level 10.
It's okay I got you.
Level 10?
Yeah cause I forgot I killed the other one accidentally.
Uh you don't lose your pals when you die.
No but he died cause I drowned him accidentally.
Oh so you put him in rehabilitation.
Oops.
So I had to replace him for a little bit.
Go chillin go.
I need to go make the...
Man I need a flying mount.
Okay.
Yeah I've been working on that too.
I'm just gonna go grab one of the shitty pigeons from the start.
That's a good idea.
A shitty pigeon?
That's all I got okay?
That's all I have.
Beggars can't be choosers.
That's a good idea.
Go fox go.
I don't have a weapon still cause I keep...
Woah!
He fucking almost one shot me holy shit.
Do you have a shield?
No.
We don't need shields.
Shields are for losers.
I say as I'm about to die.
Oh wait do we still need people?
Do we have all of our people?
No we need 10.
I think we still need...
10?
No we need 20.
Oh shit really?
We need 20 in the viewers range.
Wait can I catch him?
He's definitely dead.
Oh okay cool.
Not my fault.
I caught two more humans.
Nice.
More balls less shields.
That's right.
I'm gonna make a shield.
Please don't get involved.
Please.
There's just too much stuff going on.
We have so much shit.
Oh my god.
Lord.
Cause none of the pals are picking up the items.
So our base is just like...
It's time for you to pick it up.
It's in shambles.
Come on.
Come on!
Please at least give me that.
I got it!
One!
Clip it!
I got Grintail!
I'm dead though but I got Grintail.
That's all that matters.
What is my purpose?
You mind rock.
Oh no.
I did my job.
Okay now they grabbed my shit again.
Why are we winging it?
Because their fire pokmon is not cooking half the time.
Oh.
That's not good.
It's time to grab more.
Sounds like that would.
I might make another base and just have it only for iron and stuff.
Yeah.
Cause I need it for stuff.
Okay where's my...
That's fine.
My other die will be sixteen.
Come on.
Alright we got...
Okay we got Grintail.
I need the Azurobe.
Let me still figure out where the fuck Azurobe is.
Um he's near the bridge.
Near the bridge?
He spawns in the water.
Okay.
Alright that doesn't really help me too much but I get it.
Uh sorry the...
The bridge that's to like the north west of our house.
North west of our house?
Mmhmm.
Head to the bridge and then go to the water that's to the west of the bridge.
Where's west?
This way.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab my stuff real fast.
Uh...
Why use boar?
Boar fast.
Look how fast I'm demolishing this rock with the boar.
Yeah.
Trust in the process.
Boar is crazy.
Just trust the process.
Yeah trust the fucking process.
Come on.
We might not be like very high placement right now.
But like in the last hour you're gonna see a skyrocket.
Yeah.
It's over here.
Wait where even is the...
Oh there it is.
Okay.
Where's my stuff?
Where did I... Oh there it is.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the fire guy?
Oh he's over there.
What is he doing?
Wait there's an effigy right here too.
And now we deliver.
Come here.
Make...
Make ingot.
You have literally one task.
Just make ingot.
Okay.
Just...
Spank it into them.
I trust the process.
And then do nothing.
I think a lot of them are just getting fucked on pathing.
Yeah.
I think our base is like so...
Our base is gonna get real fucking crazy to be fair.
I'm just gonna get rid of some stuff.
Ah shit I didn't want to kill him.
Uh like we're not really using like the mill and shit.
So I'm just gonna get rid of them.
If we need them we can just rebuild them.
Isolated island cavern.
Is that part of the...
Of the dungeons we have to do?
No.
Wait why can't I pick up more of these.
Oh there it all goes.
Where the fuck is the...
It should be up here.
Okay.
I need to get the...
Nightwing Okay I'm gonna try and find the azurope right now.
Is it because of these fuckers?
Okay.
Where the fuck...
Oh, it's this way.
How many hours do we have left?
I don't have my timer up.
An hour and 45.
An hour and 45?
I think at an hour we gotta start actually doing a bunch of these.
Aye aye, captain.
I will stone production through the roof.
Damn.
I'm catching all the stone.
I'm gonna make a weapon for... holy shit this is laggy.
Wait, did you go back to the base?
Yeah, I'm destroying things right now.
Cause it's really bad.
Okay, I'll grab this.
How dare you ask me how I'm doing?
I'm mining a rock.
What do you think?
How do you think she's doing right now?
How do you think?
This is my life now.
I'm so slow.
Why is it so laggy?
Oh my god.
Oh, I didn't even have a shield.
I thought you said you didn't need one.
No, I was just... I was just a ha ha joke.
Hee hee.
I was just testing you guys.
It was just hee hee funny.
Just doing a little hee hee ha ha.
Yeah, it was just a joke.
Why are you guys so serious?
Why are you so serious?
Why are you so serious over here?
Where's the... where's the crafting table?
Uh, there's two.
There's one right by the Pell Box.
And then, uh, which crafting table?
I need like a regular crafting.
Is it just this left?
Yeah.
Okay.
There's a... hold on.
I'm building another one.
I'm building a high quality one.
I'm just gonna make this...
Or I was trying to anyway.
Here we go.
Alright, high quality crafting table right here.
Nice.
And then the speed should go up too.
We don't have like 30 crafting tables.
Wait, where's the... where's the other one?
Right here.
Yeah, the mine.
The stone mine.
Yep.
Go for it.
Okay, now I should make my shield.
Okay, who can help me craft?
Gathering... gathering all my other pals because...
I am rock.
Gathering bitches.
Okay.
I am become rock.
Yay!
Yippee!
I'm just glad to be a great great asset.
High ladder.
You matter!
One of these days I hope my stamina runs out when I jump off this cliff.
I have our... I finally have a weapon guys.
I'm doing it.
Look at that mount.
Beautiful.
Finally have a weapon.
What happened?
Wait, what happened to the fire?
I'll put another one here.
I feel like we should make another like... what is it called?
The ore thing?
Ore thing?
Oh, you mean the furnace?
Well, actually we should ask... we should ask Cher to make the better one.
Oh yeah.
I think that they... I think you actually have it unlocked already.
Do you have like the nice furnace?
I think it's level...
Let's find out.
I don't think so.
Hold on.
What level is that one?
I get it at 34.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Alright.
What level are you right now?
We need like three more POW beds.
Our guys are fucking stressed out.
Got it.
Okay.
Now I have arrows.
Let's go.
Alright.
Craft craft craft craft craft craft craft craft.
My job of company morale.
Yes.
After 20 years, I finally did it.
I have a weapon.
Yay.
MGP.
Now I can be a true asset.
I have high quality POW all over.
I have six POW all over by the way.
I can't believe she's following my footsteps.
I can't believe it.
I'm learning so much.
Is there any more POW... I need to make some POW balls.
They grow by so fast.
POW ball time.
That's not it.
Wait, that's a claw farm.
Did it not...
Oh, there you go.
Uh...
Here.
I'm gonna put more chests so I can give you guys the...
The high quality POW oil.
Okay.
Alright.
Put that away.
Okay.
That fixed the fire problem.
It's like making fire now.
Yay.
Now we got fire.
We have discovered fire.
We got fire.
Got fire now.
When do I get crossbow?
I need a POW that can fucking...
Oh shit.
I already have crossbow.
Cool.
I'm gonna make it.
No.
I can't cause I don't have any.
Alright.
Get over here.
Oh wait.
Not you.
Actually, I heard sweet butt is like the strongest shit ever.
Did you... Did you beat Azerob?
Azerob?
Nope.
Okay.
Are you doing Azerob right now?
Maybe head that way.
Maybe.
I'm thinking about it.
Yeah.
Go look for it.
Okay.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna go grab the other stuff then.
Okay.
Do I have arrows?
Let's see.
I have Giga Spears.
Oh.
I don't have Giga Spears.
It's the one after some Mega Spears.
There it is.
Don't have Mega Spears.
Nevermind.
I still need a Quillburn.
Our like Wood and Stone production is really good though.
Okay.
Where is Quillburn?
Thank you.
I think so too.
Quillburn power.
Great job.
Amazing.
Actually goaded.
Where is... Where do you unlock?
Okay.
I need to find a Quill... Where to find Quillburn.
Where are you?
Wait.
Not Quillburn.
What's not that one?
Okay.
Dragon.
Pal world.
Mount.
Fuck this.
I need a flyer.
Yeah.
When do you get a saddle though?
That's the other question.
The saddle for him?
Van Worm.
There we go.
I need to find a Van Worm.
Yeah.
They're near the desert I think.
Okay.
I can do that.
I could be wrong.
Alright.
I'm getting pal... I'm getting a Van Worm.
That's the closest.
It's like next to us right?
Right here.
One more rock.
Oops.
That should be where Van Worm lives.
That's fine.
Van Worm.
I'm just flying away for a second.
Let's see.
Van, van, van, van, van, van, van, van, van, van, van.
Van Worm should be here.
I also want to get a Van Worm.
Van Worm.
He's... It's where I am at.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait.
Let me look on the map.
Should be.
From what my Google tells me.
Uh... Oh wait.
Can I see where you are on the map?
Oh wait.
Yeah.
I can.
Okay.
It's near where I was heading to anyway.
That's where I was going anyway.
I saw a mozzer.
The mozzerina.
Perfect.
The fuck are you?
Where are you?
Van Worm.
There it is.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I have a bow now.
It's fucking right.
Get over here.
Come on.
Oh shit!
Oh that's not our shield.
That's fine.
That's my shield.
More rock.
Woo!
Oh.
Pal merchant just died.
That sucks for him.
No!
Please get over here.
Oh actually.
I guess I should probably catch them.
Oh my god.
That's...
If they're out here anyway.
I should probably catch them.
That's unfortunate.
Please.
No!
I can't aim!
I'm having a little bit of trouble aiming right now.
Are you fucking... Are you...
No!
Guys.
Can someone pick me up?
Please.
I really don't want to rock back here.
Peepee can you pick me up?
Yeah.
Wait.
Pick you up from where?
Pick me up.
I'm down.
Oh shit.
Where are you?
Let me find you.
I'm where the van worms are.
Please.
Uh.
Okay.
My wolf killed... No!
My wolf killed them!
No!
Peepee please.
What?
I'm just catching these men.
Okay.
Never mind.
I'm gonna give up.
I don't think I can reach you in time.
No!
Rest in peace.
My wolf killed him too!
Was it a shiny?
No.
It was... I just wanted a van worm.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's see.
Where did I die?
It wasn't so far.
Why didn't it open a window?
Holy shit.
It's hot in my room.
Passion.
Catching van worms is a... a struggle.
It's stressful, man.
I'm just trying to catch humans.
Alright.
You know what?
Go out there dude.
Alright.
I'm back.
Get the ball!
Where the fuck?
Oh my god.
I was getting shot at.
Please.
Why?
Why is this man refusing to die?
Get in the ball.
If you ask him nicely.
Get in the ball, man.
Please.
Guys.
He clearly didn't consent to this.
Pretty please.
Can you get in the ball?
Sentient invisible gun.
He clearly didn't consent to it.
Pretty please.
Can I put you in my human circus?
Human circus?
We have like 20 yet?
Thank you.
Isn't that one of the goals?
That we have to put them in a little cage?
We need 20.
I was like, do we have 20?
I just caught 2 or 3 I think.
I think we're far from 20.
I have like... I have like 3?
I think 3 or 2 on me.
Now I need to find a fucking bam worm again.
God damn it.
I wish I had a chillit.
Then I could like swim over there.
I really need to get some pal that can do logistics.
I can give you the chillit.
Oh for real?
I don't need it.
Oh okay.
Sweet.
Just need it.
Next time you're at the base.
Yeah I'll just put it in the thing.
If you can make it one of the pals at the base.
Yeah.
I'll grab it.
Thank you.
Fuck is a bam worm.
It's a pocha berry.
Boom.
Okay I hope for now we have enough rock.
We have 800 rock.
It's gonna have to amount to something right?
Has to be.
We must be able to get something out of it.
Oh sh...
So I killed those two bam worms and I never found any left or not.
No.
Please.
Let's see.
These are kinda useless.
Can I replace?
Boss is somewhere around here.
Oh the bees!
Oh wait no nevermind.
Oh wait there's an azerope right here.
Just kidding.
Fuck.
Yeah that's the one.
Oh there it is.
BAM WORM!
Get em!
Go!
Wait that's not mine.
There it is.
No.
No please don't.
Please don't shoot him.
Please don't.
No!
Stupid silly.
Fuck I'm gonna catch you.
I see we're doing amazing progress.
Yeah.
I caught another.
I'm gonna catch a human.
I'm gonna kill you though.
Shit.
No!
What the fuck are you doing?
My bad.
Come.
Make ore.
Alright I got two.
It's okay.
I got two syndicate thugs out of this.
I might not have got a van worm but I caught two syndicate thugs.
Make ore.
I'm so sad.
I just want a van worm.
Are you still in the van worm area?
Yes.
Yes I am.
Oh dear.
They killed the only one I found.
Oh hey there's an electric egg.
Alright.
What do you mean my kneecaps are backwards?
What does that even mean?
What does that?
What kind of insult is that?
What?
Hello?
Where are you?
Please it's night time.
Okay it's time.
Please don't kill him.
Please.
That's all I ask.
Looking for a fast travel point over here.
Okay.
I'm gonna use my mega sphere.
Oh I got one!
I have five balls.
Wait.
I got van worm!
Yay!
I have discovered flight!
GG.
Okay there you go.
I discovered flight.
Okay let me put the chillant for you.
Okay.
Thank you!
Uhhh chillant.
I replaced it with a life monk.
So is there a life monk over here?
Hold on.
Okay thanks.
And then or lift monk and then I'll put a van worm here.
And then...
That's fine.
Let's see.
I need to make a...
Where's the pal craft?
Pal crafter.
Pal crafter?
Yeah pal gear crafter.
I need to use it.
Oh uh you gotta remake it.
Oh.
Alright let me...
Wait do I have it right?
It's right here but I'm using it.
Oh it is?
Where are you?
Oh there you are.
Okay.
What are you making?
I'm gonna help too.
Thank you.
We'll all work together.
We're all gonna work together.
We got this.
We can do this.
We're all in this together.
Okay I'm gonna go kill the... I'm gonna go catch the azerob.
Actually what's... how much time do we have left actually?
One hour.
I think I have an hour mark.
We gotta like speed run some captures.
Yeah we gotta do shit.
Yeah.
We're at an hour and a half.
Once I make my pistol like speed run capture shit.
Oh shit.
Hey.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright now I'm gonna make my saddle.
Where the fuck is the vanworm's saddle?
We need spears.
No!
There it is.
Oh I just made it.
Don't let me die here.
Come on dude.
Not here.
I need ingots.
No!
Okay I need...
Not you.
My quest for vanworm also ends early.
No!
Where the fuck is our fire?
Where the fuck are our fire ones?
I don't know.
Where's our fire?
Let's see.
Just trust the process man!
It's okay!
Just trust the process!
No!
When you keep saying trust the process, I'm starting to trust the process less and less.
That's when you gotta trust the process even more.
Wait, does vanworm do fire?
Oh shit it does!
Get out of here.
I didn't even realize that.
Guys, the bad ones are fire.
I don't give a fuck about you.
What kind of fire?
What level fire is it?
It's level 1, but our other ones aren't kindling it right now.
Alright, do your thing.
I need...
Who's hungry over there?
Oh, it's Eepie.
It's Eepie.
I thought I was stuck.
Because I kept seeing it was hungry.
I'm like, man, then go eat something!
This fucking neat forehead!
Wait, what level is the chillit saddle on?
Am I blind?
Where's the chillit saddle?
I need like six more ingots if anyone has extra.
If I can make my van more sadder.
Wait, do I get the XP for capture if I direct pallets into my bar I haven't captured yet?
I think no, you don't get the capture rate, right?
You don't get it.
Let me see.
Let me grab this one.
I might see it.
Very slowly.
Nope.
I do not.
Fuck.
If you don't trust us, you don't believe in us.
You're not real.
You're not true ones.
Yeah, what the hell?
How can you not trust this process?
It's flawless.
Do you not see our long game here?
I know.
This is all... like, we're not doing short term here.
We're all... we have long term goals.
Yeah.
We've worked really hard towards this goal.
Exactly.
Tell him.
Alright, please be fast, you're a van worm, so I can ride you.
Please.
I need, like, two more.
I need one more.
Blow!
Wait, where's the palegirl?
Palegir bench now?
Oh, is that one over there?
No, that's repair.
Oh, wait, there it is.
Nice.
Okay, I finally...
Right, I died a lot for this win.
Like, come on, man.
No!
Oh, shit!
I'm sorry, can I help you?
Okay, I don't think... I don't think we...
Oh, I'm sorry, I didn't know you were alive.
Okay, thank god.
Okay, now I can... I can make it now.
My fucking saddle.
Oh, Pen King!
Fuck yeah, alright.
Alright, do we get... we got Pen King?
Yeah.
Oh, we did it!
Did you get it?
Yeah.
Did you see it, Sad?
Did you see it?
Oh, wait, no, we didn't beat Pen King.
We hatched Pen King.
Very different.
Oh, we had to capture it.
No, that's different.
Very different.
That's very different.
I was gonna be like, sure, I did it!
I can probably go fight Pen King now if he's respawned.
He's probably respawned.
He probably is.
It's been, like, two hours.
He's probably... It's only been almost three hours.
He's probably back.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Is there a hatching list?
There's no hatching list, I'm pretty sure.
Is there?
No.
No?
I don't know.
I don't think there's an achievement for hatching.
There's only four things we need to hatch that give us...
Don't touch that!
...achievements.
What is it?
Anubis, something, something, something, something.
I thought that was for breeding.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Or unless that counts.
Anubis, I know you can do even from early game, but I'm...
Yeah, you need the fat green guy and the queen bee.
Okay, small settlement.
Where the fuck did I see the azer... oh, there it is.
Are you going to get the azerope, or am I getting the azerope?
I have to go pick up my stuff.
If you get there first, then you can get the azerope.
Okay, I'll get the azerope then.
Help.
Oh, dude, the azerope.
I'm having a clerical error right now where I can't seem to... oh, shit.
I can't seem to stay alive.
Whoa!
Shiny!
Oh, second shiny!
Extra points.
Whoa!
He, like, spawned next to me!
Ow.
What shiny is it?
The fuck?
Oh, shiny fuck.
Love it.
I was like, what am I hearing?
Oh, shit.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I might die.
No!
Please, please, let me catch you.
Please, please.
Clip it!
I got him!
Yay!
That's fine.
I got the fuck.
And I died next to the respawn beacon.
I knew you could do it.
It was worth it.
Oh, what the fuck was that?
Boom.
What was that?
I leveled up.
I'm finally managing to kill stuff.
Oh, finally.
You're strong enough.
I'm trying, man.
I'm here.
Nice.
I can't figure out the rhythm to dodge abilities.
Oh, yeah.
Because you have to figure out 200.
Yeah, but I feel like my ping isn't consistently high either.
Because sometimes I'm like, okay, you know what?
I think I figured it.
If I just dodge earlier, then sometimes it's too early.
I'm like, what?
How?
You'll never figure it out.
You'll always be guessing.
All right.
Let's see.
But if it's far below me, I don't care.
I can get heat.
All right.
Are you getting...
Oh, wait.
Are you getting the Azeroth now?
Or...
I'm still picking up my gear.
All right.
I'll go grab it now.
God, this serpent is stupid slow.
I wanted to use the chillit, but since I haven't caught one, it doesn't show up in my saddle list.
Oh, you have?
Okay.
That sucks.
Rip.
It does suck.
All right.
Rip.
Now I can kill you.
Where is it?
All right.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Fuck.
I keep going the wrong way.
Oh, dizzy.
I'm gonna get this one.
I'm flying.
I'm soaring.
What the...
Oh, shit.
No, stop.
I don't want to die.
All right.
Kill my pal.
He can take it.
Here we go.
This way.
No, I didn't forget about the reincarnate.
I literally marked him.
Don't worry, chat.
Yeah, we could do those group votes.
A photo's easy.
Yeah, it's just a photo.
Yes.
Wait, do we have a camera option or, like, does photo mean like we just take a screenshot of it?
What?
I don't know.
I'm sure a clip will do just fine.
There he is.
Azeroth.
Ouch.
Dude, I don't know what to tell you, man.
My balls just fly through the wood.
What am I doing?
Your balls are just too smooth.
Yeah.
Oh my god!
I got hit there!
How?
I'm having ball troubles.
Oh no!
Not the ball!
No!
Please!
Please don't!
Don't kill me!
Please!
How am I missing?
Okay.
I gotta focus on dodging now.
Please, Crintail.
For the love of god.
No!
You killed him!
How could you?
Will you kill the boss?
No, my Van Wurm.
I was like, really?
I was about to catch him.
And then my Pal...
My Pal went a little bit murder-y.
It's okay.
I know how that feels.
No, the Van Wurm.
Oh, okay.
So, thank god.
We still have the Pen King.
Even if we kill the boss now, we can still retry.
We have like...
Yeah, but they respawned though.
Yeah.
So, worst case, if we try now, we can try again in like an hour.
Woo!
Bro, I keep dying!
Why?
Please!
No more catching pals.
Only killing Pal.
My new motto.
Oh, I could get this human.
He's only level 4.
I might get killed.
How many more do we need for humans?
Give him a new home.
Cause I have 4 on me.
You have 4 on you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
I have 6 humans.
We need 20 in total.
Where's the weapons workbench at?
I don't think we have one.
We did.
Oh, we did?
Oh, yeah.
We disassembled it.
We got it.
I need 3 nails.
Rintel, no!
You're drowning!
I can make nails.
I can make some too.
I'm just wondering.
Take this from me, sweeper!
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
I'm just killing these humans and this god is just like, whatever, bro.
You do you.
Yes!
Okay.
That's fine.
55.
Where are you going?
Stop.
Azeroth!
Done!
I got another!
Clip, clip, clip!
I got Azeroth!
Alright, what do I need to do to make those bear traps?
I think I should go catch those...
The lamb balls?
Lamb balls.
There's nothing in those cages.
Bear trap, I need ingots.
Alright, we can make ingots.
We got Azeroth, Rintel, Wait, did we get the doom mod already?
Oh, doom mod.
Oh, I'm gonna go fucking get the doom mod.
Fuck this.
I should be able to make it.
We're sleeping?
Yeah, make something easy target.
What do you mean?
Alright.
I need to figure out where doom mod is.
Get those points.
Lamb balls are struggling.
I know, I know.
I'm kidding.
Lamb balls are struggling.
I know.
Always play Struggle City.
Bye!
I'm talking about my balls.
I'm having performance anxiety.
The balls are getting smaller.
They're shriveling up.
They're turning to marbles.
You're not helping chat.
You're making them nervous.
Chat, say something negative about your balls.
It'll make us feel better.
You caused this problem.
You have to fix it.
Take your responsibility.
Okay, let's see.
I need to...
What do I need to do?
I swear, I don't usually struggle like this.
What the fuck is Doom mod?
Where's my...
Where's my Google maps?
Doom mod, ice, frost...
They spelled one of the boss's names wrong.
Oh, it's here.
Yeah, it's like DOOMBUD.
Okay, I know where to go.
Okay.
I'm gonna fucking just ride all the way there.
Okay, I'm gonna steal your gigasphere.
This is gonna be important.
Whoever's gigasphere is this, I'm stealing it.
Take it.
Hey, what the fuck?
It wasn't even yours!
What do you mean it's not mine?
I know it wasn't yours.
I literally made it.
No, it wasn't.
Oh captain, my captain.
I don't think it was yours.
It's okay.
Maybe I just won't kill any bosses.
Wait, okay.
Wait, I'm stuck.
What the fuck?
My Vanworm was stuck.
Oh, there you go.
Vanworm, where are you?
My Vanworm is like, crooked.
My Vanworm's slanted.
I'm back to mining to meet.
My Vanworm is bent.
Guys, stop looking!
My Vanworm's slanted.
Stop looking.
Stop!
He's trying his best, okay?
Leave him alone.
He couldn't handle the thighs.
Okay, did you guys get- I'm not a good day.
I'm gonna get the pen king.
Fuck this.
He's like, right here anyway.
Yeah,
they usually slant to one side.
You seem like an expert to slanted Vanworms.
Oh, I'm hungry.
Fuck, okay.
I don't wanna fight them.
Alright.
I'm gonna go back to... I'm gonna build bear traps.
Nice.
How many ink do I need?
I need...
How many... wait, was it ten or five?
Wait, I have no more crap.
How did... I already used 93 arrows?
Oh no, I actually put away some of my arrows.
Money's tight.
I can check.
I can check the list.
If anybody knows offhand though, how many land balls...
How many land balls?
Was it five or ten?
Five.
I need to capture five at the same time.
Easy.
Wait, what do they mean by at the same time?
Means like...
In the same trap?
Wait, I actually don't know.
Can someone like clarify that?
Wait, I think we just make five traps.
And we like trap five.
Can someone clarify that for us?
Who knows what that fucking means.
I think you just keep the traps up.
Like you... I think you just build the trap.
Oh, and then like have...
You just need to capture five.
Oh, same...
I got the pen king.
Guys, I got the pen king!
Clip, clip, clip!
Let's go!
Oh, clip it!
Clip, clip, clip!
Catch five at the same time.
I guess we could ask the admin what they mean by that.
Because actually I'm confused.
Clarify.
Yeah, I'm actually confused now.
Excuse me, can you clarify please?
Actually.
Please.
Where is it?
I'm stuck.
Okay, there you go.
Oh, fuck.
Five traps with...
So many.
Oh, five traps with five different lambels.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
All right, that's fine.
Yeah.
Okay, I need to find...
All right, where am I?
I need to go this way.
All right, I'm heading over to the...
Doom mod!
Doom mod, get over here.
I don't need...
I can get arrows later.
Wait, there's an effigy.
Nice.
I'll grab that effigy actually.
Oh my God.
What's so funny?
What's a effigy?
I think we're going to have to make it go into character place this time.
All right.
Take your own character.
Oh, I think here, we...
What's going on here for a second?
Wait, wait.
Uhh, Oh my God.
Wait wait wait wait.
Wait wait, I'm still doing it.
What just happened?
What the fuck?
I'm sure for sure.
Dang!
My slime was leaking out of every pore.
Oh no.
Hey, what level is this?
Level 30, I can't...
But this is good, right?
It's supposed to be juicy.
And you wouldn't want to be dry and like all crunchy and stuff.
Ew.
Wait.
Can you imagine?
I really don't want to.
I don't want to.
No thanks.
I just... I don't know.
I don't think... I don't know.
I don't know about that one.
You know, maybe...
Okay, what was the one that we needed to do together?
That dungeon.
The ravine one, right?
Do we want to do the ravines?
The ravine dungeon?
If someone can find them.
Yeah, we need to find a ravine dungeon.
Yeah, one of us find the ravine dungeon, we can do it.
Alright, I'm gonna ask Google.
I love asking Google.
Yeah, if you find it, I fly and try to...
Is there a... the ravine grotto?
You can look at the word doc.
Cause we're like right there.
I might be standing in front of it, even.
I mean, you still have to... you have to find it still.
We have to find it.
It's not like it's just there.
Wait, how much time we have left, actually?
An hour.
Okay, I'm gonna... after an hour, I'm gonna try... I'm gonna power level to 30.
So my chicken can be level 30.
After I get that doom one.
Come on, stay in the ball, stay in the ball.
Shit.
Pals are stored in the balls.
No!
Ugh.
No, I think the spot that I died at is right in front of the dungeon.
So I'm just gonna go there and check.
Yeah.
I mean, just mark the dungeon and then we can head over.
Together.
I'm like... I'm like... I can just find it in...
a waypoint.
Wait, can I open this?
Yeah.
Okay.
Nice.
It's arrows.
That's exactly what I needed.
Recon!
Wait a minute, actually.
Yeah, I don't care about these guys.
Oh, none to level 34.
I need to get to the fucking...
Where am I?
Am I close?
Am I close to doom one?
Doom one...
Am I close to you?
Oh wait, can I grab that ingot now?
Did he finish making it?
Where am I?
Nobody made it!
Okay, why are these tiles so fucking worthless?
But we have still fire pals.
Why is no one making ingots?
Why are these tiles so fucking worthless?
Whoa!
Make the ingot!
No, they matter.
They matter!
Chill, chill, chill, chill.
They matter.
They matter!
Bro, don't push them too far!
Dude!
We don't have the butcher knife!
We can't hide the evidence!
Butchering pals is not an exploit.
It is aboveboard.
I mean, they know what they did.
It's more like what they didn't do.
Isn't one of the achievements is all of us have to butcher a... pal?
Wait, really?
Is that global?
Is it?
I think it's global.
I mean, we can do that tomorrow.
Oh no, that's... oh.
Oh no, that's terrible.
That will suck.
So bad.
That would be so terrible for us to do, like, ethically too.
Right?
Yeah.
Alright, pick your lambo.
That's why we catch those five lambos.
Yeah, we just catch them all and then we just butcher them.
Yeah, exactly.
Dude, that's perfect with the traps.
I am at the dungeon.
I'm gonna see if this is the one we want.
I think it is.
This is the...
Ravine Grotto.
Oh, it is.
It is.
Okay.
Yeah, then we can do it.
We can do it now.
I'm heading to a...
Oh, I put a marker.
I don't know if you can see my markers, but I put it on there.
I cannot.
You cannot.
You have to...
Oh, well, it's where I am anyway.
You just stay where you are and then we're heading over.
Yeah.
I know.
What the fuck is the waypoint?
That was good.
Huh?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god.
There it is.
Heading over.
Lambos?
What lambos?
We never had any lambos before.
Exactly.
What?
What do you mean?
Yeah, what do you mean?
Alright, I'm here.
They need like wide open spaces to be happy, so, you know, it'd be unethical for us to keep them, so we just have...
We're gonna have to eat them, you know?
That sounds pretty ethical.
It's the morally right thing to do.
Alright, we're heading over to... Let's all head over to...
Small P.P.
Ravine Grotto.
Yeah, yeah.
But we all have to do it for the dungeon.
Yeah, I know, but you guys are gonna have to wait until I get the thing I need.
Okay.
Alright, what do you...
We have to do it all together?
Yeah, we have to do all of them.
I know.
Alright, how long do you think you'll be ready?
I don't know, soon-ish.
Alright, while you're doing that, I'm gonna...
I'll go back to getting fragments.
I'm gonna try and find...
Doomud still.
Doomud time.
Doomud.
Doodle doodle.
Oh shit, get over here.
Okay, this way.
Here I go.
Doomud.
Make sure the dungeon doesn't despawn though.
It has like a specific time to despawn.
Oh, okay.
Let me see.
I know it does despawn.
Yeah.
Okay.
What happened to the despawns though?
Like the holes?
We have to find...
No, just...
We have to find another hole.
What?
For real?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Cause there's like a timer.
Oh, that sucks.
Okay.
Um...
The amount of time we have until the despawns is...
I found a large scorching egg.
Oh, we got...
We got a ton of time.
It's like 122 minutes.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Easy.
I have a large scorching egg.
Do we have time to hatch it?
Yeah.
Alright.
I found a huge scorching egg.
Oh, okay.
We should hatch that first then.
Yeah.
Even if we don't, we can set it and it will still cook.
I found a quiver.
I'm gonna kill this quiver.
Well, we're gonna have to hatch it.
While we're not around.
It will still cook.
Yeah.
Like, technically, that's not against the rules.
I should hold the egg cooking it.
Technically, that's not against the rules.
Alright.
Wait, is quiver in the list?
I did not write that anywhere.
Let's see.
Quiver in...
Uh...
It is.
Okay.
I'm gonna go catch the quiver right now.
Alright.
Let's hope I don't die.
Let's go.
Oh, wait.
That's my fucking fist.
There you go.
Quiver in.
Boop.
Oh, shit.
He'll be fine.
Oh, shit!
I don't think I'll be fine.
My...
Oh, I don't have arrows.
Why do I keep forgetting to bring arrows?
Please don't kill me.
Trying to catch this man.
Oh, no.
I'm too strong.
He's dead.
Oh, well.
Oh, no.
It is what it is.
No!
Oh, no.
Please, Sweeper.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Alright.
Should be ready.
I'm catching this quiver and I can head over.
I'm already...
I'm still pretty close to it.
So, if you come to this location, you'll be pretty much there.
Oh, yikes.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to catch this quiver and then I'll be ready.
I'm almost there.
Sweeper, go.
No!
Okay.
Yeah.
What is our...
What is our ranking now?
My chat says that our ranking has not been updated.
Well, to be fair, we haven't really been doing any achievements.
We've just been like progressing.
I got quiver and clip, clip.
I got quiver and...
Clip, clip, clip.
Oh, the cutest fucking pal in the game.
I would die for that thing.
Yeah, they're so fucking cute.
Okay.
I'm heading over to dungeon.
I'm away.
I'm loading my inventory.
I'm trying to get this thing.
I'm gonna find the waypoint and then I can be there.
Oh boy, I have some traveling to do.
Don't shy Lillie's there, I'll head on over.
Alright, I'm walking back over.
I'm actually a little bit south of it, so...
Go north of my position.
I'm just grabbing arrows and then I should be good.
I think it's because I left it in one of these boxes, right?
Yeah, I fucking knew it.
Oh, there's a raid!
I heard a passing relaxer.
Oh, that's not good.
I guess we should kill them.
We can catch some of them too.
They give a shit ton of high quality at war.
Oh, there he is!
Yeah, there's a relaxer, he's right here.
How many?
I don't know, I see one.
It might just be one.
He's like AFK.
He's not running over, I think he's stuck.
I think they're actually... I'm just gonna kill this one.
Alright, I'm just gonna kill this one then.
I'm pretty sure he's just stuck.
A raid of one, let's go.
Oh, he is definitely stuck.
Oh shit, we're like, Sarus can breed Anubis.
We've won.
I caught one of the relaxasaurus.
Is the raid done?
I caught one of them.
That's the herd.
There's the other one.
Alright.
It's done, it was two.
Wow, what a big raid.
Alright, let's go, I'm ready.
Okay.
I'm waiting for Shy Lily to get there.
I'm making news.
Got quite some traveling to do.
Alright, I'm making some Giga Spear then.
Yes!
I got my Van Wurm.
Let's go.
Very good.
Yippee!
And then after this, I'm gonna go try and catch those mossos.
Alright, which one, where are you starting off on?
I don't know, which ones have you done?
I've done like the, all like the easy ones up to, I got Penking, Gumas, Weepy, Chillit, Azerob, Grintail, and Quiverne.
So a lot of the ones at the bot, like the bottom are not taken.
The mediums?
10, 10, 10, 20, 20, 30, 100.
Yeah, you can focus the medium then.
What level are you now?
Shrew 4?
31.
Okay.
Yeah, you can tackle the medium.
We've got 200 points it looks like, according to my chat.
We can tackle the medium.
Okay, I'm heading over to PP now for the dungeon.
Okay.
I got you.
Wait, am I wearing the wrong up?
My small PP awaits.
Oh, I can upgrade armor now?
Really?
Oh, I can.
Metal armor.
I'll do that later.
I mean, the dungeon has to be super easy, so it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
All right, let me find you.
All right, I'm heading over to small PP.
Are we all heading over?
Okay.
On my way to small PP.
Come to me.
Let me just unlock the waypoint for whenever we have to be around this area.
You're sure 4?
Is taking a picture global or day one for the resurrected dude?
The resurrected dude is day one.
Okay.
So we need to take a picture.
We're at the one hour mark, so we have to like speed run, start speed running now.
It's better like hours.
Trying to find the entrance again.
At least I'm marked on my map, but it's to the right.
It's over this way.
Okay.
I'm just following you.
It's like this way.
It says we have to complete it together.
I'm coming.
Oh, it's dark now.
Hold on.
Okay, it's over this way.
We're going to catch five humans with level 10 or higher.
I have two humans that are level 10.
Oh.
You guys have level 10?
There's a bunch of syndicates over here.
We can do that later then.
And then it's over here.
It's around this ridge somewhere.
So do we just have to complete the dungeon?
It's dark so I can't really see.
Or catch the person in the dungeon?
We have to complete it.
Just complete Ravine.
So we need to speedrun and get to the end.
It's over... does anybody have a fire pal?
I do.
I can't see shit.
Oh here it is.
It's right here.
Ravine Grotto.
In we go.
My game crashed.
No!
I think if we wait here you can enter the room.
Okay, okay, okay.
My game was a corrupt data.
Everything's falling apart.
No!
I was just there!
I didn't find you guys again.
I can't believe it's all Doki's fault.
That's crazy.
Yeah, wow.
What the heck?
She was trolling this whole time.
I was trolling so hard.
Where the fuck is... okay here.
There we go.
Alright.
I'm back.
I need to find you guys again.
Oh my god I'm back!
Wait, where do I save?
Where does it save me?
I'm loading in.
Thank god I wasn't hosting.
Come on, load faster.
Why is it taking so long?
Guys.
It's taking a while.
This is not good.
Should I restart it?
Do I restart it?
Uh, probably?
Probably?
Cause your internet's still working.
I have no pickaxe.
I have a pickaxe.
Oh my god, did the game fucking crash?
Please.
Please, power.
Should I just go the field bosses then, or...?
I guess, like, what are you guys- wait, do we have to complete it, as in like- we just have to-?
We just have to-?
As in like- All of us have to be at the end?
Okay, okay.
No, I meant like, at the boss.
That's what I meant.
Working towards the boss?
Like we just have to be at the boss together, right?
We just all have to kill the boss together.
Yeah, we can just go find the boss room.
Okay, I'm here!
Oh my god, I can't see though!
Where is it?
Oh, where is it?
Here, I'll come outside.
I don't... I can't see!
Right here.
There you go.
Is it here?
Okay, I'm in.
Nice!
Alright, now we run to the end.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm in.
Doggy.
Doggy's here!
Let's go!
You can use your bird.
I think it's gonna be... Oh no, I think this thing is slower than me walking.
It keeps getting stuck all the time.
I can...
I think we can catch Syndicate though.
We can catch these dudes.
Yeah, but we don't have... It's not like...
It's not...
What we need now.
Why is my...
Why is my little water snake so slow?
You love water.
Go fast.
Go fast, little guy.
Oh, it's cause it's night time.
Losers.
Are we all here?
Almost.
Sorry.
We'll just wait.
We're a bit slow.
We didn't have...
I'm on this little, like, noodle.
This little parasitic noodle.
We'll just wait a little.
Surefour and I are here now.
It's a Wallypop.
He's sleeping.
He's eepy.
He eepy sleepy.
I'm just looking across the way like it's some sort of like Indiana Jones adventure, but it's just Shylalee on the other side.
Oh my god.
Alright, we're here.
Oh no, I'm stuck.
Oh shit, I'm stuck too.
Too fat.
And now we kill.
Now we kill.
Alright, let's go.
Die.
Who's catching this?
Oh, he's so freaking cute though.
I love the sweepers, man.
They're so cute.
I can catch this.
Alright, just this one guy.
I'm gonna take him out right now.
Is his health not going down for anybody else?
No, it is going down.
Oh, okay.
Did we catch Pinkin?
Yeah, we caught the raid.
I caught the boss.
Oh, Pinkin is my guy.
Alright.
Whoa!
You guys almost fucking killed him.
Did we catch him?
We did it!
We finished the dungeon!
Clip, clip, clip!
Clip, clip, clip, clip!
Do we have to take a screenshot or anything?
No, it's just clip.
It says, requires screenshot or clip.
Oh, you already got it.
That's right.
It says, requires screenshot or clip.
So we're good.
Alright, cool.
Do we need to do any other dungeons?
Yeah, we have to find that mountain stream.
Mountain stream?
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna go...
Yeah, you should start doing bosses.
Alright, I know where mountain stream is.
I'll go search for an entrance.
Okay.
I'm just gonna power level the 30.
Real fast.
Oh shit, wait.
I didn't do that in...
I'll attempt to level up a little.
Oh wait!
Lily, can you try and catch level 10 so the ticket thugs...
We need... I have two on me.
So we need three more.
What do we need?
Level 10 humans.
Let me see what level the humans are that I have at least.
I have two.
Level 10 humans.
Do we have to catch them at 10?
Yeah.
Oh, it has to be caught.
I'm gonna go to the beginning.
And just...
Chilina, do I have enough for the lantern?
I lantern, I do.
Ow, fuck.
Ow.
Alright, I got a loot moon.
I wanna craft the lantern.
Wait, what level do you need to be for the lantern?
Um...
No.
Let's see... Level 22.
Okay, cool.
I can get a lantern.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Wait, what dungeon is this one?
Oh wait, has anybody done Bushi yet?
Bushi?
No.
Is he even one of the things?
I'm gonna go attempt it.
Yeah, he is.
Yeah, I'm gonna go attempt it.
Alright, I'm power leveling.
Okay, I saved a lot.
To power level.
I just need...
Oh, I'm all out of arrows.
That probably won't be a problem.
Oh yeah, sure.
You can kill the Mamoswine too.
Cause we need the meat to make a steak.
Yeah.
Okay.
Shit.
Go, Panking, go.
Get him.
Oh my god, my Panking is so small.
Just a little guy.
He's just a little guy.
Don't size shame.
Oh true.
That's fucked up, man.
It's not about the size, it's about the power.
Look at him.
Yeah, but you're size shaming him right now.
He's dominating.
Okay, I'm gonna kill you.
Let's see.
Do we have the five traps for the Lambos yet?
Uh, no.
I was waiting for the ingot to be made.
Oh, okay.
Because our lazy fire Pokemon don't wanna do it.
I can stay in base till the ingots are done.
We need 25 to make the traps.
Cause you need five for trap.
If you're doing bear traps.
Bro, like, you're just walking around.
There's other traps.
Just make another furnace too.
Make another furnace.
Yeah, we can make another furnace.
Yeah, I feel like we could...
We could spend a lot of time.
Okay, level 25.
I need five more levels for my chicken.
Let's see.
Get over here, Lambos.
Alright.
I'm getting the gigosphere ready.
What?
Where's my ball?
Why you coming for me, dude?
No.
No, stay away from me.
Get over here.
I need as many fucking chickens as I can.
I need to be level 30.
I have no arrows, but this is fine.
I don't need arrows.
Chicken nuggies.
Get over here, little cat.
Oh, he's dead.
What?
Why the heck?
Where is she going?
Dude, she's going on an adventure.
What the heck?
She's like five bases away.
What?
Is she okay?
Let her live.
She doesn't want to be with you anymore.
She's finding herself.
Let me help you find your place at the fucking front.
Oh shit.
Have fun.
Literally have one fucking job.
Ryan!
Game.
Traps.
We can just make a... does it have to be a bear trap?
Or can it be a hanging... It has to be a trap.
It just says... Patalia's been caught.
Wait.
Clip, clip, clip!
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip!
Yeah, it's just traps.
Any traps work.
Okay, then we can just make a hanging trap.
We need five of them.
So fifty would...
Bushi has been caught!
Bushi's been caught!
Clip, clip, clip!
Nice.
Alright,
I'm out.
Let's go!
Alright, three in a row.
Alright, Bushi down.
I'm gonna head back to...
base.
And then I'm gonna go to the other dungeon.
How much time do we have?
Forty-eight minutes.
Okay, easy.
I'll go find the entrance.
I'll get those screenshots at 1.2.
Yeah, yeah, we can do that in the last thirty minutes.
I have the reincarnated guy, like...
uh...
marked.
I'm putting these...
spheres in a chest.
Yes, I need them to catch the humans later.
Oh yeah, we need...
Okay, do we have... do we only have like...
two humans?
Because I... like I said, I have two...
Alright, I'm coming back to base and I can check.
I'm fast traveling.
Okay.
I caught a couple as well, but they were low level.
So I just don't count towards that one.
I know that I attacked some, but I don't know if I caught them.
Alright, let me check.
Get over here, you little cat.
Get over here, I'm gonna kill you.
Alright, uh...
The people I have...
I have...
None over ten.
Oh, you're dead.
So you just need three, Lily.
Nice.
I think that's easy.
You just gotta go to the world that has three.
That's really it.
Okay.
I'm gonna kill them too.
Alright, let me make my Vanworm Saddle.
Oh no!
Where is the Vanworm Saddle?
There we go.
Alright, I need ingot.
Fucking ingot!
Okay.
Do you think... Oh, we don't have time to breathe the new...
...anubis anymore though.
But that's a global thing.
We can do that.
That's global.
So we should start at that right now.
We can catch it.
We can start catching the stuff.
Okay.
Uhhh...
Super...
...fair.
Okay.
Alright,
let me see what it takes to do the breeding.
Alright, let me see what it takes to do the breeding.
Stupid penguin.
You think you're strong?
Breeding, breeding, breeding, breeding.
Alright, I am at levels 26.
Four more levels now.
Where's the breeding?
Did you get Fangalope?
Nope.
I don't think Fangalope's in there.
No, it's not.
Oh, it is.
Yeah, it is.
I'm just catching the level 30 for the chicken.
I see it.
It's level 19.
Okay, for the breeding farm, we already have everything we need.
So I'll just make it.
Yeah, just make it for now.
Okay.
I'm gonna put it down in the area with like the trees that we don't usually go down.
No!
Okay.
My bird!
Stop killing them!
Alright, get my Van Worms paddle and then I'm good to go.
And I can go scout.
Yes!
Finally!
Flying mount!
Yay!
Yippee!
Took way longer than it should have.
That was really...
Ugh!
See, I need like...
I'm almost close to...
Oh, my Van Worm's hungry.
Eat.
I can fast travel.
Eat everything I kill.
Oh, hey, creamy.
Okay.
Alright, fast travel...
to the bridge.
And then from there I'll fly.
No!
I almost lodged myself in the air.
Oh, Mountain Stream Grotto though is level 29.
Level 29?
I mean, there's four of us.
Well, I mean, I think it's fine because...
We'll be fine just as long as we dug it down.
As long as Trip 4 here, Trip 4 can like fucking tank everything for us too.
Yeah, it should be fine.
To tank?
Yeah.
Alright.
Go in!
As long as we find the dungeon, we just need to find it.
Okay.
What the heck?
I'm gonna try my luck this way first.
We got this.
This is gonna be easy.
Alright, we caught five lamb bolts.
I'm gonna go catch the humans now.
Nice.
Wait, for the traps?
Yes.
Clip, clip, clip, clip.
Where's our clips and clippers?
I go find the humans.
Okay, we gotta keep going.
More north.
Oh!
Trip 4, kill a Mammoth one.
The stake is 150 points.
Do it, do it, do it.
Is that day one?
Can anyone cook it?
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, what level do we need to cook it?
Any level.
Yeah.
Should it be any level?
Find me a Mammoth.
Um, spawn.
Find you a Mammoth?
There's one in the starting zone.
That one is the boss one.
You just got killed a boss.
I saw a couple near me.
At the start.
Isn't that one a...
No, that's... yeah, that's one of the bosses, so...
I think I know where a couple men are.
I spawned.
I forget the...
Yeah, I've seen some too.
Multiple clips that count towards it.
If I didn't catch them fast enough to make it all just in one clip, I guess.
Sure.
I'm near the waypoint.
Which means there could be a dungeon entrance over here somewhere.
Oh, non-boss one can spawn near the boss.
Okay.
I'm trying to catch these other...
motherfuckers though.
Are you serious?
They're all dead.
That sounds like a lot of guns.
I'm gonna...
God damn it, I'm too strong.
I have a moo-cow for breeding since we need milk.
I found the entrance.
We found the entrance for the dungeon?
Yep.
Oh, okay.
Are we all ready to go?
Let me join because then we can catch the humans in there.
Yeah, we can go.
Actually, there's humans over here and they're level 7.
Oh, okay.
I found a fucking human.
I'm literally surrounded.
I'm heading over now.
The dungeon is still around for another 98 minutes.
Are we all ready to go?
Sheriff, are you ready?
No.
Okay.
Where's the dungeon?
Where I am.
Where's Peepee?
Okay.
Yeah, I can make it then.
Reasonable time.
There's so many humans here.
Whose giga spears is this?
Mine.
Yours now.
Don't say I need those for the high level.
This is mutiny.
Okay, here.
I'm helping you craft them.
Take your... Where are you?
It's done crafting.
I'm killing the Bonjuri alpha.
Okay, it's done crafting.
I'll go make my own.
Fine.
Okay, I have one level 10 human.
How many did we need?
No, they're all dying.
They're being killed by random pals.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, no, he's dead!
Oh, wait, they're not being killed by random pals.
They're being killed by my pals!
Stupid.
Oh, no.
Nice.
You're doing your part.
Let's see what it is.
I can...
What the fuck?
Ben, are we okay?
My game crashed.
There's still more people over here, though.
Somewhere around here.
I have two level 10 humans.
There's like a crap ton of the Pal Alliance devout people.
Wait.
We don't have the clip of the traps.
In the...
In our team thing.
Did we do it?
I thought we really did it.
Oh, okay.
Can we track down that clip?
Oh, they did it.
They just did it.
Thank you.
I called them out and they did it.
Amazing.
Fuck!
Okay.
Well, it's not great.
No, that's not what I wanted.
One of the writers died.
I only caught one.
That's fine.
We just need two more.
The rest isn't high level enough.
Okay, I'm trying to catch this level 22 human.
Oh, no.
He did not want to be caught, I guess.
Wait.
Can someone clip the two humans I caught?
Because we have to compile all of them together.
Do we have a Kingpaka?
I don't think we did.
Yeah, I'm going to catch a Kingpaka.
While we wait then.
Someone...
Can someone clip the two humans I caught?
I don't know where...
Oh, we got to screenshot them in the Pal box.
I just caught a level 22 human.
Can somebody clip that?
Nice.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the Kingpaka?
Where are you?
Kingpaka is near our base.
Yeah, I know.
I flew the wrong way.
Alright, let me see if there are any other humans around.
Uhhhh...
How much time we got left?
Uh, 38.
Okay.
Uhhhh...
I might fly back and put a stop in the incubator.
Bro, have you marked it?
I have some guys in the incubator.
Oh, okay.
I just picked up a large dark.
A huge fire egg and a huge dragon egg in there.
Let's go.
Oh, dragon!
Let's go!
I'm pretty sure it's the fire dragon.
I guess.
Yeah!
That's the best one.
That's literally the best pal.
Fucking black and red Gyarados looking.
Okay, there's more people over here.
There's more human beings over here.
I'm gonna try to catch a couple.
Come on, Van Worm.
You got this.
Oh, shit!
Not the Rush Boar.
Random Rush Boar.
I can catch him though.
Alright, we're just gonna keep throwing balls at him and see if we can catch him.
No!
Wait, is that a...
Oh, he's fucking dead.
Oh, no.
He's a corpse.
Can't catch him.
He's dead.
The wild pals are killing him before we can.
The humans?
Yeah.
That's why you can catch the pals and the human at the same time.
True.
Yeah.
Alright, should I...
Should I come back to base or are we ready to go to the dungeon?
Go back to base because Surefour's not ready yet.
He's doing catching stuff, right?
Sounds good.
I need more hyperspheres.
These are high level mobs.
Tell them to stop taking their Ritalin.
That's how you get hyperspheres.
Come on, Grinto.
Grintoo.
Why is the boss not spawned?
Did someone catch this guy?
Which one?
Fangalope?
You caught him?
No.
Yes, you said you caught a fangalope, didn't you?
It doesn't say on the map that I did.
Oh, I thought you caught him.
Did I catch him?
What does the fangalope look like?
I don't remember.
It's on me on the map.
Oh.
Oh, you have a patalia.
I thought you caught the...
No, I've never even been over there before.
Yay!
I caught the Kingpaka!
We have a bug!
Nice!
Kingpaka, clip it!
Clip, clip, clip!
So, what are we supposed to do?
Are we going to get complimentary points for that?
We skip it for now?
Question mark?
Sometimes he falls through the floor and dies.
Oh, sometimes he just dies.
Okay.
Cool!
I better get half points for trying.
Alright, clip it!
Half points for trying!
That's what I'm saying.
Oh, no.
My game is broken.
Why is it like this?
Okay.
What the heck?
Alright, I made an egg.
I made an egg chest, so if you have eggs, please put them in there.
Alright, yeah, no problem.
Yeah.
Does everyone have a flying pet so we can get to that one island?
Wait, why do we need to go to the island?
Put that mofuckin' hospital because that one place that we need to take a screenshot is an island.
Oh, yeah, yeah, we can.
We can do it the last 20 minutes or something.
We're almost at the last 20 minutes!
Oh, wait, we're okay.
That's okay.
Let's do the dungeon first.
Alright.
I'm on my way.
Okay, I'll go back to the dungeon then.
These guys I need to kill though.
Are you close to a fast travel?
I don't know.
Maybe?
Yeah.
Our pals are hungry.
I think we have no food.
I'm putting food in right now.
Whoops.
Yeah, because none of them were like transporting anything to the thing, so they've run out of food.
Alright.
Big oof.
I'm heading over.
I'm heading over to the base.
Let's go get ready.
We just need Shur for the final fast travel so he can get to us.
Okay.
I just found one.
I'm flying over.
Yeah, I'll just follow.
Okay.
The best fast travel spot is up here at the ancient ruins if you can make it up there.
The bridge is also fine though.
I'm heading over to the base.
We have high level humans here.
How many more do we need?
For humans?
I have one so two more?
Okay.
There's enough here.
No, these are level 3.
Where's the cave?
Head to Peepee.
I'm on her.
Okay.
We're flying over right now.
We killed them all.
Except for this one.
I'm gonna use the wolf.
Actually, the wolf should be faster.
Nice.
Not nice.
Oh, fuck.
Did you guys kill the humans?
Yeah.
There's plenty more.
Look, I can't say that without my lawyer present.
Let's see.
Not comfortable speaking on that issue.
There's a human here.
Nah, I'm not gonna kill it.
The dungeon's right over here.
Yeah, I'm heading over.
Okay.
Oh, there's one more Free Panel Alliance devotee.
I can probably get him, maybe.
Oh, there's a couple.
Actually, there's a couple.
If anybody has the nice spheres, they might have a better chance of getting him.
I'm almost there.
Okay.
Are you close to dungeon?
Yeah, I'm right in front of it.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I caught another one.
Clip it, clip it, clip it, clip it.
He was level 17.
Level 17, so we need two more, right?
Yeah.
Oh, we need one more.
Yeah, one more.
There was one, but I just killed it.
Alright, I'm here.
Wherever you are.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, I'm right here.
Oh, god.
I'm being attacked by everything.
One of my chatters gave us the...
Huh?
One sec.
Your chat needs you.
What did your chat do?
Someone's saying we can just build one of the PAL bases in that area and then just teleport to it, but I don't know.
But we already have two PAL bases.
I mean...
You can just dismantle it.
Anyways, get in the dungeon.
I'm here now.
Are we all here?
I'm going to dungeon.
Wait, I'm not in the dungeon yet.
I need to finish catching this one real quick.
Don't worry.
Wait, what are you trying to catch?
A glider.
There's only one person who needs to go over there.
Where is he going?
He's just...
He's just zooming off.
I guess we're going in.
Alright, ready?
Alright, let's go.
Hope I don't crash.
He's just fucking going.
Don't crash.
Alright, let's go.
We just need one human anyway.
We're flying, right?
Okay.
Is one of us catching the one human?
I have a couple balls, but I probably have the lowest chance.
We still need to catch one human.
Does anyone know which is the boss room for this one?
I don't remember.
Do not remember.
Probably.
I'm trying to catch this motherfucker.
What if I catch it?
Oh, there's bees coming from here.
Don't we need to catch these?
I don't think it's the bees.
We need the little tweens that blow up.
Oh, I have two of them.
We need the queen.
It's not the bee guards, it's the queen.
I think they have what it takes to make a move.
The ping!
It's okay, I got away.
Oh, there's a human.
Okay, it's not to the right.
Okay.
Oh, that's too high a level.
I cannot catch those.
Is it the main?
Straight?
Oh, shit.
Uh, which way did we go?
Usually it's this water path.
Oh, shit.
Okay, it's fine.
Yeah, it's right here.
Okay, cool.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Give me a sec, guys.
Let me catch this.
Alright, take your time.
Give me a sec, I'm trying to catch this bee guard real fast.
Get it, get it.
It's the hot one!
I love her.
I love her!
She's making me listen to them!
She's making me question things.
No one ever listens to the flesh tuber!
I'm sorry, what did you say?
Don't worry about it.
You were saying sorry?
Okay, I'm here.
Let's go.
Are we using Giga?
Does anybody have Giga?
Yeah, surefour has a lot.
Not a lot.
I wish I had a lot.
He has just enough.
Get him.
Alright, he's frozen.
It's a heat.
He's frozen.
But maybe it's a heat.
You never know.
Yeah, maybe.
He's just trying to express himself.
You don't know.
It doesn't say.
There's no male-female sign on there.
I...
I wanted to be a female.
Let your imagination run wild.
There's no laws against Pokemon, Batman.
We're at 30%.
Be careful.
I'm retrieving my pal.
My pal is retrieved.
First try?
Clip, clip, clip.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wanna know what I called Batman?
I called him little punny Batman.
Alright, we got another dungeon.
We should take a photo with our reincarnated guy now.
Since we're all here.
Where do we have to go?
He's not over here.
Get the person.
He's a little sub-tig.
Catch him.
Level 21, too.
You gonna help?
He's freaking running.
This one's gonna get killed.
I can catch him.
I think it went into your ball anyway.
Which is... oh, shit.
It's fine.
I can still try and catch.
I have 35 attempts.
GG.
We have all of it.
Clip, clip, clip.
We have five.
We have five humans.
When do we have to put them in jail?
By tomorrow?
By tomorrow.
It's a global.
Clip, clip, clip.
Do we need more humans?
I don't know actually.
We could get them later.
Let's grab the fast travel.
And then...
And then we do the reincarnated guy photo.
Follow me.
Someone fly to the base and make a base.
And then during that I'll be trying to catch more thangs.
I'll dismantle your base.
You mean dismantle the second base?
You can dismantle it from the map.
I want to dismantle yours.
I just need someone else to fly there while I'm trying to kill the other bosses while I have time.
Oh, okay.
I'm trying to min-max.
You want me to dismantle your base now?
I can dismantle it now.
Sure.
I'm dismantling.
Alright, dismantling now.
The...
The mysterious guy is below the King Paka, right?
Yeah, I can... I'll fly over there now.
Uh...
Let's see.
Should I follow?
Do all four of us need to be there?
All four of us have to be there.
And then...
Like below that is where...
That one base is.
I need to get to level 30.
So after the photo I need to take a picture.
Not after the photo.
I need to like...
Power level to level 30 so my chicken can be level 30.
Is that...
Today or tomorrow?
Today.
I'm only level... I'm like level 28.
I need two more levels.
Uh...
Wait, does it have to be one person?
Technically you took it most of the way.
Can we give it to...
Can we give it to Shure?
And then...
Oh yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna give you the chicken and you can high level the chicken to 30.
Teamwork, teamwork makes teamwork.
Put it in the thing.
Okay, okay.
You start making the fucking ore.
Oh my goodness!
Oh my god!
That's character growth.
Alright, I'm putting it in the box.
You fucking power level the rest of this goddamn chicken.
Yeah.
Where'd you put it?
In the PAL box.
But where in the PAL box?
In the PALs in the base.
But where?
Like where?
Which one is it?
At the bottom.
It's the bottom.
It's the chicken.
There's only the chicken.
It's the one that's high level.
There's 5,000 chickens.
What do you mean?
It's in the...
It's in the working.
No, no, it's the one in the PALs at base.
Yeah, it's working.
That's like...
Yeah.
Dragoons.
Yeah, he'll be at level 30 in like a second then.
Like literally one battle and he'll probably pop up.
Alright, let's go to the reincarnated...
I marked the reincarnated guy.
Just follow me.
Okay.
He is... oh my gosh.
Are we flying there or are we...
No, no, no.
They're at the fast travel.
I'm heading over there.
Okay.
Alright, fast travel.
Oh no, I don't have that one!
Okay, that's alright.
That's alright, I'll just fly there as fast as I can.
Just like...
Alright.
Am I going in the right direction?
Kind of.
Just follow me.
I'm flying.
Everybody.
I'm going as fast as I can.
I don't have that fast travel point.
Oh, I can see it though.
I can see it though.
So it should be easy.
Just follow me and then we can all take a picture.
I found him when I was lost.
And drowning.
Oh, you're talking about pizza guy!
Reincarnated guy, right here.
Okay, okay.
I'm here.
I'm flying.
Pizza guy.
Taking a picture in the dark.
Don't worry, I have my lamp.
I have my lamp.
I swear he's there.
Guys, I swear he's right here.
Trust me.
Trust the process.
Where the fuck is...
Oh, they're here for it.
Okay, we just need...
I'm coming.
I'm at the water.
Alright.
Oh, down on the shore, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I guess we can all get off here.
Don't worry, I have the lamp so he'll be seen on my end.
There we go.
Are we all here?
Yep.
I can't dismount.
Okay, stand next to him.
Alright, screenshot, screenshot.
We're all here.
Screenshot!
Let's go!
Alright, we're done.
Someone fly to the island and make the base.
And I'm gonna try and get more of the big boys.
Who has...
The island where we can take the picture.
The wildlife sanctuary.
Wait, do I do it?
I don't know where that is.
Anyone could do it.
I have to go kill the bosses.
I'll go find the wildlife...
Oh, you guys?
You guys go... There's a picture.
There's a screenshot.
Sanctuary... location...
I don't know where it is so I'm gonna...
I'm gonna look it up.
In the docks it shows where it is.
In the docks?
There's an image.
There is?
Yeah, but... on the map though?
Yeah.
Wait, wildlife sanctuary, isn't that that thing that's off the shore?
I found it.
I know where it is.
It's like that big... that like big circular thing with the little outstretched docks, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, extreme southeast.
Oh, it's... I can literally head there right now.
Okay.
Yeah, it's like very, very southeast.
Do I have enough materials for this?
Uh... rock...
How many materials for a pall box?
Uh, not much.
You need a...
palladium fragment, 8 wood, 3 stone.
8 wood, 3 stone.
Oh, I got it.
There.
We're fine.
I'm heading over now.
Oh, we got the steak on... we got the steak?
We did?
Did you kill the mammoth swine?
Did we cook it?
Did we?
Someone said we already have it.
We have it in the chest.
Oh, shit.
What?
Someone go look, I guess.
I'm flying back.
I'll cook it if we got it.
Oh, no.
We still need it.
Never mind.
We got one guy.
Yeah, find me a mammoth and I'll go kill it.
I went the wrong way.
I keep flying the wrong way.
God damn it.
Mammoth spotting duty.
What the fuck do those suckers spawn?
The mammoths spawn at start.
Easy.
But then there's like another area.
I'm opening up the...
Wait, no, I shouldn't open up the huge dragon egg.
Or the huge scorching egg.
You should get the exp for that.
Coming.
I'm leaving it.
I'm heading over.
We're actually not far from another spawn point of those mammoths.
Ignis, right?
Yup.
Am I heading to the right wildlife sanctuary?
I just wanna know.
What was the scorcher?
Blaze howling gnaw.
Okay, okay.
Am I heading towards the correct one, guys?
Yeah.
So now we can use that to cook, but you'll probably just get stuck on everything.
That's the good one.
The island.
Yeah, probably.
Alright.
You're not wrong.
Uh...
I have no idea where the guy is, but I'm almost there.
How much time we got left?
We have... 20 minutes.
Okay.
Did you get the chicken to level 30 yet, Surefour?
I'm fucking working on it.
Faster!
Do it faster!
Okay.
We just have to...
What else can be done in a really short period of time?
Bosses?
All the bosses.
I'm looking for the Mammal Wreck.
I'm gonna fight the King P.A.K.A.
I'll fight King P.A.K.A.
I did.
I caught King P.A.K.A.
Okay.
Just kidding.
I'm at...
There's a lot of strong pals here.
Okay.
Where?
Criminal activity underway.
What does that mean?
What about the tower boss?
Did anybody fight her yet?
Is that one of the dailies?
Is it?
I don't know.
It's a global.
Okay.
I'm making the pal box.
Is it here?
I'm here.
Am I...
Oh, I'm not supposed...
Is this the Wildlife Sanctuary?
I'm pretty sure you're there.
Is it like a weird...
Do we have to talk to a person?
No.
We just have to take a picture on the island.
Oh, okay.
I'm good.
Yeah.
Come over here.
We can take a picture now.
Alright.
I'm fast traveling.
I did it.
I have to find the fast travel nearby.
Just get the pal box.
No, it's a base.
Just go to base.
Yeah.
It's the base.
We set up a base there.
I'm not near any travel point.
Oh, you're not near any fast travel.
I'm gonna see what else we can do.
Uh...
Criminal activity underway.
We need to capture ten toko tokos.
I have two.
Toko tokos are on the far right side of the map.
Usually.
I mean, if you go to your pal deck, it shows you where they spawn.
Yeah.
I only have... I have two on me, I think.
Or one?
I have one on me.
Only.
I guess I'm gonna try doing the rest of the bosses after this.
The chicken's level 30.
Oh, fuck.
Screenshot!
Clip, clip, clip!
I'm waiting.
Indeed.
Where's...
Lily's coming over.
Almost at the freaking fast travel.
He just need Lily and then we're good.
I'm on my way.
Now I'll go back to Mammoth.
Back to Mammoth's line, I think.
Dude, how is something so big so hard to find?
They're supposed to be everywhere here.
What the fuck?
Are we good?
I'm coming.
Oh, here.
Okay.
Now we're at the island.
Alright.
Screenshot, screenshot.
We're at the island.
Screenshot!
What the fuck?
Screenshot, screenshot!
That's the kids.
They're raiding us here.
We are the herd of wild animals.
Alright.
I'll see you guys later.
I'm gonna go.
I leave.
We got our...
Easy exp.
Easy, easy.
Alright, we got it.
I hope somebody screenshot it.
I left.
I'm gonna do the other bosses now.
Let's see...
Got 17 minutes left.
You got Bushi, right?
You already got Bushi?
Yeah, I got Bushi.
Bushi's done.
Dammit.
Okay.
I'll get the Duma then.
Oh, they're all dead.
Nice.
Okay.
We need to find the fucking map.
Oh my goodness!
It's a dead side.
The cast rate is so high.
Alright, we need one person.
Oh my god.
We need one person to focus on finding a Mammoth Swine for sure.
I'm doing that.
Right now.
Oh my goodness!
Stay in!
Holy shit!
Let me go get the Mammoth.
Okay.
Are we able to fight the level 38?
Mammoth Swine?
I feel like... maybe?
If we do it together, maybe?
All four of us?
It's probably on the list.
Hold on.
It doesn't look like it's on the list.
Yeah, it's not.
Uh...
The meat is quite some points.
Yeah, we still need to stay.
I found a Mammoth Swine.
Oh, you did?
Maybe I can kill it.
We'll find out.
Where is it at?
Okay.
On you, on you.
I don't have anything.
Oh, I've got nothing over there.
Yeah.
I'm trying to set up a new Pal box.
I need to get that easy.
Stupid do-mud.
I dismantled the base, so...
Okay, let me fucking look for this.
Make a new Pal box.
If only I had hyperspheres.
Oh no.
Well, you don't need hyperspheres.
You need to be dead.
We just need steak.
I don't need hyperspheres anyways.
Fair enough.
I hear you.
I'm heading over.
I got it.
What?
You got it?
I got it.
You got the steak?
Cook it, cook it, cook it!
Alright, alright, alright.
I need to find a fast travel.
Or someone could come to me.
Ugh.
That's what I thought.
That's what I thought!
Impossible.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do a little bit of...
Go, Fleshboy, go!
Did someone make a cooking pot or anything?
Yeah, I did.
It's next to the incubator.
Um...
Alright, I'm gonna...
What level?
What's this one?
Did anyone do the...
What's this?
Enter sealed...
Which one is this?
I think there's no fault in this.
No one did the felt bat, right?
Nope.
Okay, I'm doing the felt bat now.
Oh, that's my fucking fist.
Insufficient materials, why?
What are we missing?
Uh...
Uh?
Oh wait, cancel.
Pfft.
Okay.
Pal team is hungry.
You can't be hungry right now!
Oh, they're hungry!
I'm going to them.
I'll feed them.
No, my pal.
No, no, my fucking pal is hungry.
Oh, your pal?
Yeah, the one that's trying to...
Nope.
Uh...
Mammoth steak.
Yes.
Clip, clip, clip!
Well, it's not cooked.
Oh, okay.
Someone has to make it get kindled.
I'll go ahead and get it done.
I can make it get kindled.
I'm at base.
Okay.
No!
Keep it alone!
Okay, what else is something?
We have 12 minutes.
What else is something we can focus on?
Um...
Just like doing the bosses.
I don't think I'm high level enough to do bosses.
I've been doing so much farming.
I'm only 19.
I think like...
We could focus on like our base for tomorrow.
Like leveling up the bases for tomorrow.
Yeah.
There's a fucking raid?
Oh, we're being raided?
Shadow Legends.
But I think our pals can probably handle it.
I believe in him.
We're in like a pretty low level area, so...
Please don't kill me.
I'm so scared.
Let me snack some quick XP.
Oh!
Mammoth steak!
Oh wait, let me grab a kindling guy.
Kindling guy.
Come here.
Stop fighting.
I don't care about these guys.
Holy shit.
I suddenly care about these guys.
I do care.
I care very much.
Holy shit.
Jesus.
Alright, well...
Cool.
Thanks.
Please catch him.
Alright.
Alright, Van Worm, you're gonna do kindling.
And get the steak done on time.
No!
Please!
Armor is damaged.
Pal is hungry.
There's so many things wrong!
There you go.
No!
Please!
He's leaving alone!
Oh shit.
Toko.
I can get started on the toko toko toko.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get toko.
Where are they on the map?
There's two different locations.
There's one area that spawns them that's in this lower level area.
But it's unreliable.
And then if you go to the desert, then you can get a lot of them.
But it's level 25, so I don't know.
Oh shit.
Yeah, I can't do desert.
There is a lower level area around here though.
Guys, if anybody can get to me, there is a fell bed!
I'm right out of PAL balls!
Alright, hold on, hold on, hold on.
I will bring you... Oh shit.
I can't bring you.
There's no balls here.
No!
All I have are the regular balls!
I'm dead!
No!
I died!
Oh, you're so sad.
That's okay.
We can remedy that.
I thought I had enough PAL balls to do this.
Do we need more PAL balls?
Do we have to craft some?
Wait, do we get the steak shit yet?
Steak is being cooked.
How many do we have to cook?
Just one?
Just one.
That's 100 points.
It's taking a while to cook, but it's halfway done.
Okay.
I need PAL balls.
I've got my actual PAL on it, so it's more reliable.
Can I grab... Yeah, I need those PAL balls.
Yeah, grab them.
It's done.
Clip, clip, clip!
Clip, clip, clip.
We have one done one.
Clip, clip, clip...
I think you have to clip Shy's, because by the time I walked over, there was nothing on there.
Put it in the thing so I can just clip you opening the chest.
Okay, true, true, true.
What do we...
What do we need left other than the bosses?
We have three minutes left.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna try and catch this in three minutes.
Yeah, yeah, because we have to report...
We have eight minutes yet.
Why was the five minute report stuff?
Here, chat.
We can clip this.
MemRestate, right there.
There you go.
Oh, okay, okay, we have eight minutes.
Okay.
What other stuff are we missing?
Trefo, have you done anything that hasn't been clipped yet?
I mean, I've clipped a bunch of stuff, but I haven't submitted anything.
I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
What have you not submitted?
I don't know.
I just asked them to clip, and then I move on.
What is it?
What did you do?
Fuck it, they're in the clips.
I don't know what to tell you, man.
But what does it mean?
Oh my god, the kill him again?
Okay.
Thought I didn't have to.
Okay, I'm gonna see if I can do this again.
I'm gonna make more powballs, just in case.
Just kidding.
No, I'm not.
We don't need fucking it.
I think I can do this in seven.
There's no way.
I'm trying to do as much as I can in the small amount of time I have.
What is your mission right now?
Fucking killing the bosses.
What do you think, man?
How many bosses have you done?
Fucking like six, seven.
Oh shit.
Did we even clip seven of Shareforce's bosses?
They're in the clips.
Can we see what the clips after still?
No, no.
We have to report them while...
When to report them.
Mods, if you can check Shareforce clips.
And see what has been clipped.
And match it to anything that we've done.
That'd be great.
We need to make sure we got everything.
That'd be great, thanks.
Oh my god.
Please leave me alone.
Alright.
Where are you at?
Oh, you're way out there.
Nevermind.
Good luck.
Godspeed.
No way.
Yeah, I'm really far.
I'm gonna get some lift monk statues.
Just keep making some...
Do all of us...
If we all get the lift monk statues, if we all get to level 10, like tomorrow, say.
Do all of us need to or just one person?
It's per player.
Per person.
Okay.
Please kill him.
Please don't kill him.
Dameron, please.
Woo!
Please.
Oh, clip, clip, clip!
I got the...
Let's go!
I got the bat.
Okay.
I can do like...
I can do one more boss, I think.
I don't think I... I don't need to care about my armor.
I don't think I need to kill it.
Don't worry about it.
Okay, I can get the doom mud.
The doom mud is like right here.
We need to start submitting.
Yeah.
If we haven't already been submitting...
Well, I think...
There's a time frame where you can just submit.
Okay, okay.
I think my mods have probably been submitting the whole time.
Thank you, mods.
Okay.
Big appreciate.
No!
The fuck hit me?
Where the fuck is doom mud?
Oh my god.
There's too many trees.
At least have this fast travel.
Okay, one toko toko.
Doom mud.
Oh my goodness, what is that catch rate?
Just stay in!
It's 30%!
You did like 12 balls and won 30% catch rate toko toko.
What do you mean wrong way?
I don't know where I am!
Just toko toko things.
Okay, I only have six balls left.
Make them count, I guess.
East!
I'm heading east!
Wrong island!
I went on the wrong island.
I'm a fat ass bird.
Apparently I went on the wrong island.
No!
Do you think I can fight this alfederate?
Do I even have balls?
No, I should.
Wait, no, we already fought him, didn't we?
Which one?
Alfedrine.
I don't think so.
Oh, for real?
But I probably can't catch it.
I only have normal ass pal balls.
Shit.
That fucking sucks.
Four minutes?
No way.
I can catch the doom mud.
The doom mud is my last hope.
I can kill him.
We'll try.
What's the worst that could happen?
I only have four minutes.
Let's see if I can catch him with my normal ass pal ball.
What's the worst that could happen?
Oh, my van worm could die.
That could happen.
Why are you hungry?
Uh...
Uh oh.
Uh oh, he's targeting me.
No!
Okay, well I'm dead, but that's okay.
I don't have the balls to catch the freaking tokotoko, man.
You got this, Lily!
I believe in you!
I have the balls!
We need like eight more!
The three balls!
It's gonna count!
Make those three balls worth it!
Alright.
Alright, I'm gonna go back.
I need to at least get my stuff so I start tomorrow with my stuff.
Bruh!
We didn't have any balls!
Okay.
We can make some balls now.
It's not gonna matter though.
I got the worst sect.
I don't know how many bosses I got.
Out of time.
Alright.
You got Pyrexec?
I got Worsec.
Clip, clip, clip!
Alright, hopefully someone submitted the clips.
I don't know.
Thanks, Moz!
We'll find out, I guess.
It's okay.
Get over here!
The last ten points right here!
Let's go!
Go!
I get a free pal while I'm fucking min-maxing?
Yeah, it was too hard.
It was worth a try.
I wanted those tokotokotokos.
But then I had to use like five...
...trazillion balls on one.
Please, please, no.
That's a lot of balls.
That is at least two balls.
I got two more clips!
I got two more!
Nice!
We got MVP!
Okay, how many minutes do I have left?
Like none.
Oh, one minute.
I got the one we needed.
Here we got the one ten.
The one ten pointer.
I've never even seen a fucking one fourteen.
Alright, do we have everything that ShoreFloor got though?
I think so.
Maybe.
Can we double check?
Because we can report stuff.
That's it.
Double check everything.
Let me check the channel.
What clips we got.
Because we have five minutes to report everything.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
We have the steak.
Yep, steak.
Photos.
We already reported the chicken.
The level 30 chicken.
My mods said they think they got most, but maybe we should run down the list.
Yeah, run down everything.
ShoreFloor, do you remember how many you've caught?
Can you like name it off?
You can also just look at the pile box and then...
Be like, hey, find this clip.
Ding ding.
I got the...
Broncherry Aqua.
The Fangalope was bugged.
Relaxed Source Lux.
Beacon.
And Petelia.
And Warsec.
So I got one, two, three...
Four, five.
Okay.
And then you got the chicken to level 30?
I would have gotten six if the Fangalope wasn't bugged.
Did you get the...
Did we clip the chicken already?
I took a screenshot.
Uhhhh...
Oh, they missed Aqua.
Okay, they missed the Aqua.
Uhhhh...
Did you get the chicken?
Oh, they said they haven't gotten the chicken to 30 screenshot yet.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I got to post it in the screenshot.
I think this is the screenshot.
See level 34 chicken right there.
Level 32.
Did they report that we have all the humans?
Like once we put them all together?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you got that.
So we got the fun achievements.
We got the level 12 base.
Yeah.
Is it in there?
Wait, did we take a photo of level 12 base?
I don't think we did.
I don't think so.
Oh no, we did, we did, we did.
Level 12 base.
I caught the Chilit, the Sweetpea, the Gumas, the Dumut, the Peaking, the Azirobe.
Let's see.
Uh, Azirobe, Penking, Quiverne, uh, Kingpaka, the Felbat, and the, yeah.
That's all the bosses I took out.
And I have two shinies.
The Fwock and the Lamba.
Because we have like the shiny thing, right?
Yeah, we have two shinies.
We got two shinies.
Oh, and then, well we have our registered pals.
How many pals do we have registered?
Uh, let me see.
Isn't that a global event?
Or is that per day?
Well, it's global, but doesn't that add it up?
Doesn't it add up to us?
I mean, we can just look at the very end of the event, because all you do is look at your pal deck and see registered.
I have, uh...
I have 41.
I have 39 registered.
Are we doing the...
Is it the encountered?
Or is it the registered?
It's registered.
Okay, 30.
I have 39 registered.
Okay, 21 registered.
Nice!
Uh...
21...
39 registered.
I don't know if it's like... does it count to...
Uh...
Okay, what's my statue of power?
I didn't even check.
I didn't even level it up.
Okay, I managed to get three tokotokos.
We don't have by chance... I have four.
No, we didn't.
We don't.
Level...
two... uh... power...
Oh, points per player is zero.
Okay, never mind.
Uhhhh...
Wait, did the lift monk matter today or tomorrow?
That's tomorrow.
That's global.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
And we can still do day one and day two.
And on the day where you're still...
Yeah, and tomorrow the EXP multiplier is gonna be 20.
Yeah.
So...
Uh...
It's gonna be kinda wild.
Let's see...
The only thing... so we did...
Yeah, did we... did we...
report all the ones we captured?
Oh, logout?
Oh, I forgot to logout.
Whoops.
Oh.
Logout.
Oh shit, we have to...
Yeah.
Logout.
Thanks.
Thanks for the reminder.
Wait, did the mod cut...
Did the mod cut all of it?
Did the mod cut all of our palace that we captured?
Chillsweet Ghumas Dumad, Pen King Azurobe Grintail Broncherry, right?
We got Broncherry.
Cimpaka, Bushy, Quivirn Fellbat Yeah.
Uh...
What else?
Battalia Broncherry Aqua.
You got both Broncherrys?
Just Broncherry Aqua, I'm pretty sure.
Oh, just Broncherry, okay.
Broncherry, Aqua, Warsec Relaxasaurus.
Is that Overlord?
Relaxasaur.
At... who's our mod?
What's the mod's name?
At Overlord.
Did you get all of them?
Did you close the server?
I logged out.
I don't know if that closes it or not.
I think we have everything.
The server.
We need Gumos clip?
Guys, where's the Gumos clip?
Which one is Gumos?
Gumos clip.
I didn't do Gumos.
I did.
Uhhhh...
Well, I had a screenshot of Gumos.
If you have a screenshot, that should be enough.
Someone has a Gumos clip.
There you go.
If you can put it in the chat.
Nice.
Yeah.
Alright, that should be everything, right?
Okay.
We...
Now we die.
Now we...
Okay, now we're done.
That's all five minutes.
That's it.
I just saw my mod DM.
It's got like 200 messages.
Mod, how could you not get the Gumos clip?
I worked so hard on getting that Gumos.
We got all the fun achievements.
Yeah.
We did.
We're having fun.
Except for the Toko's.
But that was on mute.
Yeah.
The dev enough balls.
What placement did we get in the end?
Guys.
For day one.
Are they still calculating?
I think they're still calculating.
Yeah, we sent stuff for so long.
Are they still calculating?
Yeah.
Well, at least now though.
Now we know what the achievements are.
So we can strategize for how we want to start day two.
Yeah.
And like what the plan is.
We're on 10th place right now.
Alright, that's how much money.
That's not bad.
I don't know if they're like finished calculating though.
That's the thing.
I don't know if they finished calculating.
Alright, that is...
Hey, that's $187.
Let's go.
Ay-yo.
Ay-y.
The ranking also includes global points.
Not last.
Let's fucking go.
Ay-y.
We broke top 10.
Let's go top 10.
Top 10.
We still have time.
Well, how are we going to do tomorrow?
I can finish the day one.
I can finish like all the day one EZs.
Okay.
And then Shore4 can work on the other day ones that we missed.
Let's see.
Alright.
Day two, cook a mozzarella cheeseburger.
I think we already have the stuff for that.
We don't have any of our registered pals in yet.
So that's not in the scoring either.
Yeah.
I think looking at how many points we get for tomorrow, we should probably do...
We should probably do the leftover only if we have nothing better to do.
Because we only get half points for the day one.
And day two gives like already five times more baseline for similar difficulty for some of them.
So it seems kind of like what we might want to do is we might want to just do whatever we can to power level Shore to level 50.
So we can get a pal up to level 50.
And then we can take on...
Power level is just catching pals.
Yeah.
Just making balls.
I think I'll just make a ton of balls.
Because like we've been struggling all day.
Yeah.
We need balls.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think I'll just stick around in base and make sure they actually work.
And make balls.
Let me check on all of the...
I'll like make a list after this of all the materials that we need to get to base level 20.
Yeah.
Like just in total.
Because we're going to have to have probably sure make all of the items.
Because they're going to start getting into the high level stuff.
But I will check and see what we need.
I'm sure we're going to start needing things like...
Like coal and stuff.
So...
All right.
Yeah.
So...
Okay.
Legendary pal.
Take a photo with a lift monk energy inside the volcano.
Okay.
Easy.
Get a photo of the top of the Asher Mountains.
Second wildlife sanctuary.
Easy.
Third wildlife sanctuary.
We can get that in the last hour.
I feel like the photos.
Yeah.
Easy.
We just have one person build bases and stuff.
Yeah.
So...
The strat worked well.
Because then one can just stay back and make balls.
Yeah.
And they have like no waypoints.
But it doesn't matter.
Because we can just teleport to base.
We need a rush hour hot dog.
A rush hour hot dog.
So we need to kill one of those.
And then a mozzarella cheeseburger.
I think...
I'm going to see what's in a mozzarella cheeseburger.
Okay.
Because we already have a whole bunch of milk.
So I think we already might be able to do it.
Yeah.
We have tons of milk.
I think like...
Oh, that's right.
My Z key doesn't work anymore.
Sure.
For you need to get to level 50.
Okay.
That should be fine on the multiplier as long as balls.
Yeah.
You need level 50.
Because you need to get power to level 50.
Or you can catch it.
But just catch it.
It's hot on the balls.
And the mozzarella cheeseburger...
Honestly, the level should be fine.
Requires...
Oh, we need an electric kitchen.
That's the problem.
We have all this stuff for it.
But we need to be level 41.
Yeah.
But sure for...
Sure for getting the power level fast.
Uh-huh.
And I guess like I can...
I'll start power leveling as well.
So I can help out with catching the balls.
Yeah.
And then I can help out with the stronger powers like the Verdasch, Memorus and the Velet.
And then sure for can work on the hard ones.
Yeah.
I'll probably keep management of inventory.
And then once the base is at level 20, I'll just go back.
We need the breeding too.
We need to work on the breeding stuff as well.
Yeah.
Yep.
Okay.
I think you just do base management.
I'll just craft balls.
Okay.
The base management, a lot of it is going to be just making sure we have enough stuff.
And then once we do, being like, okay, come back.
Sure.
So, all right.
Come back crafting.
Yeah.
Come back.
Please make this.
Thank you.
All right.
Yeah.
Breeding.
Okay.
Figure that out.
I'll take breeding and base management for tomorrow.
Sounds good.
I'll take balls and the materials we spent on the balls.
I'll help capturing.
I guess cooking too because cooking is also just base management.
Our only soft cap is really ingots.
Yeah.
Apparently we can get 700.
I've seen a fine with it.
We can get 700 points for petting.
Huh?
Nice.
We can get 700 points if we find... but we need to catch every type though.
There's so many.
We probably already do have every type though.
We need water, grass, dark, ice, earth, fire, electric dragon.
The hardest one is dragon and we have dragon.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
So, we're good.
We're good already.
Let's see.
I'm just checking.
They didn't count our chicken.
We worked so hard on the chicken.
What do you mean?
They didn't count our chicken.
Why not?
They're telling me about my fangalope being bugged.
I can't believe it.
Wait, why didn't the chicken count?
What the heck?
When it says patting different pals of the same element, does that mean that we need to have four of the same element pal in the same screenshot?
Maybe.
Because that's what it looks like in the photo.
The attached photo.
I guess all four of us.
Yeah, all four of us pet like different ones.
Okay, so we need four dragons.
Yeah.
But isn't the flying wavern thing, isn't that one a dragon?
We're all teammates are paying different pals of the same element.
So we just need to make sure we're all petting the same one.
Okay.
Oh, all right.
I love stroking pals.
Different pals of the same element.
I got pals all over my shit.
Yay.
I guess that's it, right?
I think.
I think so.
Until tomorrow.
Yeah, until tomorrow.
And then we fucking grind our shit out.
Grind it.
All right.
We got 10 plays.
Let's go.
Day one.
10 plays.
Not bad.
Top 10.
I think we're hot.
We're hot.
Trust the process.
I think we're higher too because we don't have our pokey deck points.
Yeah.
Trust the process.
It's 4 fucking AM.
I'mma bounce.
Bruh.
Go sleep.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Head to bed.
You guys have pictures?
Oh wait.
They want pictures of the registered pals.
Oh.
I have to log back in though.
Look at my pal deck.
Oh.
I would have to log back in.
Okay.
No.
We must have looked at our pal deck, right?
I can just log in real quick.
Oh.
I mean on stream.
Yeah.
They said they want...
Oh yeah.
You just got a picture from your stream.
I think I'm covering the pal deck on stream.
No.
Let me check my...
Wait.
Am I allowed to log back in for that or no?
I don't think so.
No.
We can't.
I think we have it on our stream.
Do you guys have a clip?
Guys?
Do you guys have clips?
I mean I said it out loud but there's no rewind on Twitch.
I mean I could easily be like, I have it.
I have 200 pal.
That's not how it works.
It's global so it doesn't matter, right?
We can get it tomorrow.
It's just a...
It's a global one.
Yeah.
It's a global point.
Okay.
But if it means we get like nine...
I guess...
Okay.
We're not gonna get like seventh place.
Nevermind.
I'm gonna say...
Wait.
What happens if you're in the top whatever?
Top what?
What do you mean?
Yeah.
Does it matter right now?
I mean it means like...
Or you said does it matter if we're seventh place or whatever?
If we get to seventh place, we're 10th place currently.
So like if we could get to seventh place, we just get more money.
On day one?
Yeah.
On day one.
Oh shit.
Let me check the wallet if you can see the registered palts.
But I'm pretty sure I'm covering...
I think it's like in the bottom left corner, isn't it?
When you open the paldex.
I think I'm covering it.
I have no idea.
I mean if we're allowed to log in real quick, I can check but...
When we're opening the fucking paldex.
Yeah.
I wish I could just open it.
Oh my god.
Can we ping a mod and just ask them if we can open it?
Yeah, you can.
Alright, I'm just gonna ping a mod.
Because I don't think any of us had that.
Yeah, I know I have 39.
I like showed it on my end.
That we have 39.
Yeah, I'm covering it with my model and you can't fucking see it on stream.
Oh no.
I haven't opened but you can't see.
That's so unlucky.
I got my 41.
Wait, who has the clip?
Does anyone have the clip of my 39?
Does anybody have a clip of my 32?
Does anyone have a clip of that?
What do you mean me too?
If I was a facecam streamer, I would cover it too.
It's the same position.
What do you mean?
I mean, you could have put it on the other side.
I guess.
I guess so.
Yeah.
Okay.
I got it.
Yeah.
I only looked at it one time really briefly.
It's mine.
Apparently they're still calculating scores.
We're 11 not who the fuck?
How?
What the fuck?
How are we 11?
What happened?
What did I do?
Because they showed their registered pals.
Oh, they said no.
No.
Okay.
Well...
Team Burn found eight lucky pals.
What the fuck?
They found eight?
Wait.
Did we show our lucky pals?
Ma, did you show my lucky pals?
Yeah, we have two.
It counts as two.
Yeah.
I don't know if the Ma showed it though.
Ma, I worked so hard.
I swear to God.
I worked incredibly hard.
Did we put the lucky pals in here?
Yeah, they did.
They did.
They got one.
They got what?
Oh, they got two.
Thank God.
Okay.
I worked so hard capturing this.
Try and find the clip of yours registered.
My mods are scrubbing the VOD.
Shy Lily is not available.
What?
Your registered pals are not available.
Damn it.
You can kind of...
If you know where it is in the UI, you can see it.
Wait.
You know what you can do?
Oh, wait.
That's right.
You were in front of it.
For mine, I could just stop the stream right now.
It'll create a VOD and then they can grab it.
Yeah.
Do it.
Do that.
I'm going to stop the stream for one second, Huan.
Hold the line.
Wait.
I have the...
I have the VOD.
Like, it's...
I have live VOD.
Oh, wait.
They got it.
They got...
Someone got it.
You're...
Oh, she already stopped her stream.
Yes.
You can...
Oh, shit.
You can see the 21.
You can...
If you go into the VOD...
Okay.
I'm making a clip.
If you go here...
You can still have the sense of the bot while you're streaming?
What?
I didn't know that.
You can see it says 21.
It's just...
You just don't see that it says caption...
But you know that's the UI.
You know it's there.
Just post it.
Fuck it.
We ball.
It technically...
All right.
Post it.
It technically counts.
It counts.
Let me get it.
Dude, wild.
Thanks, mods.
Well, I'm going to go.
I need to go to the washroom.
Okay.
All right.
Cheat cheese.
See you guys tomorrow.
See you.
All right.
Are we all good?
I think so.
I'll come up with a plan for tomorrow.
Are we all good now?
I think so.
Just double-checking.
I am on base cooking and breeding.
Yeah, I'm just gonna power level and help.
I'm just gonna help.
I'm power leveling and helping Sherifor with capturing pals.
I evolved into a tradwife over this stream.
I'm just gonna take care of the house and the kids.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck are they finding like... where are they find... we're playing like Twitch plays some random maze right now.
Where are they finding like placements?
Bro.
How do they know what the placements are?
Wait, did we drop again?
No.
No, don't tell me that.
I don't wanna hear it.
I just wanna pretend to be top 10.
I'm almost top 10.
That's almost like top 10.
Nice level 10 points.
Wait, wait.
It could be 10 points.
Wait, no.
It's like... it's still calculating.
It should have count.
Yeah.
Wait, but like does it count or... I'll peek at it from behind the hair.
Yes, you can see.
I'm moving around and you can see it peek through.
Give us 10 points.
You can tell it's a 21.
Yeah.
Come on.
You know it says... it says capture.
You know that's...
You know I say.
No.
Give us those 10 points.
You know it's there.
Don't be weird, bot.
I'm watching the clip.
I'm watching the clip back.
It might be more towards the end.
You can clearly see it's a 21.
It says 21.
You can clearly see it.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
You can definitely see it.
Yeah.
I'm seeing.
Bro.
Screenshot of it.
We literally... Okay.
If we count it, we can see it.
Yeah.
We got all our... If we count our pal register points, that's like 30 points.
And then we'll be back to top 10.
Okay, fine.
Oh.
I got it.
I fucking got it.
Okay.
I got it.
Here you go.
Yeah.
Let's go.
21.
Chicken dinner.
Can you do some for me?
Come on.
I need to know.
I need to know our registered pal.
Wait.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna show...
I'm gonna show chat how fucking clutch this is.
Wait.
Let me save...
Bro.
Let me save the actual video.
I'm just gonna save the video.
This is wild.
Bro.
We have more achievements than the two people who are 9th and 10th.
It's fucked up, man.
We just don't have enough pal registered.
No.
It's our pal registered.
We did so many pal registrations.
We did so many achievements.
Fuck.
I hit the button.
All right.
I'll show you.
All right, chat.
This is what we were working with.
It's cause...
Look at it.
It's right there.
Someone's like, I'm confused how the team is in 10th place and a heavy.
It's cause of pal registered.
It's actually pal registered.
Here it is.
Yes.
All right.
Watch.
We're gonna see that 21.
Oh.
Come on.
Take us to top 10.
There it is.
Come on.
There's the 21.
Clutch.
Absolutely clutch.
Oh my God.
Come on.
Clutch.
Just change it.
Am I 10?
We're 10th again?
Are we 10th place again?
We're 10th.
We're 10th again?
Are we?
No, it's not.
I'm looking at the achievement list.
No.
We are.
We're 10th.
Yeah.
Let's go.
We did it.
We're in top 10.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Finally.
Top 10.
We're better than six other teams.
Nice.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
We did it.
We fucking did it.
GG.
I'm gonna...
Top 10.
I think the last 30 minutes, we should drop pals to each other so we can make sure we all have registered pals.
Yeah.
Mm-mm.
Well, wait a minute, I have a question though.
And maybe chat can answer this.
I'm pretty sure if you drop pals, does it register or does it not register?
Do you actually have to catch it?
No.
You just get bonus for catching.
You just have to drop pals and then...
Wait, you can't register from dropping pals?
Really?
There's not...
Oh, no.
Okay, I got lied to.
I got one guy earlier.
Missed opportunity right there.
I got...
I got one guy earlier.
All right.
We have to...
We're 20th place.
Stop at the 11th again?
Who keeps... I refreshed it.
How?
Somebody forgot to log off.
Stop.
No, they're like fucking around.
They're fucking around right now.
They're like... ridiculous.
It's like every time you refresh, it's different.
I don't understand.
Every time you refresh, it's like the placement is changing.
The doc is being weird right now.
All done, thanks guys.
What do you mean all done, thanks guys?
What do you mean?
Stop it!
I don't understand.
Why does it keep changing?
It says we're top 10.
There's no way.
Are we top 10 anymore?
Oh my god, we were 20 points away from...
No!
From 9th place.
What?
We were 20 points away from 9th place.
We're like 20 points away?
Yeah.
We were that close.
Dude, yeah, the registered pals really fucked us, didn't it?
Yeah.
You know what though?
We're still pretty high.
We're pretty high though.
We got so many achievements.
Yeah.
We did well despite struggling.
We had like the lowest amount of lucky pals though.
We just did not have luck.
I mean, I found that I was the only one that had lucky pals.
Yeah.
We're traveling far and wide, man.
They just don't show up.
No, what do you mean?
I literally went to a fast travel and it showed up right beside me.
It was like waiting for you.
Yeah, it says we're in 10th now again.
Yeah!
I'm on the actual one, not the viewer one.
It says we're 10 and it says they're done.
So I guess we're in 10th.
Yeah!
Top 10!
You know I take those.
I take top 10.
Yeah, let's go.
Top 10.
GG's guys.
I had a great time.
Wait.
How does the team above us have 20 more points than us when they're registered pals?
I think our total is zero.
That must be a glitch.
They might have like... wait, you're right.
What?
Yeah.
Honestly, maybe they call it the hard ones.
Like the... you know, like the pals at the bottom.
Wait, but doesn't that just mean that tomorrow they're gonna show their registered pals and then they're just gonna yeet themselves into first?
Sky and Rocket.
Yeah.
I don't fucking know.
Alright.
GG's guys.
I'm gonna go talk to my chat.
GG's.
I had a great time from day one.
GG's everyone.
GG's.
Thanks.
See you guys tomorrow.
GG's.
Those four hours passed by so fast.
Yeah, so fast.
So much fun.
Yeah.
Alright.
See ya.
Bye.
Alright.
Wow.
That was really fun.
I hope you guys had a great time.
I hope you guys had a great time with Shy Lily, Pee Pee, and Surefour.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
We were fucking gaming.
To be fair, we were a bit scum.
We had no plan.
Okay?
We had zero plan and we got top ten.
That's all that matters.
No plan, top ten.
Let's fucking go.
But it's thank you all for the subs.
Thank you all for the subs.
The gifted subs.
For following and all of that on Twitch.
Thank you guys so much.
And the biddies!
Thank you guys.
I had a great time with all of you.
I mean, we streamed for four hours.
Holy fuck.
Those four hours were intense.
But I'm gonna call it here.
Because I wanna make sure I have enough energy for tomorrow.
Because it's gonna be another four hour day.
But thank you everybody.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
For those who are new here, I usually stream on the YouTubes.
So please check me out on YouTube.
I think like, exclamation point YouTube.
You can subscribe to me there.
Sometimes I stream Twitch stuff like today because it was Twitch Rivals.
And if you wanna get more updates on when I stream on Twitch.
Please check me out on Twitter.
I don't know if exclamation point Twitter works.
And merch!
Merch!
You're gonna support me via other ways!
There is merch!
Exclamation point merch!
I will be putting up Lunar New Year merch.
I think like, I'll have an announcement later.
On like Saturday.
Or like, Monday or Sunday.
I think like Lunar New Year merch is gonna come up on Saturday or Sunday.
Anyway, I had an amazing time with all of you guys.
And I hope you guys had an amazing time with my team and everything.
Thank you all for coming.
As always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everyone.
Bye guys!
Bye!